FOR COMING THIS MORNING AND
WELCOME TO THE HEARING OF THE
SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE ON GAS
ELECTRIC AND TRANSPORTATION
SAFETY UNDER THE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
STANDING COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY
SENATOR BEN HUESO. TODAY WE
CONVENE TRIP TO DISCUSS THE
PROACTIVE DE ENERGIES ATION OF
POWER LINES OF PROCESS IS WE
KNOW HAS BEEN CALLED THAT THE
S. P. S. FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF. I RECOGNIZE THE
ENORMOUS CHALLENGES THE STATE
FACES WITH P. S. P. S. IT'S A
TOOL WITH CONSEQUENCES IF WE
USE IT AND AS WE KNOW
CONSEQUENCES IF WE DON'T. BUT
IT IS A WILD FIRE MITIGATION
TOOL THAT CAN BE UTILIZED
IMMEDIATELY. WHILE OTHER
MITIGATION MEASURES ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED. THIS THAT IS SO
WHY I SUPPORTED P. GENIES
DECISION LAST OCTOBER TO DE
ENERGIZED PORTIONS OF THE NORTH
BAY AND THIS YEAR IT'S-
FOLLOWING THE EVENT P. JEANNIE
DISCOVERED DOZENS OF INSTANCES
OF WIND RELATED DAMAGE. TO
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE PRESUMABLY
PREVENTING DOZENS OF WILDFIRES
I KNOW SUCH A DECISION WAS NOT
WITHOUT CONSEQUENCES. CUSTOMERS
LOST BUSINESS THOSE DEPENDENT
ON ELECTRICITY FOR MEDICAL
NEEDS FACED DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN THE STATE MUST MAXIMIZE
PUBLIC SAFETY DURING SUCH
EVENTS WE ARE CURRENTLY IN A P.
S. P. S. REGENE. UTILITIES HAVE
THE AUTHORITY UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW TO DE ENERGIZED. WE MUST
ENSURE THEY DO SO WITH MANY
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE AND TO DO
SO EFFECTIVELY. WE'LL TAKE THE
SUPPORT OF NOT ONLY THE
UTILITIES AND STATE REGULATORS
BUT ALSO THE COMMUNITIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT THAT WE
ALL SERVE IN CALIFORNIA SELECT.
TO WRITE MY COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WITH THIS AND ASK IF THEY HAVE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS. SENATOR
DOT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY
THE ISSUE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT OFFICES BEEN A
PRIORITY OF MINE. SINCE AWHILE
FIRES BROKE OUT NOW BUT SNOW
BUT COUNTIES IN THE AUTOMOTIVE.
SEVENTEEN AFTER THOSE FIRES
WERE BROUGHT UNDER CONTROL I
WAS BESIEGED BY CONSTITUENT
CHOIR HE'S ASKING WHETHER P.
JEANNIE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PROACTIVE IN DE ENERGIZING
THEIR POWER LINES IN THE FACE
OF FIERCE WIND EVENTS WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE RECONVENE THE IN
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
IS THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF SB
NOT A ONE REQUIRE A UTILITIES
TO IN. OUR MITIGATION PLANS
PROTOCOLS DETAILING HOW THEY
WOULD HANDLE THE ENERGIES ATION
OF POWER LINES INTO THIS
EBELING OF RE CLOSER. SINCE THE
ENACTMENT OF SB NINE A ONE WE
PAID GREATER SCRUTINY TO PUBLIC
SAFETY POWERSHOT OFFICE IN OF
COME TO REALIZE IT DE ENERGIZED
THE ENERGIES STATION CARRIES
RISK OF ITS OWN WHICH MUST BE
ADDRESSED BY THE UTILITIES IN
DEVELOPING THEIR DE ENERGIES
ASIAN PROTOCOLS. ONE OF THOSE
RESCUE SHUTTING OFF POWERS TO
CUSTOMERS WHO RELY ON LIFE
SUPPORT EQUIPMENT THAT RUNS ON
ELECTRICITY. THIS YEAR I'M
OFFERING SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
DIRECTING THE UTILITIES TO
ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR RISK IN
THEIR MITIGATION PLANS THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS HE SAID
SHOULD LEARN MORE FROM THE
UTILITIES AND THE CPUC. HOW
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
ARE BEING ADMINISTERED AND
MONITORED. I'M PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN GAINING MORE
UNDERSTANDING ON ADVANCE NOTICE
HOW THAT ALL WORKS HOW SOON
POWER CAN BE RESTORED AFTER PSP
PSP'S. P. S. P. S. WHETHER
UTILITIES OUT STAFFED UP TO
EFFECTUATE RAPID RESTORATION
HOW UTILITIES ARE WORKING WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRST
RESPONDERS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY OFFICIALS AND OTHERS TO
DEVELOP MEANS TO MAINTAIN POWER
TO ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ONCE
AGAIN THE STREETS ARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING. THANK
YOU SENATOR THE SENATOR WINNER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO'S GOING TO. UP TO
SIX. I HAVE TO SAY I AM. DEEPLY
DEEPLY CONCERNED. WITH THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE NOW
ALLOWING. PGA ANY ANOTHER
UTILITIES TO ENGAGE IN OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
WITH NOT NEARLY ENOUGH OUR
GUARD RAILS AND OVERSIGHT I IN
PLACE. AND I THINK WE ARE
CREATED A REGIMEWHERE THE
UTILITIES HAVE EVERY FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE TO ENGAGE AND- ARE ON
THE SIDE OF SHUTTING DOWN POWER.
TO DO TO ENGAGE IN TOO MANY
POWER SHUT OFF ON THAT SIDE IN
ORDER TO AVOID LIABILITY. AND
TO MAKE THEM BROADER THAN DAY
PERHAPS NEED TO BE. BECAUSE THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE FOR THE
UTILITIES IS TO AVOID LIABILITY.
BUT THE COSTS OF THESE POWER
SHUT OFFS ARE MASSIVE. WHETHER
IT IS A SMALL CITY THAT HAS
BEEN POWER DOWN OR WHETHER AS
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD IT COULD BE
THE ENTIRE CITY OF SAN JOSE OR
SAN FRANCISCO GETTING POWER
DOWN IF THAT'S WHAT HE'S YOU
NEED BESIDES IS NECESSARY
WHETHER IT'S FOR ITS PERCEPTION
OF SAFETY. FOR ITS OWN.
AVOIDANCE OF LIABILITY BECAUSE
THE GRID IS IN SUCH POOR SHAPE
BECAUSE IT HASN'T OF P. GINNY
HAS NOT MAINTAINED THAT ARE
PROPERLY. TO SCRIPT PROPERLY.
IT'S WITH WIRES PROPERLY IT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPERLY NOW AND
AS A RESULT A HUGE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES COULD BE LEFT
HOLDING THE BAG I'M PAYING THE
PRICE AND THE COSTS ARE REAL
WHEN POWER IS SHUT OFF WE KNOW
ABOUT HOSPITALS AND NURSING
HOMES AND SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. RESIDENTS ARE
VULNERABLE INSTITUTIONS WE KNOW.
WHAT THE MASSIVE PROBLEMS ARE
THERE BUT IT GOES SO MUCH
DEEPER I'VE BEEN NOT. I WAS
JUST CONTACT THE LAST WEEK BY A
BUSINESS IN MY DISTRICT I WAS
INFORMED BY THEIR INSURANCE
COMPANY I THAT IF THEY
EXPERIENCE A POWER SHUT OFF IN
HUGE FINANCIAL LOSSES. THEIR
INSURANCE WILL NOT COVER IT
BECAUSE SINCE THEY GOT TWENTY
FOUR MAYBE FORTY EIGHT HOURS
NOTICE IT'S NOT A SIDE AND AN
UNPREDICTABLE. EVENTS IT IS A
PLAN SHUT DOWN AND SO THE DAY
WILL SUSTAIN MASSIVE FINANCIAL
LOSSES TENSELY PUTTING THEM OUT
OF BUSINESS AND THEY WILL NOT
HAVE INSURANCE COVERAGE. FOR IT
I AND AS I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S NO RECOURSE AGAINST P.
GINNY FOR DOING. AND I THINK IF
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A SYSTEM
OF FINANCIAL INCENTIVES. FOR P.
GINNY IT SHOULDN'T JUST BE
WE'RE GOING TO ERR ON THE SIDE
OF POWER SHUT OFFS. BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO AVOID LIABILITY
THERE HAS TO BE. A FINANCIAL
CONSEQUENCE ON THE OTHER SIDE
AS WELL IT IS NOT FAIR TO
REPAIRS IT'S NOT FAIR TO
BUSINESSES IT'S NOT FAIR TO THE
MANY INDIVIDUALS WHOSE LIVES.
WILL BE DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED.
BY POTENTIALLY VERY BROAD VERY
DANGEROUS AND VERY SUSTAINED
OUR POWER SHUTDOWNS. SO I'M
JUST BEING VERY VERY BLUNT
HERE. BECAUSE I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SYSTEM THAT
WE SET UP I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW THESE DECISIONS ARE MADE.
WHO IS MAKING THESE DECISIONS I
HELD UNILATERAL IS IT. I'VE
BEEN TOLD THAT IT'S SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF P. GINNY CAN MAKE
THAT DECISION DO A MASSIVE
POWER SHUT OFF BUT THAT'S WRONG
I WON HERE. HI HOW THAT'S WRONG
I AND I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT THE OVERSIGHT OF
THE SHUTDOWNS AND HOW WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A TRULY.
BALANCED APPROACH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNERS
SENATOR BRADFORD. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE HAVING THIS HEARING
AND I'M NOT HERE TO BASH ANY
PARTICULAR UTILITY BECAUSE- OUR
SHOT SHOT OFF ARE NOTHING NEW I
WORK FOR UTILITY COMPANY AND WE
RETURN ROUTINELY HAD. OUR WHAT
WE CALL A BLACKOUT FOR MISTER
REASON TO EVEN DURING THE
ENERGY CRISIS. IT WAS
COORDINATED OUTAGES SO
COORDINATED OUR AGES ARE
NOTHING NEW AND I THINK MANY
TIMES WE OVER REACT YES WE HAVE
TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE A
BREAST OF WITH A DOING WHAT
WILDFIRES IN HOW DO WE
MITIGATED IF IT'S CALLS BY
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT- THE MERE
FACT OF NEEDING TO SHUT OFF
POWER. IS OF. GREAT CONCERN BUT
IT SHOULDN'T BE TO THE LEVEL
THAT. I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
NEW I ARE YOU SEE UTILITIES
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
DECADES. BASED ON WHATEVER THAT.
YES EVEN TO IMPROVE THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE SOMETIMES YOU
YOU BRING DOWN AN ENTIRE GRITS
NOW WHAT WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED WITH AND WHICH EVER
UTILITIES ALWAYS CONCERNED WITH
IS YOUR MEDICAL BASELINE
CUSTOMERS AND MAKING SURE WE
KNOW WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED
BEFORE WE BRING THEIR POWER
DOWN IN MEDICAL BASS LINE. IS
ALWAYS A GREAT CRITERIA AND IN
A UTILITIES LOOK AT THAT.
BEFORE OFF. MANY POWER IS CUT
OFF AND WERE HOSPITAL
FACILITIES ARE AS WELL MAKING
SURE THAT THEY HAVE. BACKUP
GENERATION AS FAR EVEN OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY SO. THOSE THINGS
ARE CLEARLY COORDINATED IS NOT
SOME RANDOM ACT JUST SHUTTING
OFF POWER SO IT'S GREAT
CONSIDERATION GONE. THAT GOES
INTO THIS BUT I APPRECIATED
HEARING BECAUSE IT'S A LOT WE
CAN LEARN AND NOW. MANY WAYS WE
CAN IMPROVE THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD TO. THE MORNING
CENTERS KERN SURE. THANK YOU
MISTER SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU HOLDING
THIS HEARING TODAY AND DIGGING
DEEPER. YOU KNOW WE JUST GOT
BURNT DOWN IN THE TWENTY SEVEN
DISTRICTS. WITH WOLSEY AND- THE
ENERGY IS ATION THERE'S IS
STILL IN RETROSPECT DISCUSSIONS
OF. WAS IT USED AGGRESSIVELY
ENOUGH WAS THERE TOO MUCH
HESITATION. THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
TENSIONS IN EVERY COMMUNITY
AROUND. POWERING DOWN. AND THE
BALANCE I THINK WE WERE TRYING
TO STRIKE HERE IS HOW TO. GIVE
UTILITIES THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY SAFE AND
THAT WE DON'T SPARK FIRES
DURING EXTREME INCIDENTS. BUT
HAVE SOME KIND OF PLAN. SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE STAFF
REPORTS ANALYSIS AND I GOTTA
TELL YA I'M I AM. NOT SATISFIED
I DO NOT FIND IT TO BE WELL
COORDINATED MITIGATION%
STRATEGIES FOR DEALING WITH P.
S. P. S. IN THIS STATE. IT'S
NOT UP TO SAY LIKE HAVE A GO
BAG AND GOOD LUCK. OR GO FIND A
COOLING CENTERS. IF YOU'RE A
NURSING ASSISTANT FACILITY
WHICH ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
FEDERAL REGULATIONS DON'T HAVE
OFSHE POD AND- BACKUP
GENERATION REQUIREMENTS AND
YOU. YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE ANYONE
SIGNED UP TO AN OPT IN MEDICAL
BASELINE. YOU'RE SITTING THERE
WITH A RESPIRATOR AND YOUR
POWER GOES DOWN WHAT HAPPENED.
EVERY WATER DISTRICT IN THE
STATE I'VE NOT SEEN A
RESILIENCY FRAMEWORK COME OUT
TO BACK UP THEIR PUMPING
STATIONS STOPLIGHTS CELL TOWERS
THE TELECOM INDUSTRY ONLY RIGHT
NOW I THINK HAS TO BACK UP FOR
ABOUT FOUR HOURS. THEN SHOW UP
WITH COWS AND- OTHER CELL
TOWERS ON WHEELS OR MOBILE
GENERATION RESPONSE AFTERWARDS
IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH. SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR FROM THE
GOVERNOR MUCH APPRECIATED FOR
BACKUP POWER SYSTEMS NOT GOOD
ENOUGH. NOT EVEN CLOSE THE
DEMAND SOME OPEN HERE TODAY WE
CAN SORT OF START TO GET OUR
HEADS AROUND EIGHTY. WHAT IS A
MAP OF VULNERABILITY REALLY
LOOK LIKE. HOW CAN WE ACTUALLY
ANALYZE WHAT THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ARE AND
HAVE COMPREHENSIVE DATA NOT
JUST AN I. O. U. TERRITORY. BUT
IN. AND COUNTY IS AN INTEGRATED.
SO THE CALLOW YES IS WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND IF YOU SEE ANY I'LL USE THE
PO USING THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THAT WE TRULY KNOW WHERE PEOPLE
ARE. AND WHAT WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO HAVE GO DOWN. IT STARTS WITH
THAT MAP AND THAT DATA SET AND
SECOND WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT IT
AND WHAT ASSETS DO WE HAVE TO
DEPLOY IN THOSE AREAS TO MANAGE
THEM YES IT IS ABOUT
AUTOMATICALLY CLOSERS IN
GETTING YOUR GRID TIGHTER. AS A
YOU CAN SORT OF RING FENCE YOUR
YOUR POWER DOWNS BUT IT IS ALSO
GONNA BE ABOUT DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION IN THOSE AREAS.
MICROGRAM IN SOME PLACES SOLAR
STORAGE IN SOME PLACES FUEL
CELLS AND OTHER PLACES BUT I
DON'T THINK THROWING A BUNCH A
DIESEL GENERATORS AROUND IS
JUST GONNA SOLVE THIS I WAS
RUNNING CONVOYS OF FUEL DOWN
THE BLOCK PACIFIC COAST
HIGHWAY. IN A YOU KNOW TRYING
TO PUT A CARGO NET OVER A
PICKUP TRUCK FULL OF LIGHT. YOU
KNOW GETTING FUEL OUT OF SANTA
MONICA BECAUSE IT WAS ALL SHUT
DOWN AND NOW THAN TO PAYING I'D
LIKE. JUST SO WE GET THE URGENT
CARE CENTER BACK ONLINE BECAUSE
MY FRIEND DID STEPPED ON A NAIL.
I WAS TRYING TO GET A
TECHNICIAN OUT AND SOME RELIEF
LIKE THAT'S NOT AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PLAN IN A NEAR BY.
SOME REALLY APPRECIATE MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT YOU TOOK THIS ON
TODAY I KNOW WE'VE GOT SEVERAL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION PENDING.
FROM GOOD SENATOR DODD WORKING
ON MEDICAL BASELINE SIDE ON THE
D. OUR SIDE FROM SENATOR
WIENER. I KNOW THERE'S OTHER
VEHICLES IN THE ASSEMBLY BUT I
TRULY THINK WE'VE GOT ACT.
BEFORE THE END OF THIS SESSION
ON THIS ISSUE AND HOPEFULLY
TODAY SHED SOME LIGHT. THANK
YOU SENATOR STERN I APPRECIATE
THAT IT AND IT YOU CAN SEE THE
PASSION IN FEEL IT IN THE ROOM.
A REAL CONCERN AMONG US. ALL OF
US HERE AND OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE LEGISLATURE THAT THIS BE
DONE AND DONE RIGHT AND THAT'S
WHY WILL BE EXAMINING. REALLY
HOW TO BALANCE THOSE COMPETING
FORCES WHEN SENATOR WIENER
MENTIONED THAT. YOU KNOW IT'S
THE UTILITIES ROLE TO REALLY
YOU KNOW MINIMIZE THEIR
LIABILITY AS BEST AS POSSIBLE
BUT IT'S OURS IN THE C. P. UC'S
ROLE. TO MAXIMIZE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND THAT'S THE GOAL HOW WE
BALANCE THAT IT IS CRITICAL.
AND HOW WE MINIMIZE WERE
ESTABLISHED THE PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE TO. ALLOW FOR OR THAT
WOULD TRIGGER THAT. YES PS
OPPORTUNITY AND WHAT THE
STANDARDS WILL BE AND HOW
THEY'LL BE DEVELOP THAT'S WHAT
I HOPE WE CAN DEVELOP AND GET
THAT INFORMATION TODAY ANOTHER
A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE
OF OUR PANELISTS AND I KNOW
THEY HAVE SOME GOOD VALUABLE
COMMENTS TO MAKE SURE WILL
BEGIN WITH THAT AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN BE AS CONCISE AS
POSSIBLE WITH OUR QUESTIONS AND
I'LL TRY AND DO MY BEST WITH
THAT AS WELL AND WITH OUR
ANSWERS TO SO WE CAN GET AS
MUCH INFORMATION IMPARTED TODAY
AS POSSIBLE SO. WE DID INVITE
THE C. P. U. C. O. YES AND CAL
I SO TO DISCUSS THEIR WORK
ENSURING PS PS EVENTS AND ALSO
WE'VE AS P. JEANNIE THE UTILITY
THIS NEWEST TO THIS P. S. PH.
YES SPACE TO UPDATE. THIS UP.
ON THEIR EFFORT TODAY SO WE
WILL BEGIN AND- OF. SO IT WITH
THE SIR TO THIS SERENA YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY INTHE TO ANSWERING
IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND
STAKEHOLDER AFFAIRS FOR THE-
CALIFORNIA. INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR WELCOME THANK YOU
SENATOR HELL. GOOD MORNING AND
GOOD MORNING TO ALL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AS SENATOR HILL
MENTIONED MY NAME IS JOANNE
SERENA I AM AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR.
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS WITH YOU
TODAY THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SET OF PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF THE
EYES SO. BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
THE CALIFORNIA I SO IS AN
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR IN
A NON PROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
COPPER CORPORATION. OUR PRIMARY
MISSION IS TO ENSURE SAFE AND
RELIABLE OPERATIONS OF THE FULL
COLLECTOR SYSTEM 480% OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND A SMALL
PART OF NEVADA'S GRID. WHEN I
REFER TO THE BOOK ELECTRIC
SYSTEM I'M TALKING ABOUT OUR
TRANSMISSION LINE SYSTEM WHICH
IS TRANSMISSION LINE LEVEL AND
EQUIPMENT GREATER THAN A
HUNDRED KILOVOLT VOLTAGE LEVELS.
TODAY I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE OUR ROLE IN A
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
EVENT. WHEN THE DECISION BY ONE
OF THE UTILITIES TO DE
ENERGIZED ELECTRICAL LINES IS
MADE ESPECIALLY IN EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITIONS AND TO
REDUCE WILD FIRE RISK. AS THE
GRID OPERATOR OF THE BILL
COLLECTORS SYSTEM WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR KEEPING THE
ENERGY FLOWING RELIABLY ACROSS
THE GRID ULTIMATELY KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON IN THE POWER ON FOR
ALL CUSTOMERS. TO THAT END WE
ARE CONSTANTLY MONITORING THE
OUR CONTROL CENTER TWENTY FOUR
BY SEVEN THE STATUS OF THE GRID
AND ALWAYS PREPARING FOR THE
POTENTIAL LOSS OF GENERATION OR
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH IS OUR NORMAL COURSE OF
DAY TODAY'S DUTY. UNDER THE AYE
ESOS TRANSMISSION CONTROL
AGREEMENTS THAT WE HAVE WITH
EACH TRANSMISSION OWNER THE
TRANSMISSION OWNER MAY TAKE
FACILITIES OUT OF SERVICE
WITHOUT THE EYES SAYS APPROVAL.
FOR PERSONAL SAFETY OR IMMINENT
POTENTIAL DAMAGE TO FACILITIES.
ALSO AS YOU MENTIONED SENATOR
HILL UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
UTILITIES HAVE GENERALIST
ALREADY TO SHUT OFF ELECTRIC
POWER PRIMARILY FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY. THEREFORE IN THE EVENT
OF EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS
AND WILD FIRE MITIGATION
UTILITIES MAY DECIDE TO
PROACTIVELY DE ENERGIZED BOTH
AT THE DISTRIBUTION LEVEL OR
PERHAPS AT THE TRANSMISSION
LINE LEVEL AS WELL. IN THE CASE
OF A PROACTIVE DE ENERGY THE
ENERGY STATION AT THE
DISTRIBUTION LEVEL THE UTILITY
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DIRECT
LOAD MANAGEMENT. IN THAT CASE
THE I. SO WOULD SIMPLY MONITOR
OVERALL CONDITIONS AND ENSURE
CONTINUED RELIABILITY RELIABLE
OPERATIONS OF THE GRID. WHEN
THEY ARE ANTICIPATING DE ENERGY
STATION AT THE TRANSMISSION
LINE LEVEL I SO WOULD BE IN
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH THE
UTILITY AND AS WITH ANY
TRANSMISSION LINE OUTAGE WE
WOULD EVALUATE ALL THE IMPACTS
IN THAT PARTICULAR SITUATION WE
WOULD DETERMINE MITIGATION
MEASURES THAT MAY BE TAKEN AND
WILL COORDINATE WITH THE
UTILITY TO ACCOMMODATE THEIR
DECISION TO DE ENERGIZED THE
LINE. NOW IN TERMS OF
NOTIFICATION IN THE EVENT OF A
P. S. P. S. EVENT WE ANTICIPATE
EARLY WARNING OF UP TO SEVENTY
TWO HOURS SO THAT WE CAN ASSESS
THE IMPACTS. ONCE AN ASSESSMENT
IS DONE WE WOULD COORDINATE
WITH THE UTILITY AND IN SOME
CASES THE PLAN MAY CHANGE BASED
ON THE RESULTS OF THAT
ASSESSMENT TO A BREAK BASED ON
THAT. IMPACT OUR STUDY IMPACT.
IN TERMS OF COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE EYES
SO IT'S STAKEHOLDERS AND ALL
THE UTILITIES WE LEVERAGE OUR
CURRENT PROCEDURES TO NOTIFY
THE PUBLIC ABOUT TRANSMISSION
EMERGENCIES. AND IF NECESSARY
WE DO HAVE TOOLS SUCH AS FLEXO
LURKS WHICH WE WOULD ISSUE TO
CALL. FOR PUBLIC CONSERVATION
TO HELP WITH LOAD MANAGEMENT IN
POTENTIAL AFFECTED AREAS. AS
WITH ALL TRANSMISSION RELATED
EMERGENCIES THE EYES SO WILL
COMMUNICATE WITH ALL ITS MARKET
PARTICIPANTS AND IT
STAKEHOLDERS IF THERE ARE
OPERATIONAL IMPACTS THAT ARE
CAUSED. BY A P. S. P. S. TYPE
OF AN EVENT. WE ALSO HAVE
STANDARD COMMUNICATION
PROTOCOLS TO NOTIFY HELLO YES
THE CPC OTHER REGULATORY
AGENCIES AS WELL AS GOVERNMENT
POINTS OF CONTACTS WHEN THE
BRAT AN ESCALATION OF AN EVENT
WARRANTS IT. IN SUMMARY THE ISO
IS PREPARED TO SUPPORT
UTILITIES PS PS PROGRAMS I
WORKING IN CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH THE UTILITIES AND ALL OF
THE OTHER AGENCIES AND OUR
CUSTOMERS. TAKE THE P. S. P. S.
RELATED TRANSMISSION OUTAGES
WHILE MAINTAINING RELIABILITY
OF ELECTRIC SYSTEM. I THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME OF
THE DETAILS OF OUR ROLE AND I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IN A WAY WE DO HAVE
QUESTIONS AND I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THEM WITH THE AND WITH JUST ONE
QUICK QUESTION WELL YOU.
MENTIONED THE ABILITY THAT YOU
HAVE. AND WHEN YOU SEE IT AT AM
DISTRIBUTION YES P. S. THAT'S
ONE THING BUT A TRANSMISSION
CREECH CERTAINLY OTHER
CHALLENGES IN EXPECTATIONS OF
ON THE PART OF THE UTILITY AS
WELL AS THE GREAT ITSELF. YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MOVE OUR
AROUND TO CREATE CERTAIN
REDUNDANCIES PERHAPS THE
UTILITY DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO OR WOULD THEY
HAVE THAT THAT OPTION TO DO WE
WOULD WORK IN COORDINATION WITH
THE UTILITY TO MOVE THE POWER
AROUND AND UTILIZE OTHER
TRANSMISSION LINES WERE
NECESSARY SO THAT WOULD ALL BE
IN COORDINATION. WITH THE US
AND UTILITIES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THERE ARE MORE QUESTIONS
FOR THAT WILL FOLLOW. THAT NOW
WE WIL MOVE ON TO ELIZAVETA
NOW CHANCHAL DEPUTY EXECUTIVE.
DIRECTOR OF SAFETY IN
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD MORNING. I'M GOING TO
START OFF BY TALKING A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE HISTORY OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION OF THE CPC'S
ENGAGEMENTS IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF THE S. P.
S. OF PROGRAMS THE BEGINNING OF
THIS PROGRAMS WAS IT WILL SEND
YOU GAS AND ELECTRIC THAT
SEVERAL YEARS AGO SUBMITTED AN
APPLICATION TO THE PC. FOR
APPROVAL OF THE YEAR IT'S UNIT
IS THE XIN L. PROGRAM TO
PREVENT WILDFIRES WHEN THE
COMMISSION EXAMINED THAT
APPLICATION TO DETERMINE THE.
UNDER THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE
ALREADY HAD. THE AUTHORITY TO
SHUT OFF POWER TO THEIR LINES
IF THEY BELIEVE THAT THE COULD
NOT OPERATE THEM SEE PHILLY IT
IS A FUNDAMENTAL REQUIREMENTS
OF THE UTILITIES OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE THAT THEY RUN
THEIR SYSTEMS SAFELY AND S. AS
AN OPERATOR THEY CAN ALL DO SO
FOR ANY REASON. THERE ARE
ALLOWED TO SHUT THE POWER OFF.
HOME SO THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL
PREMISE OF THE WHICH WE OPERATE
IS THAT IT IS THE UTILITIES.
RESPONSIBILITY TO RUN THE
SYSTEM SAFELY AND AS AN
OPERATOR THE HOW OF THE FIRST
HAND KNOWLEDGE IN THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THEREFORE
ALL. THE IN CITY THAT MAKE THE
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER TO
CONTINUE OPERATING THEIR
FACILITIES FOR ANY PARTICULAR
REASON TO SHUT THEM OFF. THE
IDEA BEHIND THIS IS SHUTTING
OFF POWER FOR RECEIVE TO REASON
IS REALLY NOT THE EXCLUSIVE TO
WILDFIRE THREATS. OF THE
CLOSEST OF THE PAYROLL ALL AND
DRAW ON IT IS A UTILITIES YOU
ENERGIZING UNDERGROUND
FACILITIES WHEN THERE'S A
THREAT OF FLOODING. AND MOST
NOTABLY CON EDISON DE
ENERGIZING THE LINES HE HAD ALL
OF SANDEEP. HOME TO PROTECT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN MANHATTAN ALL
WHICH ACTUALLY BECAUSE THE HERE
CITY WIDE OUTAGE I BELIEVE AT
THAT TIME. BEFORE THE STORM
ACTUALLY HIT THEM THIS EDITED
FOR. ECEIVING THE ELECTRIC
GRID THERE SO IT DOES HELP IN
ANOTHER CONTEXT OF WHERE IT IS
THE DIFFERENT WHAT'S REALLY
BECOME DIFFERENT THE LAST FEW
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA. IS THE
EXTENDS ALL THREATS OF THAT
WE'RE FACING WILL OF THE WILD
FIRE OUT CONDITIONS AND HOW THE
UTILITIES HELP RIO VALLEY
WAITED THEIR OPERATIONS IN
RESPONSE TO THAT SNEAKING THE
P. S. P. S. PROGRAMS LARGER
PARTS OF THEIR OPERATIONS AFTER
THE- THE- PRIOR TO TWENTY.
SEVENTEEN LOOK FOR YOUR SEASON
ONLY IS JEANNIE HOW ODD L. A.
B. AN OPERATIONAL PROGRAM FOR
PROACTIVELY SHUTTING OFF THEIR
LINES. EVEN AT THAT POINT THE
WEREN'T ACTUALLY ACTIVELY USING
AT THE THAT A LOT OF WORK TO
SET IT UP BUT THE ONLY HAD A
COUPLE OF EVENTS IN THE WERE
RELATIVELY MINOR. ALL P.
JEANNIE DID NOT HELP SUCH
PROGRAM AND SO IN CALIFORNIA
EDISON ON THE KEYS AND DID YOU
ENERGIZE THEIR LINES. BUT IT
WASN'T REALLY POOR IT'S OVER
THE SYSTEMATIC PROGRAM WAS
OPERATIONAL. DECISION THAT THEY
MADE US. REALLY A COUPLE OF
TIMES HELP PRIOR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN GOT THE SOME
CALIFORNIA DISCIPLINE P. G.
NEED TO RE EVALUATE THEIR
OPERATIONS AND THE NEW TO FIGHT
AIDS THE COMMISSION THEN THE
PUBLIC THAT THEY WERE IN
SENDING TO MAKE PROACTIVE OUR
SHUTTLE FOR BIG PARTS OF THE
PREVENTIVE MEASURES IN RESPONSE
THE COMMISSION ISSUED A
RESOLUTION DIRECTING OF HE
JEANNIE AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON TO FOLLOW. THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE PUT ON
AS THE G. NEED FOR THAT PROGRAM
NOTABLY FOCUSING ON
COMMUNICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES THAT
RESOLUTION DIRECTED UTILITIES
TO MEET WITH OF COMMUNITIES
THERE ARE IMPACT AND THAT COULD
BE IMPACTED BY THEIR DO YOU NEW
JERSEY SOME PROGRAMS AND WORK
WELL WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
FIRST RESPONDERS TO ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES. THAT ROAMS ALL OF.
MEETING WITH THAT THE AND
NOTICES THAT THE UTILITY
STARTED HAVING REALLY ELEVATED
ELM THE THESE PROGRAMS IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN FOR A LOT OF
MORE ATTENTION TO THEM THAT L.
A. THINK WAS PREVIOUSLY HAD
UNLESS ISRAEL. AND THE WILL TO
THIS THING I WOULD SAY
CATEGORIES OF PROBLEMS THAT
BECAME PARENTS ABOUT SLIME ONE
WAS THE IMPACT ON OF VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND THOSE SCHOOL
OR- YELP MEDICALLY DEPENDENCE
ON. ELECTRICITY AND TO THE
IMPACT OF THE FIRST RESPONDERS.
ALL ME AND ILL. THE ONE FROM
FROM SHOT OFF AND IN RESPONSE
TO THE COMMISSION CONVENE
SEVERAL WORKSHOPS TO EXAMINE
THESE ISSUES FURTHER AN OPEN
RULE MAKING L. TOOL CONTINUE
EXAMINING OUT THESE PROGRAMS
AND FINDING WAYS TO MAKE THE
WORK BETTER WE ALSO ALL
PARTNERED WITH CAL WE US TO THE
OPERATIONALIZE OF PROCESS SEES
SLOW FOR PS PS PROGRAMS HOME
AND CONTINUED TO WORK WITH
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW. EL TO MAKE ELM. THE
RUN BETTER I WOULD SAY THAT IN
TERMS ALL OF. LESSONS LEARNED
IS I THINK WE'RE ALL
COLLECTIVELY REALIZING JUST HOW
COMPLEX THIS ISSUE IS AND HOW
IMPORTANCE ELM. WE THIS YEAR.
THERE ARE HOUSES ACTUALLY WE IN
MANY SHUTTLE FROM FENCE YET THE
ONLY ONE WHO HAD WAS IN THE
EARLIER THIS SUMMER WITH P.
JEANNIE BUT WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
NOTICES OF FROM UTILITIES
ACTIVATING SPECTRALLY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON OF THE AS
THEY'RE STANDING UP THEIR
PROGRAM AND ONE THING THAT
WE'RE LEARNING FROM THAT IS
THAT SHORT OF AN ACTUAL UNIT
JERSEY XIN OF AND JUST LOSE
NOTICES IN ACTIVISION'S HOW OF
ALL THE MAJOR IMPACT BOOTH ON
CITIZENS WHO ARE GETTING THESE
NOTICES AND MEETING TO MAKE
DECISIONS AS TO HOW TO PREPARE
FOR THE HOME BUT ALSO AND THE
FIRST RESPONDER COMMUNITY AND.
ON POLICE TO THE SUCH. AS.
HELLO THE TRY TO BE PREPARED
FOR AN EVENT THAT MAY BE COMING
AND THEN WHEN THE NOTHING
HEALTH IS THAT IN THAT SOLVE
HOUSE A PRETTY MAJOR. IMPACT
THE VERY REAL COSTS. ELAM WE
ARE CONTINUING TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY ON THESE ISSUES THAT
ARE COMING UP AND LEARN FROM
WHAT'S CURRENTLY NOT WORKING IN
THESE PROPHECIES TO MAKE THEM
WORK MORE EFFICIENTLY. HOME I
WILL. AND WAY TALKING A LITTLE
BIT OF WHAT I HOPE TO SEE IN
THE FUTURE AND ONE IS THAT IT'S
A YOU THINK THE SITUATION THAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS A LOT OF
ACCEPTABLE IN LOTS OF THE
NOBLE. OF THAT WE HAVE TO FIND
A BETTER WAY OF DEALING WITH
WILD FIRE THREATS AND- L.
INCLUDING THE ROLE THAT THE
LOVE PS PS PROGRAMS PLAY. L.
OVER LONG TERM THE UTILITIES
SUBMITTED THAT THE WELFARE
MITIGATION PLANS THAT THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO SERVE IT OUT TO THE
COMMISSION. THAT HALL OF
VARIOUS EFFORTS AND HE TOLD AND
ALMOST HOW UTILITIES OR ARE
PLANNING TO SYSTEMATICALLY
REDUCE OF WELL AT THE RISK OF
WILDFIRE THREAT FROM THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND BUILD
INCREASING INFRASTRUCTURE
RESILIENCE OF THE TWO WEEKS TO
GO THERE AND ILL REDUCING HE
CHANCE OF IGNITION IS A GOOD
PORTION OF THAT SO WHETHER IT
IS CORRECTING. HELP MAINTENANCE
DEFICIENCIES. HISTORICALLY OR
USING COATED IN SO CONDUCTORS
IN HI FI A THREAT ZONES OR EVEN
ON THE GROUNDING PORTIONS OF
THE SYSTEM THERE ARE LONG TERM
PRESS UP PLANS OF HOW TO MAKE.
THE SYSTEM ITSELF WHAT THE LESS
LIKELY TO FORK OUT WHILE OUT
FIRES AND THAT THOSE EFFORTS
OVER TIME SHOULD REDUCE. THE
NEED TO FOR THE UTILITIES TO
SHUT OFF POWER. THE SECOND AREA
IS TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OF MY
ALL SHUTTING OFF A PARTICULAR
LINE. CURRENTLY LEADS RELEASE
OF THE FOR THE SYSTEM DESIGNS
THE SAN DIEGO SYSTEMS A LOT
MORE NETWORK THEM WHAT THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO DO IS TO BE
QUITE SURGICAL WHEN THERE'S
READING OFF A SPECIFIC LINE IN
MINIMIZING THE IMPACT OF THE
CUSTOMERS LOSS OF LOAD THAT
THAT ACTUALLY HOUSE. SO SOMEONE
MMHM SOME OF THE. THE IS SHUT
OFF ADVANCEMENT SING DIEGO. THE
LARGELY REASON FOR THAT IS THE
ACTUAL SYSTEM DESIGN WHERE THE
THIS THE P. GENIES SAID THE
SYSTEM IS RADIO VERSUS NETWORK
LIKE WE HAVE IN THIS D. G. NEED
TERRITORY. IT'S ELEMENT SINCE
IT DID SIX VERY LONG TIME A LOT
OF INVESTMENTS TO REDESIGN THE
GRANTED BUT IT'S WELCOME THE
GENIE IS SO AND OTHER UTILITIES
ARE ALSO MAKING INVESTMENTS. IN
THAT AREA SO THAT WOULD. OVER
TIME REDUCE THE IMPACT OF
SHUTTING OFF SPECIFIC LINES
THAT MIGHT BE RISKY. ELEMENT
AND THEN L. WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
OVERTIME GET BETTER IN TERMS OF
I'LL RISK ASSESSMENT AND
ABILITY TO PREDICT OF THE RISK
OF WILDFIRES IN THE VERY
SPECIFIC ELM. AND IT'S A VERY
DEEP THE LEVEL OF GRANULARITY
AND NOT AS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THAT
THE RED FLAG WARNING SYSTEM IS
IT TOO HIGH A LEVEL FOR
UTILITIES TO OPERATIONALIZE.
THE V. IN THAT THOUGH SOLVING
THIS ISSUE BY DEPLOYING WEATHER
STATIONS ON THEIR CIRCUITS ELM
AND GETTING MUCH MORE PRECISE
INFORMATION. ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
WHERE THE FACILITIES ARE THE
CHALLENGE WITH THAT RIGHT NOW
IS THAT THERE'S NO SINGLE
THREATS IN BACKS THAT UNITES.
EVERYBODY WHO RESPONDS TO
WILDFIRE. KING ABOUT IT WELL
THAT SHOULD EASE SOME OF THE
CONFUSION THAT RIGHT NOW TAKES
PLACE WHEN THE UTILITIES
COMMUNICATING ABOUT A POTENTIAL
ALL SHOT OFF AND THE WILDFIRE
THROUGHOUT THE THERE YOU ARE
HOME. ASSESSING AND THEN LASTLY
WITH COMMENTS ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME UP AROUND OTH
THE IMPACT OF LOSS OF POWER IN
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND ON
THE FIRST RESPONDERS. AND THE
TO PAYING TO CANYON IS THE IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF OVAT WHERE IN
THE SITUATION WHERE THEY LOSE
POWER. ELEMENT THE REALLY LOOSE
GOOD OLD THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
CAPABILITIES SO IF THERE WAS AN
EMERGENCY IT JUST ABILITY TO
TELL PEOPLE TO GET OUT OF
HARM'S WAY AND COMMUNICATE IN
THAT AREA BECOMES VERY VERY
LIMITED. BUT THE POWERS OF THE
PS FEELS PROGRAMS ARE EXPOSING
IS THOSE CHALLENGES BUT THEY'RE
NOT THE ONLY REASON WHY A LOSS
OF POWER COULD TAKE PLACE AND
COMMUNITY SO I DO THINK THAT
THERE IS A BENEFIT TO THE FACT
THAT THE PS PS PROGRAMS ARE
EXPOSING THIS VULNERABILITY.
THAT WE HEALTH BECAUSE WE IT
INCREASINGLY OR ROLE OF RELYING
MORE AND MORE ON IN HOME A LIKE
ONE ELECTRICITY ELECTRIC
SUPPLY. OUR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEM IS RELIANCE ON THE
ELECTRIC SUPPLY AND NOW WE'RE
ALSO TALKING ABOUT THE
CARBONIZED IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IN MAKING
NOT RELIABLE NO ELECTRIC SUPPLY
AS WELL AND HELP WITH THAT
CALMS. THE RISK THAT IT POSES
TO PUBLIC SAFETY IF WE LOSE
ELECTRIC POWER SO I THINK EL
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO REGARD
COMMUNITIES RESILIENCE TO LOSS
OF POWER IS IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN THAT THEY THINK
IT'S BENEFICIAL WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT IT TO THE TO. KEEP IN
MIND THAT PSP ELSE IS NOT THE
ONLY REASON AND THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES RESILIENCE
EVEN IF P. S. P. S. ALL
PROGRAMS WERE TO SOMEHOW WILL
COME WHEN NECESSARY AND GO AWAY
THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY SOLD THAT
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE. ELEMENT IN THAT AS WITH
DESIGN SOLUTIONS L. AS TO THAT
ISSUE A THINK IT'S HELPFUL TO
LOOK AT IT MORE BROADLY AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE. HOLDING
IT FOR THE ROOT PROBLEM OF
RESILIENCE OF OUR COMMUNITY IS
ALL. AND NOT JUST MAKING P. S.
P. S. ALL. TRANSMISSION IS LEFT
TO THE UTILITY TO MAKE THAT
DECISION. AND WHEN YOU LOOK IN
THE EXCELLENT EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS AND STAFF REPORT THAT
WAS DONE FOR THIS COMMITTEE
HERE AND REALLY GOES INTO THE
DETAILS OF THE DISCRETION
REALLY AND THE DIFFERENT
CRITERIA UTILIZED BY EACH
UTILITY IN MAKING THAT DECISION.
AND WE'LL GET INTO THAT OR
QUESTIONS LATER BUT- ARE YOU
LOOKING AT STANDARDIZING THAT
IN SOME FORM IF YOU MOVE TO THE
NEXT PHASE OF THE PS PS
PROTOCOLS SO THAT. THERE IS
LESS DISCRETION PERHAPS AND
MORE DETERMINED PERHAPS USING
MACHINE LEARNING TO DETERMINE.
OR ESTABLISH THOSE CRITERIA
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE CAN THEN
IT'S A LITTLE MORE RELIABLE
LESS IN THE HANDS OF THE
UTILITY TO MAKE THAT DECISION.
BUT MORE IN THE SCIENTIFIC
BASIS OF THAT RATHER THAN. AND
I THINK IT IS MORE OF A
SCIENTIFIC. DECISION. L. IT AT
THIS POINT THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE REMAINS OF THOSE THE
OPERATOR AT THE UTILITIES GET
TO MAKE THE DECISION OF WHETHER
TO KEEP THEIR FACILITIES
ENERGIZED OR NOT AND IT'S A. B.
L. QUITE SIGNIFICANT LINE TO
CROSS I MEAN THERE IS NO
CURRENTLY. I WOULD SAY WE
GENERALLY JUST DON'T KNOW. ONE
WE JUST DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT
THE BEHAVIOR ALL OF WILDFIRES
IN THE COULD CONDITIONS THAT.
RESULTS IN A CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES REMOTE ELECTRIC LINES
THERE'S SOME HIGH LEVEL
THEORIES AROUND ITS- BLADES OF
THERE IS. EITHER LOW SPECIFIC
SET OF CONDITIONS THAT THE TO
MY KNOWLEDGE HAVE BEEN STUDIED
AND VETTED THROUGH SOME KIND OF
SCIENTIFIC METHODS THAT CAN SAY
THAT UNDER THESE CONDITIONS IF
YOU DO IT YOU KNOW ALL
WARRANTED TO ENERGIZE THE LINES
IN REALITY IT BECOMES. ALL A
QUESTION OF ALL OF ALL THE
LEVELS OF RISK AND WHAT KIND OF
FIRES OR WE TOLD HIM. YOU KNOW
OR DO WE REALLY WANT TO
PREVENTS ELM AND UP I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT THIS POINTS SO
WE HOW OF EITHER ENOUGH DATA OR
KNOWLEDGE. IT TO BE ABLE TO
DRAW THAT LINE ACCURATELY SO
ELEMENT THEY THINK WHERE WE ARE
AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT AND
CLAIM IS CONTINUING TO LEARN
ALL FOR ALL MY- WEIGHT KIND OF
CONDITIONS SO. THE UTILITIES
DEEM TO BE RISKY HOME AND THEN
HALL OF DISCUSSIONS OF THEM
AFTER THE FACT OLD. GREEN
COLLECTIVELY OVER THE
ASSESSMENTS ALL THE EXPERTS
WORKING IN THIS FIELD OF WITH
THE WERE INDEED L. POSED A HIGH
RISK OF HAVING A FEEDBACK MAC
MECHANISM AND CONTINUING TO
COLLECT. MORE AND MORE DATA AND
GETTING MORE ADVANCED IN TERMS
OF HOW WE ASSESS RISKS SO WHILE
IT MAY BE. IF THEY'RE RADICALLY
POSSIBLE TO HALL OF MORE
STRICT. GUIDELINES WERE EVEN
RULES AROUND IT AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME I
DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE QUITE THERE
YET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANELIST CAROLINE THOMAS
JACOBSON CHIEF OF HEAD QUARTERS
I'M SORRY YES OF COURSE THANK
YOU HI I THANK YOU FOR THAT
JUST TWO TWO QUESTIONS. ARE THE
FIRST SAYS AND THANK YOU FOR
MENTIONING THAT SDG IN THE
WHICH ALL KNOWLEDGE IS A
SMALLER UTILITY AND SO IT'S
LESS INFRASTRUCTURE IS ABLE TO
DO MORE SURGICAL. OUR POWER
SHUT DOWNS AND AGAIN I KNOW P.
GINNY I MESSAGES DIFFERENT
TOADIES DIFFERENT SERVICE AREAS.
I'M NOT GOING TO PRETEND THAT
THEY ARE SOMEHOW IDENTICAL
THEY'RE NOT. THIS TERRITORY
WE'RE GOING TO SEE OF VERY
OVERBROAD OF POWER SHUT OFF
THAT ARE GOING TO AFFECT A HUGE
SWATH OF OUR REGION. EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A VERY LOCALIZED
VIRUS. AND SO THE QUESTION IS
WHY IS IT. THAT P. GINNY IS NOT
ABLE TO DO THESE MORE SURGICAL
SHUT OFF AND WHAT IS THE CPUC
DOING TO ENSURE THAT. HE JENNY
MOVES TOWARD THE PLACE WHERE IT
CAN DO THE SURGICAL SHOT OFFICE.
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THESE
THE GENIE AND THE P. JEANNIE OF
THIS VERY AS REASONS FOR THE
HOME AND SOME OF THEM ARE THE
TO DO WITH JUST THE HISTORY OF
THE SYSTEMS THE P. JEANNIE
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE WAS ONE LARGE
LARGER BUT ALSO MUCH OLDER SO
THOUGH IS THE GENIE TERRITORIAL
SMALLER IT'S NEWER OF WHEN THE
WE'RE DOING THE CONSTRUCTION OF
WITH A LOT OF THOSE ON THE
GROND HOME SO THEY WERE
ALREADY DEALING WITH MUCH
SMALLER FOOTPRINTS AND BECAUSE
THE AS THE SYSTEM WAS BEING PUT
INTO PLACE THEY WERE ABLE TO.
DESIGN ADS WITH MORE ADVANCED
KNOWLEDGE WORKERS P. JEANNIE
ELM IS IT THE VAULT DIFFERENTLY
OVER TIME SO SOME OF IT ISN'T
NECESSARILY THAT IS D. GENIE IS
NOT MUCH BETTER WELL THE P.
JEANNIE BECAUSE OF ADVANCE
PLANNING AND SOME OF IT YOU
KNOW THE THEY DID SEVERAL YEARS
AGO START ALL LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT MINIMIZING
IMPACTS OF THEIR BUT OF LINES
OF THE COULD POTENTIALLY DE
ENERGIZED WITH A LOT OF IT DOES
ALSO ALL THEIR BENEFITING FROM
THE SYSTEM DESIGN. THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WHAT WELL FIRE
PREVENTION ELM. IN THE FIRST
PLACE IN TERMS OF WEIGHT YOU
KNOW. CURRENTLY WE HAVE THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE HOW OFF. OF ME
AND- THE PART OF P. GENIES
WELFARE MITIGATION PLAN IN THIS
THIS THING CAN TALK MORE TO IT
DOES INCLUDE ADDING MORE
SECTIONAL LASERS AND OTHERWISE
RECONFIGURING THE SYSTEM SO
THAT THEY CAN GET ELM. A LITTLE
BIT BETTER AT MINIMIZING THE
IMPACT WHEN THEY DE ENERGIZED
ELM LINES THAT ARE IN THE HIGH
FILE THREAT ZONES. AND THEN.
AND I'M SUREYOU DIDN'T MISS A
SINGLE ADDRESS DIED IN THE
TIMING ON THAT BUT IN THE OTHER
QUESTION IS TO JUST TO BE
CLEAR. SO WHEN I WHEN I
ELECTRIC UTILITY DECIDES TO
POWER DOWN. ON THAT CAN AVOID
LIABILITY FOR THE UTILITY WHAT
ARE THE FINANCIAL. CONSEQUENCES
FOR UTILITY FOR ENGAGING IN A
SHUT DOWN AND ARE THERE ANY
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES NOT. TO GO
NOT TO ARE ON THE SIDE OF BEING.
BROAD. WHAT ARE THERE ARE I
MEAN OF COURSE YOU'RE I MEAN
PEOPLE ARE NOT PURCHASING
ELECTRICITY TO RATE THEIR
LOSING THAT REPAIR MONEY BUT
THAT'S SMALL IN THE IN THE BIG
SCHEME OF THINGS ARE THEIR
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR THEM
NOT TO ENGAGE IN AN OVERLY
BROAD. SHUT DOWN. BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S A ONE SIDED
INCENTIVE FINANCIALLY. OF YEAH
A THING PROBABLY MISS THE
SINGLES BUT IT THE POSITION TO
TALK ABOUT THE HOW UTILITIES
VIEW IT BUT AT THE HIGH LEVEL
OF THERE ARE NO RULES SPECIFIC
MAKE IT WOULD COST MECHANISMS
THAT HAVE BEEN DESIGNED TO DATE
WHO THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO P. S.
P. S. ALL PROGRAMS. ALSO THERE
IS NO WAY TO TRANSFER FOR
EXAMPLE THE COST IS BEING I'M
COVERED BY A LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND FIRST RESPONDERS ALL OVER
TO THE UTILITY OF A BUSINESS IS
PUSHED. OUT OF BUSINESS THEY
HAVE NO RECOURSE. I MEAN NOT
THROUGH THE PC REGULATORY
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT WILL MOVE TO CAROLINE
THOMAS JACOBS CHIEF OF
HEADQUARTERS OPERATION FOR
RESPONSE SECTION OF THE
RESPONSE SECTION FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WELCOME AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN SENATORS SO AS I
MENTIONED I'M THE CHIEF OF
RESPONSE HEADQUARTERS
OPERATIONS THAT CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF MARIE
SERVICES CALLOW YES. IN THAT
ROLE I HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OVERSEEING THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER DURING ACTIVATIONS AND
ARE CALIFORNIA STATE WARNING
CENTER WHICH OPERATES A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN MONITORING ASSESSING
NOTIFYING STATE RESPONDER IS OF
EMERGING INCIDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. IN THAT ROLE I PLAYED
THE OPERATIONAL LEAD AS WITH
OUR ENGAGEMENT WITH THE I. O.
U.'S I'M ON THE ELEMENT OF THE
PS PS PROGRAM SO CAROL YES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
CAL FIRE HAS BEEN LEADING
COORDINATION WITH THE I. O. USE
P. JEANNIE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON SDG ANY IN RESPONSE TO
THE I USED ELEMENT OF THE P. S.
P. S. UP PROGRAMS. AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED THEY ARE USE OF
DEVELOP THAT THE PS PS PROGRAMS
TO MITIGATE THEIR RISK OF FIRES
A UNITED BY THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE SO TURNING OFF
THE POWER IN OUR MODERN POWER
DEPENDENT SOCIETY OF COURSE HAS
CASCADING CONSEQUENCES AND
THAT'S KIND OF THE ROLE THAT
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED IN ON
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE POWER
OUTAGES CAM LAST DAYS. SO MR US
SAYING MAY GET INTO A GREATER
DETAIL ON THIS BUT THE
OPERATIONAL CONSTRAINTS OF A P.
S. P. S. EVENT IN MANY CASES
CAN LEAD TO TWELVE PLUS POWER
OUR OUR OUR POWER OUTAGES AFTER
THE POWER IS TURNED OFF THE I.
YOU YOU MUST WAIT FOR THE
WEATHER EVENT TO SUBSIDE.
COMPLETE A FULL ASSESSMENT OF
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS
IMPACTED BY THAT WEATHER EVENT
DURING DAYLIGHT HOURS AND THEN
RE ENERGIZE THE LINE SO THIS
CAN LEAD TO A MULTI OUR.
OUTAGES AS WELL AS POTENTIALLY
MULTI DAY OUTAGES. SO CARILLO
YES ALONG WITH CEBU SEEING CAL
FIRE IMMEDIATELY RECOGNIZED THE
POTENTIAL SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS.
OF THESE LONGER THAN NORMAL
POWER OUTAGES AND WHAT THEY
WOULD HAVE AND THE IMPACT IT
WOULD HAVE LONG COMMUNITIES. SO
AS HAS ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED
JUST A FEW OF THEM THE PUBLIC
SAFETY IMPACTS ON OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY RESPONDER IS AND THEY'RE
REDUCED. OPERATIONAL CAPABILITY
TO RESPOND IF THEY'RE DIRECTLY
AFFECTED BY THE POWER OUTAGE.
ON TRAFFIC CONTROL SYSTEMS AND
SAFETY EQUIPMENT THAT WOULD BE
POWER DOWN AND DURING OVERNIGHT
HOURS WATER AND WASTEWATER
SYSTEMS ARE OFF LINE. COMMUNITY
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET WOULD BE
OFF LINE AND CERTAINLY THE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WITH
LIFE SUPPORTING MEDICAL
DEPENDENT. APPOINTMENTS THAT
WOULD POTENTIALLY BECOME
VULNERABLE TO THIS AS WELL. TO
ALL OF THESE IMPACTS HAVE LED
TO A POTENTIALLY CAT COULD
COULD LEAD TO POTENTIALLY
CASCADING EMERGENCIES THE
DEVELOP OUT OF THE DECISION TO
POWER DOWN. SO HELLO YES AS THE
STATE AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING EMERGENCY SERVICES
AT THE STATE LEVEL IN
SUPPORTING LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
I'LL USE FOR OVER A YEAR TO
PREPARE FOR AND RESPOND TO
THESE EVENTUAL. IMPACTS OF PS
PS EVENTS WE'VE LET EXECUTIVE
AN OPERATIONAL COORDINATION
THROUGH WEEKLY MEETINGS I'M ACT
HELLO YES AT THE EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP LEVEL UP WITH
PARTICIPATION FROM HELLO YES SI
PC. CAL FIRE IN THE AISLE USED
TO DISCUSS THESE ISSUES AND
DRIVE ACTIONS AND KEY LINES OF
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE AREAS
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON IS
LEADING COORDINATION WITH THE I
USED TO DEVELOP THE STATEWIDE
PUBLIC EDUCATION PROGRAM I'M AN
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. PREPARE FOR
POWER DOWN. ON WHICH INCLUDED
RADIO AND DIGITAL MEDIA
OUTREACH EXPLAINING THE PS PS
PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN BUILD
AWARENESS WITHIN THE
COMMUNITIES AND IT AND THAT
INCLUDES A WEBSITE THAT YOU MAY
BE AWARE OF PREPARE FOR POWER
DOWN .COM. WE'VE HELD NUMEROUS
REGIONAL LISTENING SESSIONS AND
COORDINATION CALLS WITH OUR
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY
KEY AREAS OF CONCERN. IN
COORDINATED TO DRIVE I OWE YOU
ENGAGEMENT ON THOSE AREAS OF
CONCERNS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. WE
HAVE HELD SEVERAL PS PS
ORIENTATION WORKSHOPS TO
EDUCATE OUR STATE AGENCY
PARTNERS ON AS WELL AS THE
CALLOW YES WORK FORCE
SPECIFICALLY ARE INCIDENTS
SUPPORT TEAMS WHICH SUPPORT OUR
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER ON THE
PS PS PROGRAMS. TO ENSURE THAT
THE OUR WORK FORCE IN OUR STATE
IS THE PARTNERS ARE AWARE OF
WHAT PS PS IS OUR WHEN THEY
COULD HAPPEN AND START
ANALYZING THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS
ON OUR STATE FAMILIES
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FACILITIES.
AND CAPABILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. THESE P. FPS
ORIENTATIONS HAVE BEEN AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
STAGE THE PARTNERS TO LEARN
ABOUT PS PS IN ORDER TO
EVALUATE HOW SUCH EVENTS COULD
IMPACT. THEIR DIRECT AREAS OF
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS. SUCH AS ON
OUR FIRE SERVICES AND OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY SERVICES AS WELL
AS OUR MEDICAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICES ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'RE ALSO INCORPORATING PS PS
EVENTS AND THE POTENTIAL POWER
OUTAGE IMPACTS INTO OUR REGULAR
EXERCISE PROGRAM TO BUILD OUR
WORK FORCES AWARENESS AND
KNOWLEDGE BASE. FOR THESE TYPES
OF ISSUES AND OPERATIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS WE MAY FACE
DURING A LARGE SCALE OR HIGH
IMPACT PS PS EVENT. TO ENSURE
OUR READINESS AT THE STATE
OPERATIONS LEVEL THE OPERATIONS
CENTER LEVEL TO RESPOND TO AN
EVENT. MOST IMPORTANTLY HOWEVER
CAL YES CONSIDER THIS
CALIFORNIA STATE WARNING CENTER
AXES THE STATE THE STATE'S
NOTIFICATION POINT. FOR PS PS
EVENTS FROM THE I. O. U.'S. SO
IN THAT SENSE WE HAVE DEVELOPED
ON A CLEAR NOTIFICATION
PROTOCOL WITH THE I. O. U.'S TO
INFORM THE STATE WHEN THEY'RE
MAKING THESE DECISIONS. SO PER
THE CPU SEES DECISION THE
UTILITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
NOTIFY US THE CALIFORNIA STATE
WARNING CENTER WHEN THEY
ACTIVATE THEIR PS PS PROTOCOLS.
AND MAY DECIDE TO DE ENERGIZED
LINES DUE TO A PS PS OF AN. THE
D. I. O. U.'S ARE REQUIRED TO
NOTIFY THE WARNING CENTER UPON
FIVE TRIGGER POINTS IN A P. S.
P. S. EVENT. THE FIRST IS WHEN
THE ACTIVATE THEIR PS PS
PROTOCOLS THAT'S BEAT UP ONES
THAT THAT'S WHEN THEY DECIDED
THEIR MOST MIGHT DECIDE TO TURN
OFF THE POWER. THEY THEN ALSO
NEEDED LET US KNOW WHEN THEY'VE
ACTUALLY MADE THE DECISION TO
DE ENERGIZED. AS WELL AS WHEN
THEY MIGHT ACTUALLY WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY DO DE ENERGIZED I CALL
THAT DIFFERENTIAL OUT BECAUSE
DEPENDING ON THE I OWE YOU
THERE CAN BE A TIME DELAY
BETWEEN WHEN THEY DECIDED THE
ENERGIZED. WHEN THE ACTUAL
DINNER DECISION HAPPENS. THEY
ALSO NEED TO NOTIFY US ONCE
THEY- THE WEATHER EVENT HAS
SUBSIDED. AND THEY HAVE BEGUN
THE REASSESSMENT PATROLS TO BE
ABLE TO RE ENERGIZE. AND THEN
THE FINAL NOTIFICATION POINT.
IS WHEN THEY'VE ACTUALLY
REENERGIZED ALL OF THE LINES.
SO WHEN THEY NOTIFY US ON EACH
OF THESE FIVE TRIGGER POINTS TO
THEIR REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A
CERTAIN INFORMATION PER THE CPC
DECISION. THE SOME OF THE AREAS
THAT THEY IN A SUMMIT OF THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE US. ARE THE SPECIFIC
AREAS OF POTENTIAL PSP PS
OUTAGE SO THE POLYGONS OF THE
CIRCLES THE AREAS OF THEIR
CONSIDERING TO. TURN OFF. THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS THAT
ARE IN THOSE AREAS. THE NUMBER
OF MEDICAL BASS LINE IN OR
CRITICAL CARE CUSTOMERS THAT
ARE IN THAT THOSE POTENTIAL
AREAS. IN THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT THEY HAVE
DEFINED THAT ARE IN THOSE AREAS
AS WELL AS WELL AS THE
ESTIMATED DURATION OF THE
WEATHER EVENT. BECAUSE THAT
GIVES US SOME GUIDANCE ON THE
POTENTIAL TIMING. OF THE EVENT.
AND LASTLY ONE OF TE IMPORTANT
AREAS THAT THEY COMMUNICATE
WITH US ON IS CUSTOMER
NOTIFICATIONS. AND THE STATUS
OF THE POSITIVE CONFIRMATION OF
NOTIFICATION. TO THEIR MEDICAL
BASELINE OR CRITICAL CARE
CUSTOMERS DEPENDING ON HOW THEY
DEFINE IT. UPON RECEIPT OF EACH
OF THESE NOTIFICATION FROM THE
UTILITY. THE WARNING CENTER
DISTRIBUTES THIS NOTIFICATION
DIRECTLY TO OUR STATE AGENCY
PARTNERS. TO OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
THROUGH OUR DUTY OFFICER
PROGRAM SO FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE.
DUTY OFFICERS AND FIRE LAW AND
ARE ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
DISCIPLINES AND MAY PASSED THAT
NOTIFICATION ON TO THEIR LOCAL
PARTNERS THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
IMPACTED OR ARE ADJACENT TO THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT AREA. OF THE
PS PS EVENT SO THAT THE BROAD
PUBLIC SAFETY RESPONDER
COMMUNITY IS AWARE OF THE PUT
POTENTIAL PS PS OF AND- WE ALSO
DISTRIBUTE THIS NOTIFICATION.
FOR TO DOWN TO A PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCH CENTERS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM KNOWN
AS CLASS AS WELL SO THERE'S
ALSO A DIRECT NOTIFICATION TO
OUR DISPATCH CENTERS THAT ARE
UP ON CLASS. DURING ACTIVE PS
PS EVENTS HELLO YES STAYS IN
DAILY CONTACT WITH THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITY THAT IS EXECUTING
THIS PAST PS OF AND THROUGH
DAILY BRIEFINGS. AND FOR LARGER
EVENTS WE MAY HOLD A STATE
AGENCY COORDINATION CALLS TO
ENSURE THAT THE ENTIRE STATE
FAMILIES AWARE AND ENGAGED ON
THE A AND READY TO RESPOND TO
THE POTENTIAL CASCADING
IMPACTS. OF A LONGER TERM DE
ENERGIES ATION AND POWER OUTAGE.
AS OF TODAY P. JEANNIE AN S. C.
E. HAVE ACTIVATED THEIR PS PRE
ASK PS PROTOCOLS THIS YEAR. P.
JEANNIE AND EARLY JUNE AS HAS
ALREADY BEEN REFERENCE THE
DINNER RISE TO SEPARATE AREAS
TURNING OFF POWER. TO OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND CUSTOMERS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AN S. C.
E. SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
HAS SINCE EARLY JULY BEEN UNDER
ALMOST CONSTANT PS PS PROTOCOLS
THERE IS A SHORT I THINK A
COUPLE DAYS THEY WEREN'T. BUT
PRETTY MUCH UNDER CONSTANT PS
PS PROTOCOLS SINCE EARLY JULY.
NO THEY HAVE NOT ACTUALLY
DECIDED TO EXECUTE ON THE
INTERPRETATION ON ANY OF THOSE
YET. SO CAL YES ALONG WITH HER
SEE IF YOU SEE AND CAL FIRE
PARTNERS ARE REMAINING ACTIVELY
ENGAGED WITH THE I. O. USED TO
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
MEASURES TO MITIGATE THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS. OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
THREAT IN MAINTAIN OUR
READINESS TO RESPOND TO THE
CASCADING CONSEQUENCES AS
NEEDED. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN THIS TOPIC AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED I THINK THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC TO
TALK THROUGH AS A LARGER
COMMUNITY AND PROVIDING CAL S.
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE OUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS IN THE KIND OF.
EDUCATED US ON ON EXACTLY HOW
THAT PROCESS WORKS THANK YOU
WELL NOW BEFORE WE GO TO
QUESTIONS WILL GO TO SUMIT
SAYING THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
ASSETS RISK MANAGEMENT A
COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE SAFETY FOR
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY WELCOME MR SINGH. THE
MORNING AND THANK YOU CENTER
HEALTH AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS SESSION AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. THAT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WITHOUT COOPERATION
AND CONTINUED COLLABORATION IS
NOT GOING TO BE. A SUCCESSFUL
MORE EFFECTIVE. OWN START BY
STRESSING THAT AS A UTILITY HER
MOST IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITY
IS THE SAFETY OF OUR CUSTOMERS
AND OUR COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
SO WHAT WAS ECHOED. BY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN REGARDS TO
THE FOCUS ON MAXIMIZING PUBLIC
SAFETY. THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
OUR INTENT AND FOCUSES. THE
DEVASTATING FIRES A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
HAVE MADE IT EXTREMELY CLEAR
THAT MORE MUST BE DONE AND MORE
MUST BE DONE FASTER. TO THAT
END WE HAVE A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH IN REGARDS TO A
COMMITTEE WHILE FAR SAFETY
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAD OUTLINED
IN THE LOS FOUR SAFETY PLAN
THAT WE HAD SUBMITTED. EARLIER
THIS YEAR WHICH HAS SUFFERED
SUBSEQUENTLY BEEN APPROVED BY
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WE HAVE NOT WAITED
WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
IMPLEMENTING MANY OF THE RISK
REDUCTION MEASURES THAT HAVE
BEEN OUTLINED. WITHIN THE LOS
OUR MEDICATION PLAN NOT ONLY
DOES NOT INCLUDE. EXPANDING OUR
CAPABILITIES ON REAL TIME
MONITORING AND INTELLIGENCE AS
MISS MALASHENKO MENTIONED IN
REGARDS TO DEPLOYMENTS OF HIGH
DEFINITION CAMERAS. WATER
STATIONS SATELLITE DETECTION
CAPABILITIES BUT ALSO
IMPLEMENTING NEW AND ENHANCED
SAFETY MEASURES TO BE ABLE TO
DO A PRO ACTIVE ENHANCED
INSPECTION OF ALL OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE. WITHIN THE HI
FI RISK AREAS USING DRONES
HELICOPTERS WITH HIGH
RESOLUTION IMAGERY THE TYPES OF
CAPABILITIES THAT HAVE NEVER
BEEN EMPLOYED BEFORE. AS PART
OF THIS INSPECTION REGIME. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ARE. VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN REGARDS TO OUR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
AND GOING WELL BEYOND THE
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS TO
TRIMMING A TO IDENTIFY THOSE
TREES THAT POTENTIALLY COULD
FEEL INTO OUR LINES AND
IDENTIFY THOSE SO WE ARE
PROACTIVE ABOUT REMOVING AND
IDENTIFYING THOSE HAZARDOUS
TREES AS OPPOSED TO DEALING
WITH THAT IN A REACTIVE
SITUATION. AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON A
FUNDAMENTAL REBUILD OF OUR
ELECTRICAL UTILITY SYSTEM IN
REGARDS TO THE SYSTEM HARDENING
AND RESILIENCE CAPABILITIES WE
ARE PRO ACTIVELY UNDER
GROUNDING OUR LINES ON A
TARGETED BASIS WE ARE
REBUILDING OUR OVERHEAD
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE
SOMETHING CALLED COVERED
CONDUCTOR SO WE REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD. OF POTENTIAL
VEGETATION COMING IN CONTACT
WITH OVERHEAD LINES AND WHEN
THEY DO THE MINIMIZE THE
SURFACE AREA FOR CAUSING A
POTENTIAL ARC OR A SPARK IN ALL
OF THESE. RISK REDUCTION
MEASURES ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED
AS WE SPEAK TODAY. MOST
IMPORTANTLY TODAY WE'RE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF PROGRAM WE DO
NOT LOOK AT THIS AS OUR ONLY
RISK REDUCTION MEASURE IT'S ONE
OF THE TOOLS OF WITHIN OUR TOOL
KIT OF A RISK REDUCTION
MEASURES AND WE REALLY LOOK TO
THE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF. IN THOSE INSTANCES WHERE
WE ARE EXPERIENCING EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITIONS AND EXTREME
NGUYEN TYPE OF CONDITIONS AND
REALLY EMPLOYING THIS IN A MUCH
MORE TARGETED AND A STRATEGIC
WAY. AND I'LL TALK A BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT LOT OF QUESTIONS
THAT CAME UP IN REGARDS TO THE
DECISION CRITERIA AND
RESTORATION WHICH I'LL SPEAK ON
AS WELL. BUT LET ME FIRST TOUCH
ON WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN REGARDS
TO THE EXTENSIVE OUTREACH
EFFORTS THE MORE THERE'S MORE
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND- WE A
WELCOME THE CONTINUED A
PARTNERSHIP AND CO CREATION. ON
THIS FRONT WE HAVE REACHED OUT
TO ALL OF OUR FIVE MILLION
ELECTRIC CUSTOMERS BY MAIL BY
EMAIL PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS. WERE PROVIDING A
UNIQUE EDUCATIONAL KITS TO OUR
MASTER METER CUSTOMERS THAT MAY
BE LIVING IN APARTMENT
BUILDINGS AND MAY HAVE A SINGLE
METER LOCATION. WE ARE DOING
PROACTIVE REACH OUT TO OUR
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS TO
ENSURE WE HAVE THAT UPDATED
CONTACT INFORMATION. AS WAS
STATED BY SOME OF THE PANEL
MEMBERS THE PROCESS WE HAVE FOR
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS FOR
NOTIFICATION IS ENSURING THAT
THE POSITIVE CONFIRMATION WHEN
WE DO REACH OUT TO THEM. EITHER
VIA TEXT EMAIL PHONE CALL TO
ENSURE THAT WE MAKE POSITIVE
CONFIRMATION AND IN THE
INSTANCE WE DO NOT MAKE
POSITIVE CONFIRMATION WE DO A
TRUCK ROLE IN ACTUALLY SEND
PERSONNEL FROM OUR STAFF TO GO
OUT TO THE RESPECTIVE.
FACILITIES TO ENSURE THEY DO
MAKE THAT POSITIVE CONTACT.
WE'RE ALSO. ENGAGING AND HAD
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS WITH LOCAL
OFFICIALS CUSTOMER GROUPS
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS.
ENTITIES NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS CRITICAL FACILITIES
TELECOM PROVIDERS WATER
SERVICE. PROVIDERS WE'VE DONE
PLANNING WORKSHOPS WITH THE
LOCAL AGENCY OFFICIALS
THROUGHOUT OUR SERVICE AREA AND
THIS WORK IS CONTINUING. AND
THERE'S MORE THAT WE KNOW THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THE SPACE.
THE TOPIC THAT CAME UP IN
REGARDS TO THE SOCIALIZATION
AND THE TIMING OF THAT WORK WE
ARE VERY MINDFUL. THAT A PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF HAS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT OF FROM A
PUBLIC SAFETY STANDPOINT AS
WELL AND THE RISK OF DE
ENERGIZING THE ELECTRIC GRID.
SO ON THAT FRONT WE ARE WORKING
ON A NUMBER OF ITEMS WE ARE OF
TAKING A PAGE OUT OF THE
PLAYBOOK OF THE SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC IN TERMS OF BECOMING
MUCH MORE TARGETED IN REGARDS
TO OUR GREAT. AS MISMO SHEKEL
MENTIONED ARE GREAT IS
OBVIOUSLY MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT
IN TERMS OF SIZE AND SCALE. WE
HAVE NEARLY THIRTY THOUSAND
MILES OF OVERHEAD LINES THAT
TRAVERSE THE HIGH FAR THREAT
DISTRICTS OF PUT THAT IN
CONTEXT IT'S- MORE THAN THE
DISTANCE AROUND THE WORLD AND
THAT'S REALLY THE SCALE THAT WE
ARE MANAGING. WE ARE CURRENTLY
INSTALLING SOCIALIZATION
DEVICES WITH IT STALLED MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THIS
YEAR ALONE AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO PROACTIVELY INSTALL THOSE
DEVICES AND WHAT THOSE DEVICES
DO IS THEY BASICALLY REDUCE.
THE ABILITY FOR US AN INCREASE
THE ABILITY AND REDUCE THE
IMPACT. ON THE CIRCUIT ITSELF
SO THEREBY MINIMIZING AND
REDUCING. THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
IMPACTED. OF IN THAT THE IDEA
GENERATION EVENT. IN ADDITION
TO THAT WE ARE INSTALLING A
SIGNIFICANT NETWORK OF WEATHER
STATIONS WE HAVE. MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED WEATHER STATIONS
INSTALLED WITHIN OUR SYSTEM.
AND THAT GIVES US THE ABILITY
ON A TARGETED BASIS TO
UNDERSTAND THE MICRO CLIMATE.
AND WITH THAT COUPLED WITH THE
SOCIALIZATION DEVICES BE MUCH
MORE TARGETED AND PRECISE. NOT
IN NARROWING IN ON OUR
CAPABILITY OF THE ENERGIZING
WHEN WE DO DE ENERGIZE. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT. AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY ARE CONSTRUCTING A
RESILIENCE OWN UP IN THE
PACIFIC A UNION COLLEGE IN AND
WHEN IT SHOULD BE OPERATIONAL
WITHIN THE MONTH AND THE INTENT
BEHIND THIS RESILIENCE ON IS TO
PARTNER UP WITH DAHLE OUR
COMMUNITY ENTITIES TO IDENTIFY
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE CRITICAL
ESSENTIAL SERVICES. LIKE
HOSPITALS THAT IN AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL SERVICES WITH IN THAT
RESPECT OF COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN OUR SERVICE TO THEM
IN THE INSTANCE WHERE WE DO DE
ENERGIZED SO THE OF RESILIENCE
ON CONSISTS OF WHAT'S CALLED A
PRE INSTALLED POP HUB. THAT
GIVES THE CAPABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO BRING IN AND CONNECT A
MOBILE GENERATOR AND THEN
DOWNSTREAM OF THAT WE HAVE TO A
HALF MILES OF UNDERGROUND
ELECTRIC LINES THAT PROVIDE
SERVICE. TO THE CRITICAL AND
ESSENTIAL SERVICES WE ARE
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT FOR
ADDITIONAL. ZONES THIS YEAR
ALONE WITH A- GOAL TO CONTINUE
TO EXPAND AND BUILD ON THE
PORTFOLIO. IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE ARE DEPLOYING CUSTOMER
RESORT COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTER SOME SORRY. AS PART OF
THE DEALER JUST ATION PROCESS
WHICH PROVIDES SOME OF THE
BASIC. SERVICES FROM MOBILE
CHARGING WATER THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO GET UP TO DATE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE EVENT
ITSELF MODELED. VERY SIMILARLY
TO WHAT SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC
HAS DONE. AND THEN WE ARE ALSO
WORKING. VERY CLOSELY AND
PARTNERING WITH THE A
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION OF THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. TO
REALLY ENGAGE WITH OUR MEDICAL
BASELINE OUR CUSTOMERS SO THAT
WE WORK WITH THEM FROM A GRANT
AND I ALLOCATION PERSPECTIVE
AND THEY BEST IDENTIFY. HOW TO
DISPERSE THOSE FUNDS IN REGARDS
TO THE NEEDS OF THE MEDICAL
BASELINE. CUSTOMERS AND THE
SPECIFIC VULNERABILITIES THAT
THEY MAY HAVE. THE ABILITY TO.
EXECUTE THE OTHER KEY ELEMENTS
OF OUR PROGRAM AND OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF IS
CRITICALLY DEPENDENT ON THE
COLLABORATION WOULD NOT JUST
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE
REPRESENTED HERE ON THIS PANEL
BUT EVERYONE OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL OF THE LOCAL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AND IT'S
REALLY GOING TO TAKE THE
COLLECTIVE US TO FOCUS ON THIS.
LET ME TOUCH ON TWO OTHER ITEMS
THAT CAME UP IN REGARDS TO THE
DECISION CRITERIA AND
RESTORATION AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO A ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY HAVE IN
REGARDS TO THE DECISION
CRITERIA IT IS NOT A AD HOC
PROCESS IT IS A VERY STRUCTURED
PROCESS THAT HAS A DETAILED OUR
TIME LINE WITH THE APPROPRIATE
TECH TALK IDENTIFIED IN REGARDS
TO ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
ACCOUNTABILITY IS. AND WHEN WE
DO ACTIVATE FOR EMERGENCY
CENTER AND ACTIVATE OUR
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
THAT'S WHEN WE REALLY A SWING
INTO MOTION LEVERAGING OUR
INCIDENT COMMAND STRUCTURE AND
EACH OF THE DATA POINTS IS
MONITORED ALL OF THE
COMMUNICATION INFORMATION HAS
STRUCTURED PROTOCOL IN TERMS OF
HOW. IT WILL INFORMATION IS
COMING FROM HI WAS COMMUNICATED
WITH OUR EXTERNAL ENTITIES
EXTERNAL PARTNERS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A CRITICAL NEED TO BE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT COULD BE WHO
IS POTENTIALLY IMPACTED ARE THE
ENGAGEMENT THAT WE DO IN
REGARDS WITH THE FIRST
RESPONDERS TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO PROSPER NOTIFICATIONS WE
STRIVE FOR UP A FORTY EIGHT
HOUR NOTICE OUR CUSTOMERS TO
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE YEAH THIS
IS WEATHER DEPENDENT IN SOME
CASES WE MAY NOT TRULY HAVE THE
LUXURY OF THAT. CASTING THAT
NOTICE THAT THE POLICE THINGS
THAT WE SAW IN REGARDS
SPECIFICALLY OUR DECISION
CRITERIA WE ARE MOVING TO OF A
PSYCHIC OF APPROACH THEY ARE
URGING US SOMETHING CALLED A
FIRE POTENTIAL INDEX IT'S A
VERY. SIMILAR METHODOLOGY
THAT'S BEEN EMPLOYED WITH
SENDING. A GAS ELECTRIC AND
THIS IS A INDEX THAT'S ACTUALLY
PUBLISHED BY OUR METROLOGY TEAM
ON A DAILY BASIS ON A ROLLING
THREE DAY. TIME FRAME TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE FOUR CASTING
CAPABILITY OF THE UTILITY FIRE
RISK FOR THE NEXT THREE DAYS
ACROSS OUR SERVICE TERRITORY.
AND BASED ON THAT WE ARE. HAVE
THE INITIAL OPERATING
RESTRICTIONS THAT WE ARE PUT
FORWARD IN REGARDS TO OUR GRADE
AND ANY PLANNED WAR COULD THAT
BABY TAKING. OUR PLACE IN
REGARDS TO HI FAR RISK AREA.
WITHIN THE RESPECTIVE
GEOGRAPHIC SERVICE TERRITORY IT
INCLUDES FACTORS ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO. THE FACTORS ARE
USED WITH THE NATIONAL FIRE
DANGER RATING SYSTEM. WITH THE
US FOR SERVICES LOOKING AT. A
LIVE FEEL MORE SURE DID FEEL
MORE SURE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
SPREAD THE FUEL LOADING.
CONDITIONS AND IN ADDITION TO
THAT WE HAVE ALSO DONE. SOME
ANALYSIS ON LOOKING AT THE
PERFORMANCE OF OUR DISTRIBUTION
CIRCUITS TO WINS AND REALLY
IDENTIFYING. WHERE WITHIN OUR
SERVICE TERRITORY IN OUR
CIRCUITS DO WE SEE A HIGHER
LIKELIHOOD. AND PROBABILITY OF
THE COLLEGE WHICH COULD BE A
LEADING INDICATOR TO A
POTENTIAL FIRE IGNITION. AS WE
START TO SEE THE WIND SPEEDS
PICK UP. SO THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
FROM A SCIENCE STANDPOINT OF
STATISTICS PERSPECTIVE. TO BE
ABLE TO HELP FORMULATE THE
UNDERLYING CAPABILITIES ON THE
DECISION MAKING CRITERIA
INCLUSIVE OF. TAKING. INTO
ACCOUNT ALL OF THE VARIOUS
OTHER FACTORS. I'M IN REGARDS
TO RESTORATION WE'VE GOT A
ACTIVE FOCUS ON RESTORATION
MOVE VERY MINDFUL OF THE FACT
THAT WANT TO TRY TO MINIMIZE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME. THAT WE ARE
IMPACTING WHEN WE DO DE
ENERGIZED AFTER THE ALL CLEAR
ON THE WEATHER IS IN PLACE. WE
HAVE A DEDICATED TEAM THAT
SOLELY BEEN FOCUSED ON
RESTAURANT ON RESTORATION
STRATEGIES THE DEVELOPING AND
HAVE DEVELOPED A LARGE PART. OF
PLAYBOOKS FOR EACH OF OUR
DISTRIBUTION CIRCUITS WERE
HOLDING INTERNALEXERCISES WITH
ALL OF OUR- OUR QUALIFIED
LINEMEN AND PERSONNEL SO THAT
WE ARE PRO ACTIVELY GOING OUT
AND DOING GROUND PATROLS
IDENTIFYING HOW LONG IT'S
TAKING TO DO THOSE INSPECTIONS.
BECAUSE TO THE POINT THAT WAS
MADE BY MR SCHECK ANOTHER'S
PREVIOUSLY OF MY ON THE PANEL.
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
NO DAMAGE TO THE GRADE. PRIOR
TO RESTORATION WE ARE ALSO
EMPLOYING HEAD OF RECENTLY.
CONTRACTED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF AERIAL FLEET. NEARLY THIRTY
FIVE. HELICOPTERS EMPLOYED AS
PART OF DOING AERIAL PATROLS TO
BE ABLE TO FURTHER EXPEDITE
THAT PROCESS WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT CAPABILITIES INCLUSIVE OF
LOOKING AT LIGHT ARE. ALSO WE
CAN DO NIGHTTIME PATROLS AND
AGAIN FOR THE REDUCE AND
MINIMIZE. THE AMOUNT OF TIME
FROM A RESTORATION PERSPECTIVE.
SO WITH THAT. WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TOPIC AND
CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE WITH
EVERYONE. THANK YOU INTERESTING
IN ANOTHER MANY QUESTIONS AND
I'D LIKE TO JUST EXERCISE THAT
YOURS FOR AUG TWO OF. FOR A
COUPLE MINUTES BEFORE WE GET TO
THE QUESTIONS IS MAYOR SAM
LICCARDO FROM STAND AS A DOES
HAVE TO LEAVE AND SO WE WERE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FACT THAT
EACH YEAR SO. PERHAPS IF YOU
COULD COME UP IN YOUR IN THE
SECOND PANEL BUT WE WILL MAYBE
MAKE ROOM FOR YOU AT THIS POINT
AND RIGHT OVER HERE DISH TO MR
SAYING. AND. WHICH A YOUR NAME
TAG THERE AND- YOUR TESTIMONY
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMING TODAY
MISTER LICCARDO AND IN THERE
THAT IT THAT. IT'S CRITICAL
THAT OUR CITIES THE SPECIALLY
OUR MAJOR CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THE END THAT WE'RE- COGNIZANT
AND AWARE OF IN ALL OF US
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT. OF A P.
S. P. S. EVENT AND WHAT THAT
COULD MEAN FOR A CITY SO IF WE
APPRECIATE YOU COMING TODAY
MISSION HERE THE SHERIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR.
INVITING ME THANK YOU FOR
TAKING ME OUT OF ORDER AND MY
APOLOGIES FOR HAVING TO DEPART
BUT FORTUNATELY OUR DIRECTOR
MERCY MANAGEMENT RAY REARED IN
AS WELL AS OUR DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY LARA MITCHELL ARE
HERE SO IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS THEY CAN ANSWER THEM
FOR MORE INTELLIGENTLY THAN I
CAN. I'LL BE HAPPY SIMPLY SHARE
MY THOUGHTS. I THINK YOUR ALL
VERY AWARE OF THE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES OF AN EXTENDED P.
S. P. S. ADVANTAGE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES I YOUR DAILY GOING
HERE FOR MANY EXPERTS AFTER ME.
BUT I'LL JUST SHARE WITH YOU
WITH REGARD TO ONE PARTICULAR
PHENOMENON THAT IS NINE ONE ONE
CALLS. THE BEST CASE SCENARIO.
WE BELIEVE IS THAT AFTER A.
SAFETY SHUT DOWN THERE WOULD BE
A SURGE OF NINE ONE ONE CALLS
THAT WILL OVER WELL. OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS COMING FROM
RESIDENTS WITH RESPIRATORS
COMING FROM RESIDENTS WITH
MEDICINE MEDICATION IT NEEDS
REFRIGERATION COMING FROM FOLKS
WHO MAY BE CALLING BECAUSE
POLICE ARE DEALING WITH
MULTIPLE TRAFFIC COLLISIONS IN
AND PERHAPS FASTENED IN
DARKENED ARE AREAS OF THE CITY
THE WORST SCENARIO OF COURSE IS
THAT THERE'S NINE ONE ONE CALLS
WE MADE INTO. OVERLOADED
NETWORKS ALTERNATELY LOST. AND
EVEN WORSE STILL THAT WITH AN
EXTENDED DURATION THE P. S. P.
S. OF SIX TWELVE OR MORE HOURS.
THAT CELL TOWERS WILL
ESSENTIALLY SHUT DOWN. SO IN
VIEW OF THESE RISK MY AVERAGE
HE REALLY FOLKS ISN'T THREE
BASIC AREAS ONE IS THE LACK OF
ACTIVE PUBLIC STAKEHOLDER INPUT
AND PS YES DECISION. AS
SECONDLY ON THE NEED FOR
IMPROVED COMMUNICATION WITH
TACTIC COMMUNITIES AND THIRD ON
RESOURCES FOR RESILIENCY. OF
FIRST THE ISSUE OF WHO DECIDES
I DON'T WANT TO OVERLOOK THE
OBVIOUS THAT HAS BEEN OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S BEEN CLEARLY STATED
THAT THE CURRENT RULES LEAD
THESE LIFE OR DEATH DECISIONS
OVER DE ENERGIES ATION. IN THE
HANDS OF INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AND NOT A PUBLICATION
SEE. UTILITIES HAVE ASYMMETRIC
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES AS WITH
POINT OUT BY SENATOR WIENER. I
SHUT DOWN TRANSMISSION LINES
MITIGATE LIABILITY EVEN WERE
DOING SO WILL SUBJECT.
RESIDENTS IN CITIES LIKE MINE
TO PARA. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
NEITHER YASSER ISO OR PROBABLY
ANY OTHER PUBLICATIONS HE WANTS
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS
VERY CONSEQUENTIAL PS PS
DECISION BUT THESE ARE
DECISIONS THAT ALLOCATE RISKS
AMONG AND WITHIN COMMUNITIES.
AND THE DECISION TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA BEEN DELEGATED BY
DEFAULT I TO COMPANY THAT'S
BEEN CRIMINALLY CONVICTED FOR
SAFETY VIOLATIONS THAT
FALSIFIED ELECTRIC AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE RECORDS FOR HALF
A DECADE AND PAID SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. AND SHAREHOLDER
DIVIDENDS IN A DECADE WHICH
THEY SLASH INVESTMENT ON KEY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY AND
MAINTENANCE. I WE UNDERSTAND
THE DECISION WILL BE MADE BY AN
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT P.
JEANNIE ABOUT THE SHUTDOWN WE
HAD NO IDEA THAT PERSON'S AN
ENGINEER HAS ANY EXPERTISE. AND
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT IN ANY
CASE I WOULD URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER HOW TO
REALLOCATE DECISION MAKING
AUTHORITY FROM PRIVATE TO
PUBLIC. NOT MERELY AN OVERSIGHT
REVIEW BUT IN THE ACTIVE
INVOLVEMENT IN THE PS YES
DECISION. IF THERE'S A
RELUCTANCE TO DO SO AT THE
FRONT END AND THE TIERS IS
ATION. I WOULD ASK AT LEAST TO
CONSIDER A GREATER PUBLIC ROLE
IN THE BACK AND TO RE ENERGIZE.
THE GRID AFTER IT'S BEEN SHUT
DOWN THE TRANSMISSION LINE. IT
SEEMS THAT THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL IMPACTS OF THE
ENERGY IS ATION COME NOT FROM
THE DECISION TO FLIP THE SWITCH
OFF BUT RATHER. THE DELAY
DURATION ON WHICH IS SWITCHED
OFF AND AT THE VERY MINIMUM. WE
ASK THAT EVERY UTILITY'S LOCAL
MERCY OPERATIONS CENTER WOULD
ALSO INCLUDE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT STAFF TO
INFORM. ABOUT THIS SITUATION ON
THE GROUND UP. BUT WE KNOW A AS
WAS JUST MENTIONED THAT
INSPECTIONS REPAIRS ARE THE
CRITICAL PATH TO RE ENERGIZING
A TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
LINE. RIGHT NOW THE PC IS NOT
ESTABLISHED ANY FROM TIMELINE
TO REQUIRE UTILITIES TO ACT
QUICKLY. TAKING FIVE TO SEVEN
DAYS TO INSPECT WINDS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE AND THEY SHOULD GET
HELICOPTERS AND DRONES IN THE
AIR WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
WHERE SUFFICIENT REDUNDANCY
EXISTS IN THE SYSTEM
PUBLICATIONS HE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DIRECT THE MAJORITY OF POWER
TO BE RESTORED WHILE REPAIRS
ARE ISOLATED ON SPECIFIC WINDS.
THAT MY REMAINED DARK. A SECOND
A COMMUNICATION. WE WOULD ASK.
THAT THERE BE SOME LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE TO DIRECT UTILITIES TO
IMPROVE NOTIFICATION
COMMUNICATION PROTOCOLS. GIVEN
THE UNIQUE CONTROL THAT
UTILITIES HAVE A RELEVANT
INFORMATION THE UTILITIES MUST
BE PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
COMMUNICATING WITH BUILT IN
REDUNDANCY FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO BE INFORMED IN
PARALLEL AND WE CAN REINFORCE
MESSAGES. TO MITIGATE THE REST
THAT RESIDENTS FALL. TO ENSURE
THE RESIDENTS DON'T FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS. BUT IN
PARTICULAR UTILITIES IN THE
BEST POSITION HAS THE MOST
ACCURATE INFORMATION NOTIFY THE
CRITICAL INSTITUTIONS HOSPITALS.
CHEMICAL PLANTS PUBLIC TRANSIT
POLICE STATIONS INDIVIDUAL. IT
IS AGREE THAT P. GENIES CURRENT
PLANS FOR NOTIFYING COMMUNITIES
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT AND LEAVE
TOO MANY PEOPLE IN PERIL FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'RE ONLY PROVIDING
OUTAGE INFORMATION BY UTILITY
ACCOUNT NUMBER WITH NO SPECIFIC
REFERENCE TO A PHYSICAL
ADDRESS. OR A STREET BOUNDARIES.
FINALLY A LOCAL COMMUNITIES NAY
RESOURCES FOR RESILIENCY. AND
YOU'LL BE HAPPY HERE NOT ALL
THOSE RESOURCES REQUIRED THE
LEGISLATURE TO CUT A CHECK. WE
ARE SEEING EXAMPLES IN CITIES
LIKE CARD FOR NEW YORK WHERE
THEY'RE LEVERAGING PRIVATE
INVESTMENT TO DRAMATICALLY
EXPAND MICHAEL GRAETZ. I THE
LEGISLATURE CAN HELP BY
PROVIDING POLICY CERTAINTY
SPECIFICALLY BY REQUIRING
UTILITIES TO ALLOW MICRO GRIDS
TO INTERCONNECT WITH CLEAR
RULES AND COST WITHOUT
PROHIBITIVE FEES. MOREOVER WE
NEED CALLOW YES HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WITHIN EXTENDED PS
PS. AT THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY NOW. STATE OF
EMERGENCY POWERS WILL ENABLE
CITIES TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
MORE QUICKLY FOR STREAMLINED
PROCUREMENT FOR REIMBURSEMENT
FOR COMMANDEERING RESOURCES.
AND FOR SPECIAL POWERS TO
DECLARE CURFEWS. AND YES OF
COURSE WE ALSO NEED MONEY
WHETHER FOR ON SITE BACK UP AND
GENERATION BATTERIES ARE
MICHAEL GRAETZ FOR CRITICAL
FACILITIES HE'S LIKE HAS A NEED
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT RESILIENCE.
FOR THOSE POLICE AND FIRE
STATIONS WASTE WATER TREATMENT
PLANTS WERE POPS AIRPORT AND
COMMUNITY CENTERS THAT WILL BE
PROVIDING POWER FOR MEDICAL
DEVICES IN THEIR CONDITIONING
FOR FRACTAL RESIDENTS. I WE'VE
BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN CONDUCTING
ASSESSMENTS WORKING IDENTIFYING
FUNDING RESOURCES BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS A STATE WIDE
SAFETY ISSUE WE KNOW THAT
COMMITTEES WILL NEED STATEWIDE
INVESTMENT SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION. ON
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF MY YEARS.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYOR ED IN
JUST A QUESTION THEN WE'LL SEE
IF THERE ARE OTHERS HAVE
QUESTIONS OF YOU OF THE- YOU
TALK ABOUT THE COMMUNICATION.
ASPECT OF IT ESPECIALLY RELATED
TO THE RESTORATION OF POWER
AFTER THE D. ENERGY STATION.
HOW DO YOU FEEL THAT IS TODAY
DO YOU FEEL YOU HAVE A
COMFORTABLE GOOD TO A
COOPERATIVE RELATIONSHIP ARE
YOU PART OF THOSE. THAT
COMMUNICATIONS SPECIALLY WITH
YOUR NINE ONE ONE AND YOUR
EMERGENCY SERVICES WITH WITH
THE UTILITY. YES REGION HAS
BEEN COOPERATIVE I THINK THE
CHALLENGE AND I THINK FIVE YEAR
IN SPEAK MORE TO THIS. I IS
THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE THE
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE IS
SUFFICIENT A BY ANY STRETCH AND
I KNOW THERE ARE OTHER CITIES
OF FEEL THE SAME WAY. THE
PROTOCOL IN REESTABLISHING IN
THE TIME FOR ALL I'M SORRY
RECEPTION SPECIFICALLY. I YES
IT WE ARE SIMPLY NOT BEING
GIVEN MUCH REASSURANCE. I HAVE
A FRESH DURATION OBVIOUSLY
WHICH THE GREATEST DOWN IS
CRITICAL BUT WITH REGARD TO THE
COMMUNICATION YES THERE WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE ROBUST
COMMUNICATIONS READ YOU HAVE A
SUGGESTION AS TO HOW WE- HAVE
THAT COULD COME ABOUT. OTHER
COULD BE CREATED IS THE ANY
MENTION HAVING. A P. JEANNIE OR
UTILITY REPRESENTATIVE IN YOUR
OPERATIONS CENTER WE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE FOR YOU WOULD BE AND
YOU WOULD HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
IN THEIR CENTER THE LATTER IS
WHAT WE'RE MOST INTERESTED IN.
I SIMPLY WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
A PUBLIC AGENCY WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY IS
INFORMING. THE DECISIONS ABOUT
ONE TO REENTER THE USERS
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE SERVED
BY THAT THAT. THE IMAGES ASIAN
AREA OR GREATER. THIS EFFECT
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS OF A OF MAYOR
LICCARDO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. GOOD. SENATOR
QUESTION THANK YOU I I'M GONNA
ASK QUESTION ALSO P. JEANNIE
AND OF OUR STATE AGENCIES HERE
BUT. HOW WHAT UNDER WHAT
DEFINITION ARE YOU YOU YOU LIST
A LOT OF CRITICAL FACILITIES.
AND VULNERABLE PEOPLE WHAT HOW
ARE YOU DEFINING THAT IN
SCOPING THAT THAT DATA SET IF
YOU WILL YEAH WE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED FACILITIES WHERE WE
DON'T ALREADY HAVE BACKUP
GENERATION OR POWER STORAGE. WE
HAVE ESSENTIALLY RUN VARIOUS
SCENARIOS IN WHICH WE ARE
IMAGINING WHAT ARE THE MOST
CRITICAL URGENT RESPONSES AND
NEEDS. FIRE STATIONS OF COURSE.
AND. WE ARE WITH MANY PARTNERS
LIKE THE WATER DISTRICT AND
COUNTY AND SO FORTH IDENTIFYING
THOSE. CRITICAL FIRST
RESPONDERS. THAT WOULD BE MOST
TENDER AND AGAIN I THINK RAY
WE'RE IN ARTICLE PROBABLY BEST
IDENTIFY THE PROCESS FOR DOING
SO BUT WE'VE EXTENSIVELY
ANALYZE THIS WE THINK WE'VE GOT
A COST SOMEWHERE ON THE ORDER
OF ABOUT FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
JUST TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
PLACE. WHERE NGUYEN EXTENDED
DOWN OF A DAY OR TWO WE AT
LEAST HAVE THE FACILITIES
ONLINE TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
EMERGING. NEEDS AND THAT AND
THAT COST CORRELATES TO.
GETTING THEM TEMPORARY POWER
TRIP KEEPING IS THAT IS THAT
ABOUT LIKE I DIESEL GENERATOR
YES I DON'T NURSING HOME YES SO
ARE YOU NOT THINKING AND ABOUT
ALTERNATIVE POWER SOURCES LIKE
FUEL CELLS SO THERE'S NO ROOM.
VERY MUCH CONSIDERING FUEL
CELLS BUT PROBABLY EVEN MORE
SOLAR WITH BETTER STORAGE. THAT
IS OBVIOUSLY THE HOLY GRAIL WE
KNOW THAT THAT TAKES. MORE TIME
HI BUT FROM PLANNING AND MORE
RESOURCES BUT WE ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IT'S WELL WORTH THE
EFFORT WE NOW. NEXT DOOR
FREMONT TO DOING. THAT WAS
SEVERAL FIRE STATIONS AND WERE
LOOKING CAREFULLY AT THAT MODEL.
THANK SENATOR STERN AND THANK
YOU MISTER MAYOR APPRECIATE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE COMMENTS
VERY INSIGHTFUL THANK YOU.
SENATOR DODD AND SENATOR
REQUIRE. YET TO MISS THING.
YEAH IT SEEMS TO ME AS WE TALK
WHO IS WE LOOK AT THESE MAJOR
POPULATION CENTERS THAT ARE
NEAR THE WILL EAT. IT SEEMS
LIKE INVESTMENTS IN TRIED TO
TARGET THOSE AND NOT HAVE. YOUR
MAJOR SHUTDOWNS A MAJOR
POPULATION AREAS THAT ARE NO
WHERE NEAR. WHERE THERE'S
REALLY A SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
WILDLAND FIRE IS SHOULD BE
PRIMARY. BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT SAN FRANCISCO OR YOU LOOK AT
SANTA SAY YOU LOOK AT OAKLAND.
YEAH THERE'S A HUGE POPULATION
AREA AND. IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
THE COST OF GOING THROUGH AND
SUPPORTING. YEAH PUBLIC SAFETY
pDIFFERENT YOU KNOW ENTITIES
JUST IS PROBABLY PALES IN
COMPARISON TO. IT OUT AS MUCH
SMALLER INVESTMENT IN YOUR IN
TARGETING IN TARGETING THE GRIT
SO I I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT.
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT IN THAT
AREA AND THEN THE OTHER THINGS
I THINK THAT THE WHAT THE MAYOR
DID COME UP WITH IN TERMS OF
HIS CONCERNS AND QUESTIONS AND
I REALLY THINK WE'RE REALLY
GONNA NEED THESE TYPE OF
SERVICES YOU'LL BE OF MUCH LESS
OF INVESTMENT IN SMALLER
COMMUNITIES LIKE ANGLER.
CALISTOGA IN MY DISTRICT OR
MANY SMALL COMMUNITIES IN
SENATOR MAGUIRE'S DISTRICT
BECAUSE THEY ARE RIGHT THERE
GROUND ZERO AND LET ME TELL
YOU. YOU DID THE POWER SHUT OFF
IN CALISTOGA LAST YEAR I'VE
NEVER SEEN A BETTER. PLAN
EXECUTED TO GET THE POWER OFF
BUT CANDIDLY TO GET IT BACK ON
I'VE NEVER SEEN A WORSE YEAH
PLANNED SO THAT NEED THE EL
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND BY
THE WAY. ALL THESE PEOPLE
DIDN'T KNOW. WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WHEN THE POWER WAS GONNA COME
BACK ON THERE WAS NO
REPRESENTATION BY PGD ANYWHERE
IN THE COMMUNITY AND THEN AT
THE END. WE FOUND OUT TWO WEEKS
LATER THERE WERE TWENTY SEVEN
LINES ON THE GROUND. ALL COULD
HAVE BEEN IGNITION POINTS. FOR
MORE FIRES AND NOBODY EVEN KNEW
ABOUT IT SO IT'S KIND OF LIKE
YOU NEED TO HELP YOURSELF BY
KEEPING THE COMMUNITIES AFTER
THE SHUTDOWN INFORMED OF WHAT'S
GOING ON SO SORRY ABOUT THAT
TWO PART QUESTION NO PROBLEM
THANK YOU CENTER FOR THAT FOR
THE QUESTION AND- I DON'T HIT
ON ALL OF THEM PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO. LET ME KNOW CLINIC WE MORE
WITH YOU I IN TERMS OF THE-
CRITICAL NATURE OF THE FEEDBACK
WE RECEIVED AND RIGHTFULLY SO
AFTER OCTOBER EVENT LAST YEAR
ON THE RESTORATION SIDE WHICH
IS EXACTLY. WHY WE'VE PUT A
DEDICATED FOCUS TO THAT IT WAS
OUR FIRST EVENT THAT WE HAD
EVER. IMPLEMENTED WITHIN P.
GINNY OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR A
LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED THAT
CAME OUT OF THAT. AND ARE
UNWAVERING FOCUS IS NOT JUST TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE DOING THIS
AND BEING VERY MINDFUL FROM A
SAFETY STANDPOINT. BUT ON THE
BACKEND ON THE RE ENERGIZE
ATION. INSPECTING OUR ASSETS AS
SAFELY AND AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND RE ENERGIZING. IN
IN THAT SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME AS
POSSIBLE SO WE'VE GOT ALL OF
OUR CONTROL CENTERS ENGAGED NOW
WE'RE DOING INTERNAL EXERCISES
WE'VE GOT OUR LOCAL PERSONNEL.
THAT MANAGE THOSE CIRCUITS IN
YOUR EACH OF YOUR RESPECTIVE
DISTRICTS. TO INSURE THEY'RE
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
SWITCHING DEVICES SO THAT
THERE'S A GAME PLAN IN TERMS
AWARD WE GO AND REALLY LEVERAGE
THE COMBINATION OF BOTH. ARIEL
AND A GROUND FLEET TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS WHERE WE WERE LAST
YEAR WE WERE PART PRIMARILY
DEPEND UPON. ARE QUALIFIED A
LINE MEN ON THE GROUND DOING
GATE AND IT TOOK QUITE A BIT OF
TIME TO INSPECT EVERY INCH OF
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED MILES THAT
WILL SHUT DOWN AS A RESULT OF
THAT WE HAVE MUCH. AND FAR
BETTER CAPABILITIES GOING INTO
THIS YEAR IN REGARDS TO THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE MAYOR RESPECTFULLY FROM
THAT THE CITY OF SAN JOSE WE
WELCOME INITIAL IDEAS IN TERMS
OF HOW MORE EFFECTIVELY WE CAN
COMMUNICATE WE HAVE ENGAGED
WITH THE CITY OF SAN JOSE ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS IN REGARDS
TO OUR PROTOCOLS. HOW WE WOULD
GO ABOUT THE NOTIFICATION
PROCESS WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
MANY DIFFERENT OF THE LOCAL
ENTITIES WITHIN YOUR RESPECTIVE
DISTRICTS TO SIGN NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS SO WE CAN GIVE THEM
SPECIFIC INFORMATION IN REGARDS
TO THE MEDICAL BASELINE
CUSTOMERS WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED
THEIR ADDRESSES INCLUDING
CRITICAL AN ESSENTIAL SERVICES
SO THOSE ARE ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY DOING AS
AS PART OF THIS PROCESS SORRY
IF I MISSED A ANY ANY OTHER
QUESTION THAT YOU HAD IN THERE.
JUST LIKE SPECIFICALLY CITY BIG
CITY CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
OAKLAND SAN JOSE HOW DO WE RE
DIRECT POWER SO THAT MAJOR THAT
I JUST THINK THAT JUST
MAGNIFIES PROBLEMS IN IN IN OUR
ANTICIPATION IS THAT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A POTENTIAL PS PS
WOULD IMPACT MORE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THE
HIGH FAR THREAT DISTRICTS THAT
ARE IN THAT URBAN WILDLAND
INTERFACE. ME OBVIOUSLY WE'LL
PUT THAT IN ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE GOT OUT AND COMMUNICATE
TO THE FIVE MILLION CUSTOMERS
IS THE INTER CONNECTED NATURE
OF OUR GREAT WITH TRANSMISSION
AND DISTRIBUTION OF DIFFICULT
TO BE ABLE TO RELY ON HISTORY
ACROSS THE BOARD RIGHT IN TERMS
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH THE
WEATHER AND CLIMATOLOGY AND OUR
CONCERN HERE IS IF WE DO SEE A
EXTREME TOP OF A WEATHER EVENT
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN
PREVIOUSLY. AND THERE IS A
POTENTIAL IMPACT A TRANSMISSION
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKINGVERY VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE SERENA AND THE CAL I SO
TEAM BECAUSE THEY'RE ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING THAT
GRADE BUT IN THE INSTANCE WHERE
THERE'S A POTENTIAL IMPACT OF
THE TRANSMISSION. LINE IS THE
REASON WHY WE WANT OUT A. MADE
THOSE COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE
FIVE MILLION CUSTOMERS WE
ANTICIPATE THE LIKELY WHO'S
GOING TO BE LOWER ESPECIALLY
WITH IN THOSE CITIES AND CONDOS
DENSE URBAN AREAS. AND WHERE WE
HAVE OUR DISTRIBUTION CIRCUITS
THAT ARE TRAVERSING THE HIGH
FALL RISK AREAS BUT ALSO
PROVIDE SERVICE. TO THOSE
DENSER YES THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE
WE ARE INSTALLING OUR
SOCIALIZATION DEVICES SO THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY FIND WAYS TO BE
ABLE TO ISOLATE THOSE CIRCUITS.
THAT ARE TRAVERSING THE HIGH
FAR RISK AREA AND PERCENT
POWER. AROUND TO AN AREA OF A
LOWER RISK THAT COULD STILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO
THAT URBAN. DENSITY OF BUT
COMMUNITY SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT
OUR FOCUS AND HOW WE'RE
PRIORITIZING. WHERE WERE
INSTALLING THE SOCIALIZATION
DEVICES. WITH THAT ARE REQUIRED.
THANK YU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
JUST TO HAVE SOME COMMENTS IN
SOME QUESTIONS FOR A P. GENIES
WELLS BECAUSE COMMISSION MISTER
IF THAT'S OKAY AND JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HOSTING TODAY AND
JUST SAYING JUST REALIZED THAT
MY FRUSTRATION TODAY'S NOT
DIRECTED TO PERSONALLY BUT TO
THE TO P. JEANNIE AND AT
REPRESENT AN AREA BETWEEN
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE IN OREGON
BORDER SHARING MY SENATOR DIED
UP WE'VE BEEN HIT HARDER THAN.
MOST ANYWHERE ELSE WHEN IT
COMES A WHILE AND FIRES AND WE
ARE IN THE REGION THAT HAS HAD
THAT IS UNDER THREAT SEVERAL
TIMES DURING THE FIRE SEASON
AND I BELIEVE THAT TRUST HAS TO
BE EARNED IN P. JEANNIE HAS A
LONG WAY TO GO TO BE TRUSTED I
WITHIN YOUR SERVICE TERRITORY
QUITE CANDIDLY NOT A TO GIVE
YOU SINCE THE SPECIFICS AND-
YOU KEEP MENTIONING THAT YOU
ARE COMMUNICATING WITH YOUR
FIVE MILLION CUSTOMERS IN THE
YOU'VE GONE OUT AND HAD SEVEN
HUNDRED DIFFERENT MEETINGS
WITH. PUBLIC AGENCIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SERVICE CLUBS
EXCEPT SO THERE WAS A MEETING
WITH THE MEDICINE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HERE ABOUT A
MONTH MONTH AND A HALF AGO. AND
EVERYONE NEARLY EVERY QUESTION
THAT WAS ASKED OF THE. TEAM
THAT SHOWED UP COULDN'T BE
ANSWER AND GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES. ARE THE TEAM SAID
THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE SIX
HUNDRED FIRE CAMERAS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE. DEPLOYED HOW MANY
MENDOCINO COUNTY WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT YOU'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON
UNDERGROUND IN OF LINES HOW
MANY MILES ALIGNS MINUTES YOU
KNOW COUNTY WE DON'T KNOW. WHAT
IS YOUR STRATEGY WHEN IT COMES
TO TURNING OFF THE POWER IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY. THE COULD NOT
SHARE. TALK ABOUT PRIORITIES
WHAT ARE YOUR PRIORITIES IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY THEY DIDN'T
AND COULD NOT SHARE WITH THE
PRAIRIES WOULD BE WHEN IT COMES
TO. THAT TURNING OFF THE POWER.
IN LAKE COUNTY NOW I WILL SAY
IT WAS YOUR FIRST TIME
UNFORTUNATELY POORLY COUNTY.
WAS THE GUINEA PIG IN ALL OF
THIS. LESS THAN EIGHT HOURS OF
THE SHARE FINDING OUT THAT
POWER IS GOING TO BE TURNED OFF
HE JIMMY WOULD NOT SHARE THOSE
RUN THREE MACHINES OVER SIX
HUNDRED. AND IT WAS THE FIRST
TIME THE FIRST TIME THEY
LEARNED THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
FIGHT SIGNED A NON DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENT. WHICH IS RIDICULOUS
SO. ALL OF THIS SHOULD HAVE
BEEN THOUGHT OF. PRIOR TO
MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE
UTILITIES IN THE STATE THAT
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR YEARS
THERE UTILITIES IN THE MIDWEST
AND BEEN DOING THIS FOR YEARS.
THIS IS BEEN SUCH A HAP HAZARD
APPROACH. AND NOW WE'RE IN YEAR
IN WERE KNEE DEEP IN THIS. AND
I CAN BE HONEST. I THE
FRUSTRATION IS GROWING. BECAUSE
THE FOLKS WERE OUT ON THE FRONT
LINES TRYING TO BE ABLE TO TELL
THE MESSAGE OF WHAT PHÑ SHOULD
BE PREPARED FOR DON'T EVEN HAVE
THE MESSAGE THEY SHOULD TELL
I'M GONNA CONTINUE YOU TOLD A
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
LIKE PORT THAT THEY WOULD LOSE
POWER THEY CANCEL CLASSES THE
POWER EVERYONE OFF EVERYONE
OFF AND THEN THEY COULDN'T
GET A HOLD OF THE P.
JEANNIE REPRESENTATIVE I'M
GONNA CONTINUE OUR WHEN
ASKED ABOUT THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DEVICES THAT ARE BEING
INSTALLED HOW MUCH OF THE
SERVICE TERRITORY IS THAT
IMPACTING THERE WAS NO ANSWER
YOU KNOW HOW MANY CUSTOMERS
OF THOSE HUNDRED FIFTY DEVICES
WHY ACTUALLY SERVE WITHIN THE
SERVICE TERRITORY THIRTEEN
SOLVE THE YOU HAD SAID THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO BETTER
PINPOINT WELL AS POWER OUTAGES
ARE IT'S IT'S IT'S ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND IS WHAT IT
MITIGATES AND I CAN I EXPLAIN
HOW THAT -- COMES ABOUT BUT
I MEAN I I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT I'M JUST WHERE THEY THE
QUESTION WAS WHERE WAS GOING TO
BE NOT TO YOU BUT THIS IS THE
QUESTIONS WHERE WAS GOING TO BE
WEARING THE SERVICE TERRITORY
IS THERE ON THE NORTH COAST
THEY COULDN'T ANSWER MR SO
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT OFFICER
RICKY SERVICES FOR A MOMENT I
THINK IT'S GREAT THAT DABABNEH
WARNING CENTER AND BY THE WAY
WE LOVE MARKER DUTY HE'S AN
ANGEL FOR EVER -- ON THE NORTH
COAST AND WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
TO THE ENTIRE -- ESTEEM
HE JENNY LEADING THE WARNING
CENTER NOW IS CRITICAL BUT
WHAT IS I BELIEVE JUSTICE
CRITICAL IS MAKING SURE THAT
THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND WHEN AND
HOW LONG TO EXPECT AN OUTAGE
FOR SO THAT'S WHY CANDIDLY
AND I'M NOT GONNA TALK ABOUT
IN DEPTH HERE WORD MANSON
LEGISLATION TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT MANDATED THAT P.
GINNY HAS TO WORK WITH
HOSPITALS HAS TO WERE IN THANK
YOU TO SENATOR DODD WHO REALLY
DEFINED WITH THESE CRITICAL
CARE FACILITIES ARE AND NOT A
ONE HE'S LED THIS BUT FOCUSING
ON MANDATED ADVANCE WARNING
FOR HOSPITALS NINE ONE ONE
CALL CENTERS POLICE FIRE SHARE
SIX ADDRESS BECAUSE WE CAN'T
COUNT ON UTILITY FOR BEING ON
THE PROVIDE THAT IN DEPTH AND
I'M EARLY WARNING MOBILE HOME
PARKS THERE ARE MILLIONS IN
THE STATE TO LIVE IN MOBILE
HOME PARKS MOST MOBILE HOME
PARK SEVEN MASTER METER SO
WHEN YOUR REPRESENTATIVES
RAST HOW YOU CAN GET THE
INFORMATION ABOUT POWER
OUTAGES TO ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO
DON'T HAVE METERS THEY CAN'T
SO SOME OF THE MOST MEDICALLY
FRAGILE IN SENIOR IN THIS
STATE WHO LIVE IN MOBILE
HOME PARKS HAVE ONE METER
NOT ALL BUT MOST OF ONE METER
AND THAT'S THE OWNER OR THE
OWNER'S REPRESENTATIVE THEY
WILL GET A NOTICE BUT THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MOBILE
HOMES IN THE STATE WILL NOT
THAT'S A HUGE GAP THAT WE HAVE
AND THEY'RE STILL NO ANSWER
TO THAT AGAIN I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT MEDICALLY FRAGILE IN
SOME OF THE OLDER FOLKS WHO
ARE LIVING HERE IN THE STATE
THIS IS A HUGE CONCERN AND
WE'RE YEAR IN OVER CONTINUE
TO DEPLOY THESE POWER OUTAGES
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY DAMN
ANSWERS AND AGAIN I WILL KEEP
MY COOL HERE I SO THE OTHER
ITEM IS THE CUSTOMER RESOURCE
CENTERS ARE THEY BEING DEPLOYED
THEY ARE AND WE HAVE A SHE DID
DEPLOY ONE IN ORVILLE -- IN THE
JUNE EIGHTH AND NINTH -- EVENT
THAT WE DID WE HAVE AGREEMENTS
IN PLACE WITH FIFTEEN OF THEM
-- AND WE'RE TARGETING MORE
THAN A HUNDRED OKAY SO I LOOKED
A BIT TO GET MORE INFORMATION
ON THAT BECAUSE THAT IS NEVER
COME UP IN ANY PRESENTATIONS
IN THE BORDERS TO THE END I
APPRECIATE THE OUTRAGE BUT
I'D LIKE TO GET INFORMATION IF
IT IF YOU BE WILLING LIKE TO
HAVE AN OFFLINE CONVERSATION
ON THAT THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL HAPPY TO OKAY THAT'S
GREAT AND HAVE YOU RESPOND
STING AND AGAIN I'M NOT TARGET
JUST TO YOU SIR SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE YOU KNOW THAT THIS
IS NOT PERSONAL AT AT TOWARD
YOU IS PERSONAL FOR ME BECAUSE
I FEEL EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED
YOU COULD TELL I'M GONNA END
HERE WITH THE PC I'D LIKE TO
HEAR SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE PC
IS CONCERNED ABOUT ABOUT WHAT
THEY'VE SEEN IN HOW THESE OF
ROLLED OUT SPECIFICS I HEAR
YOU SAY THAT YOU WANT TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS AFTER THE FACT
I'VE HEARD YOU SAY YOU WANT
FEEDBACK MECHANISMS WHAT IS IT
SPECIFICALLY HERE TODAY THAT
YOU WANT TO SEE CHANGE FROM P.
JEANNIE AND HOW THESE OF
ROLLED OUT AND I LIKE TO
GO TO GET DETAILS FROM YOU
IN THIS HEARING ABOUT THE
CONCERNS I'VE SHARED CONCERN
SPECIFICALLY I LIKE TO GO TO
HEAR YOUR CONCERNS SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT YOUR -- HOW THESE
HAVE PERFORMED IN WHERE YOU
THINK WE SHOULD IMPROVE UPON
MISTER CHAIR OF STOP TALKING
I APOLOGIZE A WINNER FOR SO
LONG AND IT IS INTERESTING AND
THANK SO THANK YOU SIR MCGUIRE
I SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION
-- AND I I THINK A LOT OF
THE EXAMPLES THAT YOU WERE
ALLUDING TO -- WAR FROM THE
OCTOBER -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN
-- EVENT I ACTUALLY DIRECTLY
ENGAGED WITH THAT COMMUNITY
THE MEDICINE KIND OF OUR
SUPERVISORS PRESENTATION WAS
LIKE A MONTH MONTH AND A HALF
AGO JUST A MAJORITY EXAMPLE
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT WITH
THE THE THE THE SCHOOL ITSELF
GETTING NOTIFIED -- AND AND NOT
ACTUALLY GO TO THE DEALER JUST
ATION -- WE OWN IT -- I OWN IT
ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU SAID
I OWN IT RIGHT EN -- MAKING
A COMMITMENT THAT -- BERGEN
REVERSING WE CAN TO ENSURE
WERE SATISFYING THE NEEDS AND
THE INTEREST IN REGARDS TO
THE INFORMATION THAT OUR TEAM
SHOULD REALLY BE PROVIDING TO
YOU -- BE ONE EXAMPLE I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU BECAUSE I WAS
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT LAKE
COUNTY THERE WERE TWO OR THREE
WEATHER STATIONS OVER PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE AS PART OF THE WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE WITH INSTALL
THIRTY MORE WEATHER STATIONS
NOW BECAUSE THAT IS ONE OF THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE CONTINUE
TO SEE A HIGHER LIKELIHOOD
OF A POTENTIAL PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF SO WE HAVE THAT
TYPE OF INFORMATION AVAILABLE
AND THE FACT THAT THAT'S NOT
BEING SURE TO SOME OF THESE
MEETINGS ISLAND SO I WILL TAKE
THAT BACK IN A SURE THAT WE
DO RIGHT BY YOU IN RIGHT BY
ALL OF THE OTHER COMMUNITIES
IN THAT REGARD IN REGARDS
TO THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR WE HAD
MANY AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO
COLLABORATE WITH ALL OF THE
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE THE
THE THE LOCAL ENTITIES AND
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO GIVE
TO FEEDBACK I CAN'T FIX WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT FOR
IF IF THERE'S THINGS THAT ARE
NOT HITTING THE MARK HELP US
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE SOME OF THOSE
WAYS ASSISTANT IS WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT FOR A MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR CORPORATION SOME OF THE
BRIGHTEST MINDS IN THE STATE
WHERE YOU COORDINATING WITH
UTILITIES ACROSS THIS NATION
IN THE STATE AND FIGURING
OUT WHAT IS WORK FOR THEM BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY WHAT NOT TO
DO AND I GOTTA BE HONEST I
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT SO WHY ARE
YOU EXPECTING US TO PROVIDE
YOU FEEDBACK WHEN YOU ALREADY
EXPERTS RESTRICTED SO I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IT TAKES
FEEDBACK FROM FOLKS LIKE US
ON THIS DIES INDIVIDUALS OUT
IN THE FIELD WHEN THEY SHOULD
BE COORDINATED WITH YOUR
PEERS WITH OTHER UTILITIES
I APOLOGIZE RESPECTFUL JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY MYSELF SO SO
THAT FEEDBACK WAS IN REGARDS
TO HOW BEST TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THAT PERSPECTIVE A
CITY OF COMMUNITY OR COUNTY
BECAUSE WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT
THE COMMUNICATION NEED IN
THE COMMUNICATION CHANNEL IS
DIFFERENT BY TYPE OF CUSTOMER
BY TYPE OF CITY BY TOP OF
COUNTING BY TOP OF COMMUNITY
AND THAT THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THE ASK IS OFF FROM US AND
WE WILL ABSOLUTELY COME TO
THE TABLE -- AND CO CREATE
AND DELIVER ON WHAT'S NEEDED
OKAY I I THINK WHAT I'D LIKE
TO DO IS GET THIS SPECIFIC
ITEMS THAT I BROUGHT FORWARD
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO I'M NOT
TO BELABOR THE POINT MISTER
CHAIR WELL AS I DO GO OFFLINE
MISSING WITH YOU ON NO AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEIR MCGUIRE AND I THINK YOU
CAN CERTAINLY TAKE AS MUCH
TIME TODAY AS AS YOU'D LIKE THE
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO TIME PLAN
FOR THIS HEARING THE ISSUES
ARE IMPORTANT AND WE WILL TAKE
WHATEVER TIME IS NECESSARY
AND I THINK MISTER SINGH WILL
APPROPRIATELY RESPOND TO YOUR
QUESTIONS AND THE EITHER TODAY
AFTER THE MEETING OR AFTER THE
HEARING OR IT AT ANOTHER TIME
I DON'T THINK HE'S TRYING TO
WORK I THINK YOU HAD A QUESTION
OF THE PCS PLEASE THANK YOU
AND JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
I GOT THE QUESTION RIGHT THE
QUESTION WAS WOULD WE WOULD
LIKE OF THE AS THE PC TO SEE
UTILITIES TO THE FRONT WHEN
IT COMES TO OF PS PS PROGRAMS
YEAH WE'RE WE'RE HEARING
RIGHT RIGHT AND I THINK THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN CANDIDLY QUITE
A FEW BLUNDERS WE SEE THEM
ON THE CITY AND COMMUNITY
LEVEL WHAT DO YOU SEEN ON THE
STATE LEVEL AS A REGULATOR
HOME A THINK ONE MAJOR
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IS THE
DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION ONE
BIG DIFFERENCE THAT I SEE AS
THE REGULATOR THAT GETS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE EVENTS
AND ACTUALLY BE AT THE EEOC
WHETHER IT'S AT THE UTILITY OR
-- -- WE US IS THE CHALLENGE
OF GETTING INFORMATION OUT
ANYTHING HISTORICALLY UTILITIES
OR VERY CONCERNED WITH GETTING
INFORMATION OUT INTO THE
PUBLIC THAT'S LEADER PROVED
TO BE INCORRECT THAT SENSE TO
BE CHALLENGING ALL KINDS OF
-- EMERGENCY AND RESTORATION
EVENTS INTERNALLY L.
HAVING WORKED IN UTILITIES
WITH UTILITIES IN DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES I KNOW THE HEALTH
MUCH MORE ACCURATE RESTORATION
AN OUTAGE ELM -- -- --
PREDICTIONS THAT THE TYPICALLY
PUBLICLY SHARE ALL BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO TELL THE CUSTOMER
THAT THE GETTING TO BE ABLE TO
TURN THEM ALL AND ALL AND THEN
NOT BE ABLE TO DO SO AND EITHER
JUST THE INNOCENT JUST TO USE
THE EXAMPLE OF RESTORATION
FROM MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE
UTILITY TYPICALLY DOES IS THE
YOU KNOW YOU HOW THE WEATHER
EVENT GO THROUGH YOU HAVE A
LINES OUT TO GET THIS STARTED
GOING OUT INSPECTING IN THOSE
THAT COLLECTING MORE AND MORE
INFORMATION THEY CONSISTENTLY
UPDATING THEIR INTERNAL PLANS
AS TO WHEN THE THINGS THEY CAN
GET CUSTOMER OF ON AND IN WHAT
ORDER BUT THOSE PLANS CHANGED
IT IS ALWAYS A CHALLENGE A
THING FROM AN OPERATOR'S POINTS
OF VIEW IS IF YOU SPEAK THROUGH
EARLY AND THAT INFORMATION
LEADER PROVED TO BE INCORRECT
ELEMENT THEY NEED YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE A CHALLENGE OF EXPLAINING
WHY YOU KNOW YOU PUT THAT
INFORMATION OUT THERE AND THE
CONFUSION OF THE POTENTIALLY
CREATED SO A THINK WE ARE THE
UTILITIES TYPICALLY ARE IS ON
THE MORE CONSERVATIVE SIDE OF
THAT SPECTRUM WITH THE ONE TO
BE SURE BEFORE THE SPEAK BY A
THINK ILL YOU KNOW IT CREATES
ALL ALONG -- OF EFFORTS THAN
FOR OTHER AND CITIES LAY COOL
WE ASK AND THE PC TO EXTRACT
THAT INFORMATION OUT OF THE
UTILITIES AND TRY TO GET THAT
OUT INTO THE PUBLIC DOMAIN AND
I THINK IF MORE INFORMATION
COULD BE SHARED OLD ACTIVELY
BUY UTILITIES WILL MORE BROADLY
-- A THINK IT COULD HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THOSE OLD
FRICTIONS HELLO MY A.
B. HE THINK YOU KNOW OUTSIDE
ALL OF WORKING EL UNIT IT
SO THAT THAT I THINK IS ONE
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE HAVING
IS GETTING INFORMATION
OUT THERE ARE -- JUST MORE
INFORMATION A MAKING IT PUBLIC
ALL YOU NEED THE SECOND IS SO
FULL AWAITING THE L.
DIRECTIONS OF MY OLD SCHOOL
WE ASSN PHONES IT'LL FRAMEWORK
THE VIN SOME CHALLENGES
AROUND SO COULD OVER THE
HOW THE UTILITIES HAVE BEEN
MESSAGING ELM ALL ROUNDS SO
THERE OF VANS ESPECIALLY IN
HOW THEY'RE ASSESSING THE
RISK GOAL OF -- WILD FIRES
AND THE RISK SPECIFICALLY
TO THEIR FACILITIES VERSES
THE OVERALL -- L.
WILDFIRE THREAT CONDITIONS
IN STATE THE ROOM PARTICULAR
REGION SO YOU THINK YOU THE
DOTS IN THE AREA WE ARE ALL
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE UTILITIES
IMPROVE THEIR PERFORMANCE
NOW AND REALLY FOLLOW THE
GUIDELINES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED FOR THE STATE'S AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR MESSAGING
IS COORDINATED ELLIS THROUGH
THE ENTIRE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
SYSTEM THE OTHER PART I WOULD
SAY IS A COLLABORATION ACROSS
IS THREE ARE YOU USE THAT'S
ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE A THINK
OF BETWEEN -- WE US IN THE
PEACE YOU'VE PROBABLY SPEND
THE MOST TIME ON IS JUST TRYING
TO GET ME THROUGH UTILITIES
TO WORK TOGETHER AND SPEAK THE
SAME LANGUAGE AND IS BEING EL
RESISTANCE FROM FROM HOME TO
DO THAT ON THEIR OWN SO UNLESS
WE'RE ACTUALLY GETTING THEM
WHEN THE MEETING AND AND AND
DRIVING TO A STANDARD PROCEDURE
ON SOMETHING AND THEN HOVERING
OVER THEM TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY FOLLOWING IT YOU
KNOW LOVE TO THEIR OWN DEVICES
THE GO ON INTO THEIR OWN SILO
THEY'RE NOT GEOGRAPHICALLY
THAT YOU NEED TO HELP SEPARATE
GEOGRAPHIES AND FOOT PRINTS
AND SO IT'S VERY EASY FOR THEM
TO JUST GO INTO THEIR DOMAIN
AND NOT THINK ABOUT THERE'S
THIS SISTER UTILITIES BEFORE US
WERE MANAGING IT AT THE STATE
LEVEL SO THESE DIFFERENCES
THAT THEY MAY WORK FOR THEM
OPERATIONALLY LOCALLY AND
BROKE FOR EXAMPLE FOR SEEN YEAR
AGO YOU KNOW THEY'VE HAD THIS
PROGRAM FOR QUITE A LONG TIME
NO A LOT OF BEST PRACTICES THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY WORK FOR THE
OTHER TWO UTILITIES G.
TO THE SCALE AND SO YOU KNOW
WE HAVE KIND OF CHALLENGES
LAKE EITHER IS D.
G. NEED NOT WANTING TO CHANGE
WHAT ALREADY WORKS FOR THEM
AND IT'S BEEN PROVEN IN THE
SCENE DIEGO COMMUNITY ALL BUT
YOU KNOW WE IF WE HEALTH THREE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS IN YOU KNOW
THESE ARE NOT ONLY UTILITIES
WILL HELP IN THE STATE OF
WOULD KIND OF START CARVING
IN NOW THE EVERYBODY DOES IT
DIFFERENTLY IT DISINTEGRATES
AND BECOMES VERY VERY DIFFERENT
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE ACROSS
THE STATE LINE SLEEPING PRO
ACTIVE COLLABORATION ACROSS
OF THREE I WE USE AND ALSO
FRANKLY WITH OTHER UTILITIES
AND IN THE STATE SO THAT WE
A STATE AGENCIES WILL HAVE
TO CONSTANTLY BE DRAGGING
THE MAN TO HAVE A CONSISTENT
APPROACH TO THIS WOULD BE
EXTREMELY ALL EXTREMELY HOPEFUL
THANK YOU THANK YOU RIVERS
CENTERS DON'T THANK YOU --
AND AND AGAINST HER THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THIS HEARING AND
LET ME SAY THAT -- I I REALLY
-- APPLIED MY MY COLLEAGUES
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND DODD FOR AN
DURING A LOT OF MORBIDITY AND
MORTALITY IN THEIR DISTRICTS
IT VERY WELL COULD HAVE BEEN
IN MY DISTRICT I HAD THE
CRANSTON FIRE AND THE HOLY
FIRE -- THE CRANSTON FIRE WAS
IN THE IDYLLWILD AREA THAT AS
IN -- VERY LIMITED INGRESS AND
EGRESS HAD THAT FIRE STARTED
AT THE TOP OF THE MOUNTAIN
INSTEAD OF THE BOTTOM OF THE
MOUNTAIN WE'D BE TALKING ABOUT
NOT NECESSARILY -- HUNDRED OR
TWO HUNDRED GUESTS WE TALKING
ABOUT MAYBE A COUPLE THOUSAND
US SO THIS THIS CONVERSATION OR
HAVING TODAY IS VERY IMPORTANT
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT POINTS THAT I WANT
TO MAKE TODAY IT'S A WE CAN NO
LONGER AFFORD TO DISCOVER OUR
FAILURES WITH MORE FIRE OFFENSE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OF NUMBER ONE -- A DEATH IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS JUST AS
IS A FAT AS A DEATH IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE TO DO
WE CAN NOW TO LIMIT THE THE
MORBIDITY MORTALITY ASSOCIATE
WITH WILDFIRES ARE BECOMING
MUCH MORE COMMON -- IN THE
STATE OF OF CALIFORNIA SO WITH
THAT -- TO MR SAYING IT IT DOES
YOUR COMPANY -- LOOK AT WHAT
I WOULD CALL RISK QUANTIFIERS
OWNS IN OTHER WORDS AN AREA
IN SAN FRANCISCO MAY NOT HAVE
THE THE VULNERABILITY OF A
WILDFIRE THAN SAY IDYLLWILD
OF MY DISTRICT OR IN SOME OF
THE MORE RURAL AREAS OF SEND
REQUIRES DISTRICT -- JU JU
OUTLINED THOSE HIGH RISK AREAS
WE WE DO -- SENATOR AND THAT'S
PART OF WHAT GOES INTO OUR
RISK PARTICIPATION PROCESS TO
HELP INFORM OUR RISK REDUCTION
MEASURES SO THINGS AROUND THE
REFERENCE A SORT OF REQUIRE
MADE ABOUT THE SIX HUNDRED
HIGH DEFINITION CAMERAS THAT'S
INTENDED TO BE A MULTI YEAR
PROGRAM -- BY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO -- BUT WAR WERE INSTALLING
AND WE'RE WE'VE INSTALLED A
FIFTY THIS YEAR RIGHT AND ON
A PATH TO DO ALMOST DOUBLE
THAT IS INFORMED BY THOSE RISK
REDUCTION MEASURES WHICH IS
WHAT WE SEE THE POTENTIAL OUR
DYEABLE TYPE OF WIND PATTERNS
WHAT WE SEE THE EXTREME WIND
PATTERNS WHAT WE SEE EGRESS
INGRESS -- IMPLICATIONS OF
THOSE ARE ALL THE THINGS THAT
GO INTO THAT DECISION MAKING
PROCESS AND I AND APPRECIATE
THE GOOD WORK OF THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
-- SHE AND SHE TALKED ABOUT
-- CASCADING EVENTS THAT
ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT --
THE ENERGIZING IS ONE THING
GETTING THE ENERGY BACK ON
IS ANOTHER AND AGAIN I'LL
PUT MY MY FRIEND FROM -- NAPA
THAT -- IS IDENTIFIED THROUGH
LEGISLATION IMPORTANT -- RISK
FACTORS FOR PEOPLE THAT ON
RESPIRATORS AND -- EQUIPMENT
THE NEEDS ELECTRICITY FOR THEM
TO MAINTAIN THEM THEIR LIVES --
THESE HIGH RISK -- PEOPLE HAS
YOUR UTILITY EVER THOUGHT OF
-- IDENTIFYING THOSE HIGH RISK
RESIDENCES PEOPLE AND COMING UP
WITH THE REVERSE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM THAT IN THE EVENT OF A
POTENTIAL DE ENTERS ATION THAT
YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO CONTACT
THESE PEOPLE TO LET THEM KNOW
THAT THIS POSSIBILITY COULD
IN FACT BECOMING SO WHAT ONE
OF THE THINGS WE'RE DOING AND
AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED THOSE AS
OUR MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS
-- SO WE'VE BEEN PROACTIVE IN
REACHING OUT TO THE EXISTING
MEDICAL BASED ON CUSTOMERS AS
WELL AS THROUGH THE VARIOUS
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS THAT
WE HAVE WITH THE CITY'S THE
COMMUNITIES TO ENCOURAGE THE
MEDICAL BASED ON CUSTOMERS TO
SELF IDENTIFY THEMSELVES WITHIN
OUR SYSTEM AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A -- CUSTOMER CARE SYSTEM WE
WE HAVE AN ACCOUNT FOR EACH OF
THE RESPECTIVE MEDICAL BASED
ON CUSTOMERS THAT HAVE NOTIFIED
US OF THEIR DEPENDENCY ON A
-- ELECTRICITY FROM EMERGENCY
PERSPECTIVE AND AS PART OF OUR
NOTIFICATION PROCESS -- THIS
WHAT I WAS ALLUDING TO EARLIER
WE HAVE A PROACTIVE TOUCH
POINT WITH THE MEDICAL BASED ON
CUSTOMERS NOT ONLY DO WE SEND
A NOTIFICATION OUT -- BUT WE
EXPECT A POSITIVE CONFIRMATION
AN DURING THE EVENT ONE IT'S
WHEN WERE ACTED EMERGENCY
CENTER THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
COORDINATING ALL OF THIS AND
ALSO TRACKING HOW MANY OF THOSE
CUSTOMERS AND WHAT SPECIFIC
CUSTOMERS HAVE WE OBTAIN
POSITIVE CONFIRMATION FROM
AND WHERE WE HAVEN'T WE SENT
PERSONNEL OUT IN OUR TRUCKS TO
GO KNOCK ON THEIR DOORS TO DO
SO IN ADDITION TO THAT WE ARE
TO THE POINT THE SENATE MCGUIRE
MADE YOU KNOW TO THE -- AND
THE UNFORTUNATE ISSUE OF THE
EIGHT HOURS BEFORE LAKE COUNTY
IDENTIFYING THAT INDIA NEEDS
TO BE PUT IN PLACE THOSE ARE
THE CUSTOMER PRIVACY LAWS THAT
WE UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW EXISTS
WITHIN THE STATE THAT'S ONE
AREA WHERE WE COULD USE SOME
HELP BUT WE HAVE NOW NBA'S PRO
ACTIVELY THAT HAVE BEEN SET
UP I WOULD MORE THAN THIRTY
COUNTIES AND WE'RE PROVIDING
THAT TYPE OF INFORMATION TO A
SECURE PORTAL WITH MAPS WITH
THE AREAS WHERE WE ANTICIPATE
A HIGHER LIKELIHOOD OF A
POTENTIAL PS PS EVENT FOR
FACILITIES ARE SEVENTY CAVEAT
ABOVE INCLUDING THE CRITICAL
ESSENTIAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SPECIFICALLY THE MEDICAL BASED
ON CUSTOMERS YEAH AGAIN IT
SEEMS LIKE WITH EVERY MAJOR
FIRE WE WE LEARN ABOUT HOW
UNPREPARED WE ARE FOR THESE
FIRES -- WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP AND PROBABLY -- MANY OTHERS
THAT ARE SITTING ON THE DAIS
ARE FROM CALIFORNIA WHEN I WAS
IN GRAMMAR SCHOOL WE USED TO
HAVE EARTHQUAKE DRILLS SO WE
USED TO SOME ALARM USED TO GET
ANY THEIR DESKS AND COVER HEADS
AND STUFF -- HAS EVER BEEN ANY
THOUGHT TO HAVING A AN EXERCISE
A A PRACTICE P. S.
P. S. INCIDENT SO THAT INSTEAD
OF AN EMERGENCY SITUATION WHERE
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO FIGURE
THINGS OUT -- WE ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN IN THE
COMMUNITY -- AS AS ROSS PEROT
WON SAID THERE'S AT THE LAKE
ROSS PEROT SAID THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH STEALING A GOOD IDEA
FROM SOMEBODY ELSE SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THAT WITH
-- SDG ANY THAT DOES NOT WANT
TO RELIVE SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT THEY HAD TO AND OR OR --
A DECADE OR TWO AGO -- ERIC
ALSO BRINGS TO THE POINT CENTER
MCGUIRE SAID YOU KNOW REACH
OUT TO THESE OTHER STATES AND
FIND OUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING --
BUT WHEN I HEAR YOU SAY THAT
IT'S GONNA TAKE YEARS TO PUT
THESE CAMERAS IN PLACE WHEN
YOU HAVE THE ELECTRICAL LINES
TO PUT THOSE CAMERAS I MEAN
WHAT IS A COST YOU PER HOUR
EVERY EVERY HOUR THAT YOU BE
ENERGIZED AND YOU CAN'T GET
THAT ENERGY BACK ONTO YOUR YOUR
STOCKHOLDERS I'M SURE IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
PROBABLY PALE IN COMPARISON
TO WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO PUT
THESE REMOTE CAMERAS SAID THAT
YOU'D BE COMBINED BEST BUY FOR
FIVE BUCKS TEN BUCKS A CAMERA
-- I WOULD BELIEVE A COMPANY
WITH -- THIS PROFESSIONALS THAT
YOU HAVE -- THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT YOU HAVE YOU COVER WHAT
TWO THIRDS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU CAN AFFORD ANOTHER
MAJOR INCIDENT -- IN THE FUTURE
WITHOUT COMPLETELY DECIMATING
YOUR COUNTRY WHICH COMPANY
WHICH IS UNDER ASSAULT RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW --
PRIOR PRIOR PROBLEM SO -- HOW
CAN WE EXPEDITE YOUR ABILITY
TO EVALUATE YOUR INFRASTRUCTURE
POSTI AN URGES ASIAN TO GET
THAT ELECTRICITY BACK ON SAFELY
SO YOU DON'T CREATE ANOTHER
INCIDENT WITH THE EXISTING
TECHNOLOGY THAT EXISTS TODAY
WHEN YOU'VE GOT THE POWER RIGHT
AT YOUR DISPOSAL SO SO SO SO
RESPECT LASERS STONE OUR OUR
OUR FOCUS IS THE SAME AS YOURS
WHICH IS TO ENSURE THERE'S NO
-- WHILE FAR BECAUSE BY OUR
ELECTRICAL SYSTEM THAT THAT'S
THE UNWAVERING FOCUS AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT -- WITHIN
LESS THAN A SIX MONTH TIME
FRAME WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
ON RAMP NUMBER OF CONTRACTORS
LINEMEN VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WORKERS TO DO THE WORK ON
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE AS
SAFELY AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SOME OF THIS WORK IS HIGH HAS
RISEN NATURE -- AND WE ARE
DEPLOYING IN EMPLOYING THE
LATEST AND GREATEST TECHNOLOGY
MORE THAN HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
A MORE DETAILED DISCUSSION ON
THE AERIAL FLEET CAPABILITY
WE HAVE THE CAPABILITIES
WITH CAMERAS WITH LIGHT HOURS
ALL COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY THAT -- WE ARE
GOING TO BE EMPLOYING AS PART
OF A RESTORATION STRATEGY AND
IF THAT'S NOT ENOUGH WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR IDEAS ON WHAT
ELSE WE CAN DO WE'VE TRIED
TO TURN EVERY ROCK AS PART
OF THIS EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE PUTTING OUR THE BEST
CAPABILITIES OF THE BEST MINDS
-- TO THIS EFFORT WELL AGAIN
AND NOW WELL SUMMARIZED BY
JUST SAYING THAT WE WE DON'T
WANT TO RECREATE THE WHEEL YOU
HAVE THE PROFESSIONALS WITHIN
YOUR RANKS TO FIGURE THIS OUT
ES DE WILL INDEED DEBT ACTOR
THEIR FACILITY THEY KNOW EVERY
WHEN PATTERN THROUGHOUT THEIR
ENTIRE AREA OF JURISDICTION I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR AREA IS
MUCH LARGER -- BUT I ALSO KNOW
THAT WITH TECHNOLOGY -- WE NEED
TO KNOW -- WHEN THE ATMOSPHERIC
ADVANCE -- DECADE THAT A.
B. ENERGY STATION IF NECESSARY
SO CAN YOU NEED TO DE ENERGIZED
AND THEN WE ALSO NEED TO HAVE
THE CAPABILITIES OF EVALUATING
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT IS CONNECTED NON
HAZARDOUS AND TO TURN ON THE
ELECTRICITY AS FAST AS WE CAN
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THOSE ARE THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT AND THEN ALSO --
RISK QUANTIFICATION ZONES THAT
YOU SAY YOU'VE ALREADY DOING
-- YOU MAYBE YOU NEED MORE
FURTHER DETAIL ON THOSE RISKS
OWN IN COMPARISON TO OTHER
SONGS ARE YOU READY TO FOCUS
ON DURING THESE THESE HIGH FIRE
VENTED OUR FIRE SEASON I THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AGAIN THIS
ABOUT PERSONAL I I WAS JUST --
WE WANT TO BE HERE AGAIN NEXT
YEAR FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED
-- IN THE LATEST FIRE INCIDENT
AND AND AND AND JUST LASTLY
IF YOU'D ANSWER MY QUESTION
ABOUT IS IT EXERCISE IS AT
ALL IS THAT A GOOD IDEA OR A
BAD IDEA TO DO THINGS WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE LIVES IN JEOPARDY WE
WE WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THAT
RIGHT IT'S IT'S NO DIFFERENT
THAN AN ATHLETE TRAINING
RIGHT AND DOING PRACTICE AND
DRILLS TO BE ABLE TO GET READY
FOR THE GAME WE LOOK AT THE
SAME WAY INTERNALLY WE'RE
DOING THESE EXERCISES WERE
DOING THESE DRILLS WERE DOING
PLANNING WORKSHOPS WITH SOME
OF THE FIRST RESPONSE AGENCIES
INCLUDING SOME OF THE THAT THE
LOCAL COUNTY OFFICIALS -- AND
WHAT WOULD BE HAPPY TO ENGAGE
IN THAT DISCUSSION AND DIALOGUE
I THINK SO IT IDEA AND WAIT ON
IT TOO DOES THAT SOUND LIKE A I
MEAN WOULD BE GREAT TO TURN OFF
THE ELECTRICITY WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE AN EMERGENCY TO FIGURE
OUT YOU KNOW WHAT WE MISSING
SO THAT WHEN WE REALLY HAVE THE
REAL EVENT WE'RE MORE PREPARED
SO WE DO HAVE HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN EXERCISES WITH P.
JEANNIE -- ON EXERCISING
THE PROTOCOLS A NOTIFICATION
BUT IF I UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION CORRECTLY YOU'RE
ACTUALLY SUGGESTING TURNING
THE POWER OFF PRO ACTIVELY
YEAH I THINK THAT THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOME TO TALK ABOUT
AND CONSIDER -- WE CERTAINLY
BELIEVE IN THE CONCEPT OF
EXERCISING IN TRAINING AND
YOU WANT TO TRAIN LIKE YOU'RE
GONNA FIGHT TOTAL YOU CAN
BUY IT THAT WAY FOR SURE
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE SENATOR
RUBIO THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE -- CLEARLY THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT MATTER --
BUT I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MY COLLEAGUE -- SENATOR MCGUIRE
YOU KNOW IT IS A MOTION ON IT
IS PERSONAL ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
HAPPENS IN YOUR BACKYARD SO ALL
OF US ARE AFFECTED DIFFERENTLY
AND WHEN YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH YOUR CONSTITUENTS COMING
UP TO YOU AND AND SHARING
CONCERNS ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
PERTAINS TO TO PEOPLE WHOSE
LIVES ARE AT RISK SO I CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND YOUR MOTION AND
I THINK YOU HAVE EVERY RIGHT
TO BE -- I'M ALSO GOING TO
AGREE HERE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER STONE AND NOW DIE YOU
CANNOT AFFORD ANOTHER ANOTHER
EVENT I MEAN WE'VE HAD ENOUGH
TIME TO TO ANALYZE WHAT WE
CAN DO SOMETHING LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED PREVIOUSLY IS GOING
TO BE PROBABLY THE LAST TIME
WE TO BE DEALING WITH THIS
BUT I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT I HEARD I THINK
ALL OF YOU SEE AT ONE POINT
OR ANOTHER WHICH IS THE ON
THE CHALLENGE OF COMMUNICATION
I THINK I HEARD MISS ARM
I HOPE I PRONOUNCED RIGHT
MALASHENKO SAY COMMUNICATION
I'VE HEARD ALL OF YOU APPEAR
AT ONE POINT OR ANOTHER TALK
ABOUT COMMUNICATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NOW WHEN I HEARD MR
DOT STATE THAT THERE IS TWENTY
SEVEN LINES ON THE FLOOR THAT
THEY HAD NO KNOWLEDGE OF I
JUST WANT TO KNOW I MEAN HAVE
AND IT'S SO SIMPLE BUT HOW DO
YOU ENGAGE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IN THAT RESPECT IT JUST MAKES
ME THINK OF WHAT THE MAYOR SAN
JOSE STATED HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO ENGAGE PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR
ON THE GROUND LEVEL WHERE THEY
KNOW EXACTLY EVERY CORNER OF
THEIR COMMUNITY AND THEY KNOW
WHAT TO LOOK FOR SO WHEN WE'RE
HAVING COMMUNICATION CHALLENGES
HOPE PARTICULAR YOU ARE YOU
CONNECTED TO LOCAL ENTITIES
IN TERMS OF COMMUNICATION
BACK AND FORTH I DID HEAR YOU
STATE THAT YOU TEND TO BE ON
THE CONSERVATIVE SIDE AND NOT
RELEASE INFORMATION BECAUSE
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET IT WRONG
YOU WANT TO BE SURE BUT I
DON'T SEE THE HARM AND HAVING
A POINT OF CONTACT WHERE YOU'RE
COMMUNICATING FROM BEGINNING
TO END THE MINUTE YOU THINK
SOMETHING'S GOING WRONG --
EIGHTIES AT THE GOVERNMENT
LEVEL SO THEY THEN THEY CAN
BE READY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
A PLAN OF ACTION IN CASE OR
SOMETHING HAPPENING SO CAN
SOMEONE EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT
EXACTLY SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF
HOW YOU ENGAGE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THE MINUTE YOU KNOW SOMETHING
COULD POTENTIALLY GO WRONG
SO I GUESS I CAN START --
BUT WHEN WE ARE FORECASTING A
POTENTIAL PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF OF AND -- AND WHEN
WE ACTIVATE OUR EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER WE HAVE A
DESIGNATED POSITION WITHIN
OUR INCIDENT COMMAND STRUCTURE
OF CALLED LIAISON OFFICER AND
THEN THAT -- INDIVIDUAL HAS A
TEAM -- AND THEY'RE ENGAGING
WITH ALL OF THE RESPECTIVE --
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS WE ALSO
HAVE A TEAM ON THE CUSTOMER
CARE SIDE THAT'S MANAGING
AND AND ENSURING THAT WE'RE
COMMUNICATING WITH ALL THE
LARGE CUSTOMERS WITH ALL THE
MEDICAL WONDERFUL BASE FIND
CUSTOMERS ON THE LOCAL SIDE WE
WORK WITH THE -- ESTABLISHED
LOCAL OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES -- BECAUSE AS MORE
ACTIVATING OUR EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER FOR A
POTENTIAL PS PS OF AND TO
THE LOCAL OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES -- IS TYPICALLY
ACTIVATING AS WELL IN ADDITION
TO THE NOTIFICATIONS AND THE
SPECIFIC TYPE OF INFORMATION
THAT WE'RE SHARING WITH
THE STATE -- U. S.
CALLOW YES CPUC ARE ENTITIES
-- PLAN THAT'S TYPICALLY HOW
WERE ENGAGING WITH THEM TO THE
DIRECT LINE OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE RESPECTIVE
EMERGENCY CENTERS THIRTY YOU
AUTOMATICALLY NOTIFY LIST HIM
MAYOR AND CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
WHEN THERE'S A POTENTIAL
-- INCIDENT THAT YOU'VE YOU
FORESEE HAPPENING NOT MOSTLY
A OF POTENTIAL INCIDENT FOR
SEEING HAPPENING IT'S IT'S
IT'S WHEN WE ARE ACTIVATING AID
GEOGRAPHIC AREA ORG ACTIVATING
OUR EMERGENCY CENTER FOR WHEN
WE ARE FORECASTING HE POTENTIAL
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
SO THAT WE CAN START TO DO THE
PREPAREDNESS FOR DOING ALL OF
THE PROACTIVE COMMUNICATIONS
AND IN SOME CASES -- THAT
COMMUNICATION MAY NOT TURN
INTO A NOTIFICATION INTO AN
ACTUAL THE LEGISLATION THAT'S
REALLY WHERE ARE STRUCTURED
COMMUNICATION PROTOCOL -- COMES
INTO PLAY SO THAT THAT'S REALLY
YOU KNOW THE EXAMPLE THAT I'M
SPEAKING OF ATTENDANCE IS A
QUESTION WELL IT SOUNDS GREAT
WHERE YOU'RE STAYING RIGHT NOW
BUT FROM ALL THE TESTIMONY AND
STORIES WE'VE HEARD FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND EVEN MISTER
DOT APPEAR ON THE TIRES THERE
SEEMS TO BE A DISCONNECT AND
EVEN THOUGH THERE'S SOMETHING
AND PLAYS THERE STILL SEEMS
TO BE A DISCONNECT AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO START CONSIDERING
VERY STRONGLY WHAT THE MAYOR
OF SAN JOSE STATE AT THAT AT
SOME POINT I THINK THERE HAS
TO BE A PARTNERSHIP OR THERE'S
DIRECT COMMUNICATION THEY KNOW
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE OFFICES A
START WORKING IN ISOLATION BUT
AS A LOCAL FORMER GOVERNMENT
INDIVIDUAL MYSELF THERE'S A
LOT OF CONFUSION WITH -- WITH
POLICE AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
BECAUSE WHEN AN INCIDENT
HAPPENS OUR RESOURCES START
BEING STRESSED EVERYONE WAS
CALLING ON ONLINE YOU HAVE
EVERYONE RUNNING AROUND TRYING
TO ASK YOU QUESTIONS IN YOUR
LITTLE CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN AND I KNOW IT'S
HAPPENED TO ME PERSONALLY IN
THE PAST BUT I REALLY DO THINK
AT LEAST FOR COLLEAGUES APPEAR
AS WELL AS YOU I THINK WE NEED
TO START CONSIDERING WHAT THE
MERIT SAN JOSE STATE AND THAT
IS WE HAVE TO BECOME PARTNERS
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
THAT DISCONNECT CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN AND AS MUCH AS YOU'RE
SAYING WE HAVE THINGS IN PLACE
WERE NOT SEEN THAT IN ACTUALITY
IN THE GROUND BUT UP BUT THANK
YOU FOR FOR BEING HERE THANK
YOU THERE WAS THE OLD ADDRESS
AND REVIEWS I MEAN IT'S IT'S
NOT PERFECT BY ANY MEANS I SAID
I DON'T WANT YOU TO WALK AWAY
THINKING THAT THAT IT'S PERFECT
WITH EVERY SINGLE COUNTY WITH
EVERY SINGLE ENTITY YOU KNOW IT
IS IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS THAT
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
EVERY SINGLE DAY IS IT BETTER
GOING INTO THIS YEAR'S U.
S. P. S. COMMA SEASON IF YOU
WANT TO CALL IT AS COMPARED
TO WHAT IT WAS LAST YEAR I
FINALLY BELIEVE SO BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF EFFORT
AND FOCUS -- ON THIS SPECIFIC
ISSUE BUT IS THERE MORE TO BE
DONE ABSOLUTELY WELL I HOPE WE
CONTINUE TO MORE BECAUSE ONE
MORE LIFE LOSSES UNACCEPTABLE
MAKING RUBIO SENATOR STERN AND
WE HAD A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF FOCUS ON P.
JEANNIE THIS MORNING BUT
-- I HOPEFULLY -- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND ES DE
JEANNIE ARE HERE AS WELL AS
-- OR MUNICIPAL UTILITIES AND
ARE COUNTIES AND WE'RE GETTING
A CITY PERSPECTIVE BUT ONE
SUGGESTION MIGHT BE -- MAYBE
IN THE WAKE OF HIS HEARING
TO GET SOME WRITTEN FEEDBACK
FROM ALL THE I. O.
USE AS WELL AS THE PO USE AS
WELL AS OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF
HOW ALL OF THEM ARE PLANNING
-- FOR P. S. P. S.
MANAGEMENT -- BECAUSE THE
QUESTION I HAVE -- FOR FOR
YOU ALL IS THE SAME AS AS FOR
MAYOR LICCARDO ABOUT THE SCOPE
OF VULNERABILITY HOW YOUR
INITIALLY MAPPING THE RISK AND
WHO IS WHO IS IN AND WHO IS
OUT WHAT IS AND WHAT IS THAT
I'M I'M LOOKING BACK AT SB NINE
NO ONE IN THE DEFINITION HERE
OF WHAT HAS TO BE INCLUDED IN
A WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN
THAT SIR DODD IS PROPOSING TO
ADD GRANULARITY TO AN SP ONE
SIXTY SEVEN BUT AT THIS POINT
-- THAT DEFINITION IS IS MERELY
THE THAT YOU GUYS HAVE TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE IMPACTS ON
CRITICAL FIRST RESPONDERS AND
ON HEALTH AND COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE S.
PROPOSED TO BE REFINED THAT
WOULD BE EXPANDED TO TO SAY
CRITICAL FIRST RESPONDERS
HELPING COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN
CUSTOMERS WHO RECEIVE MEDICAL
BASELINE ALLOWANCES -- FIRST
QUESTION IS A MEDICAL BASS
LINE IS AN OPT IN PROGRAM IS IT
NOT IS THE PGA ANY RIGHT WHEN
WE STARTED THE P.
UC'S MEDICAL BASELINE AN OPT
IN PROGRAM YES IN THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY DESIGNED IS THE
RACE ASSISTANCE A PROGRAM
FOR HOME CUSTOMERS WHO NEEDED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE BECAUSE
OF THEIR MEDICAL CONDITIONS GO
MORE SO IS A RATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THAT IS A PROGRAM TO
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY WHERE SAY
MEDICAL OR HEALTH NEEDS ARE
OUR MOST CRITICAL CORRECT
CORRECTLY AT MY UNDERSTANDING
OF THE HISTORY OF THE PROGRAM
IS A WAS NOT DESIGNED WITH
EMERGENCY RESPONSE IN MIND
AND SO THERE IS GOING TO BE
A POPULATION I WANT TO GET
A SENSE MAYBE FROM YOU MR
SAYING OR COMPREHENSIVELY FROM
EITHER -- YES TO THE P.
YOU SEE HOW MANY CUSTOMERS
OUT THERE WITH CRITICAL HEALTH
NEEDS ARE NOT CURRENTLY WITHIN
YOUR MEDICAL BASELINE ALLOWANCE
AGAIN THIS ALSO SENATOR START
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE DIFFICULT
TO BUILD IDENTIFIED THAT
RIGHT BECAUSE THOSE RESPECTIVE
CUSTOMERS MAY NOT HAVE --
IDENTIFIED -- REGISTERED WITH
US WHAT I CAN SHARE WITH YOU IS
WE HAVE FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
ELECTRIC CUSTOMERS OF THAT
THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND OVERALL
I'M TALKING ABOUT WITHIN OUR
ENTIRE SERVICE TERRITORY --
THIS INCLUDES -- OUTSIDE OF
THE HI FI RISK AREAS -- THAT
WE HAVE REGISTERED AS MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMERS AND THE
DEFINITION THAT WE HAVE HERE
IS RIGHT THERE LIFE SUPPORT
CUSTOMERS -- THAT ARE USING
ANY MEDICAL DEVICE THAT'S USED
TO SUSTAIN LIFE AND -- IT'S
A SIGN BY A LICENSED MEDICAL
PRACTITIONER AND THE EQUIPMENT
IS FOR HOME USE ONLY WITH US
THE WAY WE UNDERSTAND IT SO YOU
A HUNDRED NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
IS THAT SO OKAY SO HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND TO FIVE
POINT FIVE MILLION FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION NICER THE POINT
FOUR MILLION AND THEN WRIT
LARGE IN THE I OWE YOU -- WORLD
IN GENERAL MISS MALASHENKO
HOW MANY CUSTOMERS IN OHIO YOU
TERRITORIES ACROSS THE STATE
I DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER WITH
ME BUT IT'S SIMILAR MAGNITUDE
SO AND THEN DO WE KNOW HOW
MANY TOTAL MEDICAL BASELINE
ALLOWANCE CUSTOMERS ARE WITHIN
ALL THE AYE YOU TERRITORY DO
YOU GUYS HAVE THAT INFORMATION
I DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME RIGHT
NOW NO BUT IT'S SIMILAR ABOUT
MAGNITUDES TO -- P.
JEANNIE IN TERMS OF PROPORTION
OF MEDICAL BE SLAIN CUSTOMERS
TO THE OVERALL CUSTOMER ACCOUNT
AND IS YOUR SENSE THAT IT IS
NOT NECESSARILY A COMPREHENSIVE
ACCOUNTING WHO IS OPTED IN THE
MEDICAL BASS LINE VERSUS WHO IS
ACTUALLY MEDICALLY VULNERABLE
I I KNOW THE MAYOR TOM RIGHT
THOSE WHO NEED REFRIGERATION
SAY OF OF OF PRESCRIPTION NOT
EVEN BE ON A RESPIRATOR PER SE
OR SOMEONE'S IT WAS ON DIALYSIS
BUT NOT INTO ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITY THAT MIGHT NOT BE
CAPTURES YOUR SENSE THAT IS
AN INCOMPLETE COUNT -- IF WE
SOLELY USE MEDICAL BASELINE
AS THE SORT OF -- BASS LINE IF
YOU WILL OF WHO'S VULNERABLE
THAT IS CORRECT THAT IS IT IS
INCOMPLETE AND FOR TWO REASONS
SO FULL ONE IS THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE NOT DESIGNED
AS AN EMERGENCY RESPONSE
OF PROGRAM SO THERE MEDIA
CUSTOMERS WHO COULD BE SOMEHOW
MEDICALLY DEPENDENT HOME WHO
ARE NOT CURRENTLY REGISTERED
BUT THE SECOND REASON IS ALSO
THE MASTER METER -- ISSUE
WHERE AT LARGE BUILDINGS
MOBILE HOME PARKS AND OTHER
FACILITIES -- COULD BE BEHIND
ONE METER WITH A HUNDRED SO
FULL OF PEOPLE BEHIND THEM SOME
OF THEM COULD BE L.
MEDICALLY DEPENDENT OTHERS MAY
NOT BE BUT IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE UTILITY SEES THEY DON'T
SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE THERE ARE
BEHIND THE MEAT OR OMIT SO
THAT'S ANOTHER AREA WITH THAT
MAKES THIS INFORMATION HIGHLY
IT THAT UTILITIES OF HIGHLY
INCOMPLETE WE I SEE CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS THAT'S WHAT WE SEE
RIGHT AND SO YOU TAKE SOMEWHERE
LIKE THE JEWISH HOME FOR THE
AGING THE LARGEST SENIORS --
CARE FACILITY OVERNIGHT IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY YOU
HAVE HUNDREDS OF RESIDENTS
LIVING A SINGLE FACILITY
WITH ONE METER SUMMER -- YOU
KNOW SELF DEALING WITH SEVERE
DEGENERATIVE DISORDERS SUMMER
AGING IS A PLACE AND -- YOU
KNOW VARYING DEGREES OF RISK
AND AND NOT NECESSARILY OSP
PIES OR FEDERALLY REGULATED
AT BACK OF DIESEL GENERATION
SO THOSE PEOPLE MY GRANDMOTHER
IS ALWAYS ON MY MIND RIGHT NOW
-- -- MISS THOMAS JACOBS THOSE
ZOOMING OUT EVEN BEYOND OUR
SORT OF MEDICALLY VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS HOW IS -- YES
LOOKING AT THIS SORT OF BROADER
SCOPE OF VULNERABILITIES SO
WHAT WHAT HOW DO YOU WELL
DEFINED CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
CRITICAL ASSETS SO FROM
A CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PERSPECTIVE WE USE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY'S --
CLASSIFICATION SYSTEMS OF THESE
THE SECTION OUT BY SECTOR RED
SERVICES TRANSPORTATION ENERGY
SO WE USE THOSE CLASSIFICATIONS
-- AND THAT WAS WHAT ORIGINALLY
IN FORM OF THE CURRENCY IF YOU
SEE DECISION IN TERMS OF THE
CLASSIFICATION OF THE CRITICAL
FACILITIES IN THAT DECISION
-- IN TERMS OF VULNERABLE
POPULATION AGREED THAT IT
THAT THE DEFINITION IT IS NOT
FULLY DEFINED IN THAT THERE
ARE BROAD GROUPS THAT ARE
NOT INCLUSIVE IN THE CURRENT
CATEGORIES THAT ARE BEING USED
-- WE'VE HAD MEETINGS WITH OUR
-- HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY -- PARTNERS TO TRYING
TO ZERO IN ON -- GETTING MORE
SPECIFICITY ON THAT BUT WE
DON'T HAVE HE WELL DEFINED --
FULLY COMPREHENSIVE DEFINITION
OF VULNERABLE POPULATIONS DO
YOU THINK YOU NEED ADDITIONAL
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO MARRY
THOSE DATA SETS STATE EXPOUND
YEAH WELL SO I'M THINKING OF
AS COUNTY HEALTH DATA OF WHAT
YOU KNOW WHO WHAT SENIORS ARE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING SUPPORT
THROUGH SOME SERVICE OR OTHER
OTHER DATA SETS THAT MIGHT
INDICATE TO YOU -- SOMETHING
BEYOND THE MEDICAL BASS LINE
I CAN'T I CAN'T SPEAK TO
WHETHER WE NEED SUCH AUTHORITY
IT -- BUT I WOULD SAY THAT WE
WE ARE WORKING WITH -- BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES ON
THE DATA SETS THAT THEY HAVE
IN EXPLORING WHAT ADDITIONAL
DATA SETS THEY MAY HAVE THAT
WE NEED TO COMBINE -- RIGHT NOW
I KNOW SOME OF THE FOCUS HAS
BEEN ON SORT FOR FOR EXAMPLE
MEDIC MEDICARE AS WELL AS MEDI
CAL THE DATA SETS TO LOOK AT
BUT AGAIN TRYING TO THAN THAT
TO STILL THAT DOWN TO WHICH
ONES THAT ARE VULNERABLE FROM
A POWER PERSPECTIVE RIGHT --
BECAUSE IT'S NOT A SLATE ALL OF
THEM RIGHT -- SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AND
OUR SEE PAGE PARTNERS -- ON
THE AND POWER PROGRAM WHICH IS
OF ALLOW WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
SOME MORE SPECIFICITY MON ON
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WITHIN
THOSE CATEGORIES -- BUT AGAIN
THOSE THOSE DATA SETS AREN'T
FULLY COMPREHENSIVE FOR EXAMPLE
THE EMPOWER PROGRAM THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RUNS WHICH
WOULD ALLOW US ACCESS OF THE
-- LOCAL AGENCIES TO REQUEST
A DATA SETS OF VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WITHIN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM OR MEDICARE PROGRAM
-- IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY GIVE
CONTACT INFORMATION TO GIVE
THEIR THEIR ADDRESS BUT IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY GIVE THEIR
PHONE NUMBER RIGHT SO THE DATA
SETS CAN GIVE US A BROADER
SCOPE BUT THE CATEGORIES OF
OF INFORMATION ELEMENTS IN
THOSE DATA SETS AGAIN THEY
WERE DESIGNED FROM AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PERSPECTIVE SO WE
WOULD NEED TO THINK THROUGH
HOW TO BROADEN THE DATA SET TO
BE ABLE TO USE IT EFFECTIVELY
UNDER EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CONSIDERATIONS I KNOW YOU'VE
REACHED OUT TO COUNTIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WELL WITH
SOMEONE OF A SOLICITATION IF
YOU WILL OF SORT OF WHAT THEY
SEE IN THEIR MAP OF CRITICAL
POPULATIONS AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE DOES
THAT -- INTERFACE STAND DO
YOU HAVE -- YES WE HAVE A
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
UNIT WITHIN OUR STATE FRED
ASSESSMENT CENTER ON THAT HAS
DEFINED -- -- STATE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN THERE'S
A BROADER THAT'S THAT'S A
SORT OF THE THE HIGHEST CRITIC
CRITICALITY IF YOU WILL AND
THEN WE HAVE BROADER DATA
SETS THAT WE USE WITHIN ARCGIS
DEPARTMENT THAT IDENTIFIES
ALL THE FIRE POLICE STATE
POLICE STATIONS FIRE STATIONS
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES I'M SO
WE CAN OVERLY THOSE IN OVER
THE MAPS THAT WE RECEIVE FROM
THE UTILITIES ON THE PUBLIC
SAFETY DO YOU HAVE ADEQUATE
DATA THOUGH FROM THE COUNTIES
ON THAT FRONT AT THIS POINT TO
HAVE A SO THAT WE AT THE STATE
LEVEL OF A COMPREHENSIVE DATA
SAID THAT WOULD BE TOO BROAD
A STATEMENT TO SAY IT ADEQUATE
ACROSS THE BOARD SO NOT SO
THERE ARE PROBABLY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ELEMENTS THAT WE
WOULD WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE DATA SET
GOOD BECAUSE AGAIN MOST OF OUR
DATA SETS COME FROM A STATE
PERSPECTIVE -- SO IT WOULD
IT DEPENDS ON WHERE YOU WHERE
YOU WANT TO DRAW THE LINE OF
TRACKING ALL FACILITIES SO IF
YOU'D INDUSTRY FINAL QUESTION
HERE IT SEEMS LIKE WE'VE GOT
A HUGE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW
-- EVEN IF WE'RE COMMUNICATING
IN THE RIGHT WAY TO YOUR
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMER
SAID IT'S STILL AN ADEQUATE
-- PERHAPS SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
OR THAT AN EFFORT THEY'RE
YOU KNOW THEY'RE IN -- CAN BE
USED TO SORT OF REMEDY SOME OF
THESE GAPS -- BUT EVEN IF WE
DO IDENTIFY ALL THESE PEOPLE
AND THEN WE GO TALK TO THEM
AND SEND THEM JUST PULLED UP
PREPARE FOR POWER DOWN -- SEND
THEM THIS THIS WEBSITE -- I SEE
A BIG PICTURE OF OF -- BACKPACK
SOME CANS A BATTERY A POCKET
KNIFE AND SOME WATER -- AS THIS
SORT OF -- BASIC RECOMMENDATION
HERE YOU GO YOUR POWER IS
GOING TO BE OFF FOR HALF A
DAY MAYBE THREE DAYS IT'LL
BE OFTEN IT SAYS WHAT IF I'M
DEPEND ELECTRICITY FOR MEDICAL
DEVICES SAYS CONSIDER A SAFE
BACKUP POWER SOURCE SUCH AS A
GENERATOR OR UNINTERRUPTIBLE
POWER SUPPLY WE TALKED EARLIER
ABOUT COMMUNICATING IN THE
MESSAGE I DON'T SEE ANYWHERE
TO CLICK HERE TO SAY HOW DO I
GET ONE OF THOSE DEVICES HOW DO
I ACTUALLY BACK MY POWER UP SO
I I HAVE TO GO OUT I'M EIGHTY
FIVE YEAR OLD WOMAN LIVING THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY DEPENDING
ON YOUR CONDITION I GOT A
OKAY I GOT I GOT THE NOTICE WE
IDENTIFY THE PERSON NOW THEY
GO OUT NAY SAY I GO TO THE HOME
DEPOT AND GET A GENERATOR I
CAN'T EVEN DRIVE I DO THERE'S
NO WHERE TO CLICK LIKE ONCE
WE ACTUALLY IDENTIFIES PEOPLE
NOTIFY THEM I DON'T SEE THE
TOOLS TO ACTUALLY EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO TAKE CARE OF THESE
ISSUES AND I DON'T THINK THAT
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT PUTTING
A SOLAR BATTERY SYSTEM AT A
NURSING HOME WILL JUST TAKE
TOO LONG SO LIKE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO FIGURE THAT OUT DOWN
THE LINE LET'S KICK THAT CAN
DOWN THE ROAD WE KNOW FULL WELL
THAT WE CAN GET THE SYSTEMS
UP AND RUNNING NOW AND I'M
NOT JUST TALKING TO NURSING
HOMES HERE TOO I'M TALKING
ABOUT GASOLINE STATIONS IN
OUR OIL REFINERIES EVEN THAT
IT WE RELIED FOR OUR ENERGY
SYSTEMS IN THE REGION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PUMPING STATIONS
ACTUALLY KEEP THE WATER MOVING
BUT THINGS THAT INDIVIDUALS
CAN DO OR PRIVATE OR PUBLIC
FACILITIES CAN DO I STILL
THINK WE'RE LACKING A A STATE
WIDE DEFINITION THAT ACTUALLY
IDENTIFIES THEM COMPREHENSIVELY
THE BE A SOLUTION SET BECAUSE
THAT'S SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
IN THE BUDGET CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG BUT THAT WAS
REALLY INTENDED MOSTLY JUST
FOR STATE FACILITIES THAT
THAT SORT OF TOP TIER LIST
IS THAT CORRECT MISS THOMAS
JACOBS THIS IS STILL BEING
EVALUATED IT'S LOOKING AT BOTH
STATE AND LOCAL NEEDS IS IT
FAIR TO SAY THAT SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION IS SOMEWHAT OF A DROP
IN THE BUCKET COMPARED TO THE
TOTAL NEED FOR BACKUP POWER
GENERATION CITY SO THAT'S TO ME
THE PROJECT HERE THAT I HOPE WE
CAN ALL ENDEAVOR IN TOGETHER IS
HOW TO FILL THAT GAP QUICKLY --
AND I DON'T THINK DIESEL POWER
GENERATION SOLELY IS GONNA BE
THE ANSWER I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF FOLKS AND HOPING THIS
NEXT PANEL WE CAN START TO
DIG INTO THAT BUT FROM THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS COMMUNITY
PERSPECTIVE FROM ALL THOSE
FOLKS OUT THERE WHO MIGHT NOT
BE CAPTURED -- AND FROM THOSE
CRITICAL INDUSTRY SAYS NOT JUST
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT
BUT THOSE PRIVATE FACILITIES
THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED -- I
THINK WE OUGHT TO DELIVER THIS
SESSION THANK YOU SENATOR AND
AND WE WILL NOW BEFORE I GO TO
MY QUESTIONS WILL GO TO SENATOR
WIENER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APOLOGIZE
THAT I HAD TO STEP OUT IT
WAS UNAVOIDABLE SO AND I HOPE
I DON'T -- AS QUESTIONS ARE
ALREADY ASKED -- I SUGGEST --
IF YOU THESE ARE ALL THE P.
GINNY AND AGAIN NOTHING
PERSONAL MISTER SAYING AYE AYE
AND YOUR HER REPRESENTING A
COMPANY THAT HAS SOME REAL --
-- CHALLENGES -- SO FIRST OF
ALL THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK -- THAT'S
HAPPENING ABOUT THE -- I FORGET
THE TERM BETTER SEGMENTATION SO
THAT THE SHUTDOWNS CAN BE MORE
STRATEGIC AND THEN OF COURSE
THE OVERALL -- HARDENING TRIED
-- ARE REDUCE THE RISK OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF P.
GINNY CAUSING WILDFIRES I GUESS
ONE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IS WHY
WASN'T THIS INFRASTRUCTURE WORK
DONE A LONG TIME AGO -- AND
I I'M NOT I'M NOT JUST TRYING
TO BE ARGUMENTATIVE BUT I I
THINK THE PUBLIC DESERVES AN
ANSWER ABOUT WHAT IN TERMS WHY
THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN A LONG TIME
AGO -- YOU KNOW REPAIRS OF THE
PAYING MONEY FOR A LONG TIME
AND AND I UNDERSTAND THE P.
GINNY SYSTEM IS OLDER AND --
IT'S A HUGE SERVICE AREA AND
NOTES MANY CHALLENGES -- BUT
WHAT TOPPING THEY SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED A LONG TIME AGO NOT
ONLY WITH THAT OF A WAITED --
LIKELY TO MAYES WILDFIRES BUT
WE WOULDN'T BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT POTENTIALLY
MASSIVE OVERLY BROAD POWER
SHUT DOWN SO BECAUSE WE'LL
REFINERIES TO FLARE -- OR THE
BECAUSE SMALL BUSINESSES TO
HAVE TO SHUT DOWN A POTENTIALLY
CLOSE UP SHOP ENTIRELY OR
CAUSE PEOPLE TO LOSE THEIR
MEDICATION -- WHAT -- SO WHY
SENATOR FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
I HARD FROM TO SPECULATE
AS TO WHY DOES NOT THE AREA
THAT HAVE FOCUSED IN -- I
TRANSITION INTO THIS ROLE OF
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR OF FROM
OUR GAS OPERATIONS FOR THE
ORGANIZATION -- AND CHARTED
WITH THE FOCUS ON LOOKING AT
-- WILDFIRE RISK FROM A ACID
AND RISK MANAGEMENT FRAMEWORK
VERY SIMILAR FRAMEWORK THAT'S
EMPLOYED IN THE NUCLEAR
INDUSTRY THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY
THE NATURAL GAS THE IN THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY THAT'S
REALLY WHAT MY FOCUS HAS BEEN
-- IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ANOTHER WALL
FAR CAUSED BY OUR ELECTRICAL
ACID IN INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S
REALLY BEEN -- GO FORWARD --
FOR ME THE AS I'VE LOOKED AT
THE THE THE INFORMATION THAT'S
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE -- ON ON
THE ON THE SPECIFIC TOPIC
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS TOPIC IN
THIS QUESTION IS ON A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S MINDS BUT THAT'S NOT
BEEN MY AREA OF FOCUS WE WE
HAVE YOU SEEN WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE THE COURSE OF THE TIME
PERIOD BETWEEN TWENTY TWELVE
AND -- THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF
FIRE THREAT DISTRICT MAPS THAT
WERE PUT TOGETHER THE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS THAT TOOK PLACE THE
CLIMATE IN WHICH ARE LOGICAL
ASSETS ARE WE'RE SURROUNDED
WITH A DRASTICALLY CHANGED --
AND I'M NOT BLAMING ALL OF THAT
ON THE CLIMATE CHANGE -- SO AND
THERE'S THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING
NOW THAT -- WE'RE COMMENSURATE
WITH REDUCING THAT RISK BOTH
IN TERMS OF INSPECTIONS IN
TERMS OF EDUCATION IN TERMS OF
HARDENING THOSE ARE ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WE PUT INTO ACTION
-- SINCE -- ABOUT BEEN PART OF
THIS -- PART OF THIS -- EFFORT
YEAH AND I -- -- GUY ARE YOUR
MORE RECENT IT'S JUST I JUST
FIND IT REALLY UNACCEPTABLE
THE LEVEL OF -- INFRASTRUCTURE
DETERIORATION THAT WAS ALLOWED
TO HAPPEN THAT P.
GINNY AND AND NOW NOT ONLY
DO WE SEE THE WILD FIRES
BUT WE SEE THESE POTENTIALLY
CATASTROPHIC OF POWER SHUT
DOWN AND ONE WHEN I SHUT DOWN
HAPPENS WHAT'S THE FOCUSING
ON BUSINESSES BOTH SMALL AND
LARGE SIR UP WHAT IS THEIR
RECOURSE SO YOU HAVE OF WHAT
WE SAW YOU KNOW THE THE -- THE
WILLINGNESS AND I'M NOT USUALLY
ALIGNED WITH THE OIL INDUSTRY
BUT THEIR THEIR LETTER WAS --
WAS VERY COMPELLING -- THAT YOU
ARE YOU KNOW I I MEAN THAT'S
PRETTY PROBLEMATIC TO TO TO
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN BUT THAT'S
JUST A ABOUT THAT ONE THE CIVIC
STREAM EXAMPLE THERE'S ALSO --
THAN WHAT I MENTIONED THAT AT
THE BEGINNING LESSONS YOU KNOW
DOES LACK OF INSURANCE DOESN'T
COVER IT IN THESE BUSINESSES
-- IT'S IT'S DEVASTATING TO
THEM AND SO WHAT WHAT IS THERE
WHAT IS A RECOURSE AND WHAT'S
A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE FOR FOR
PGA ANY NOT TO ERR ON THE SIDE
OF OVERLY BROAD POWER SHUT
OFF SO SO RESPECTFULLY CENTERS
NOT A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
IT'S REALLY A PUBLIC SAFETY
OF FOCUS FOR US I I UNDERSTAND
YOU PARTICULAR KIND OF THE
THE THE TWO SIDES OF IT FROM
MY ECONOMIC AND FINANCIAL
PERSPECTIVE WE DON'T LOOK AT IT
THAT WAY WE LOOK AT IT IN TERMS
OF THE RISK OF DEHYDRATION AS A
RESULT TO PUBLIC SAFETY IMPACT
OR AS A RESULT OF NOT DE
ENERGIZING AND POTENTIALLY
CAUSING A CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES SO THAT THAT'S-
REALLY THE RISKS THAT WE ARE
WEIGHING. IN TERMS OF YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT THE FINANCIAL
RECOURSE. THAT'S LEFT UP TO
WERE WERE TRYING TO BE
PROACTIVE ON THE COMMUNICATION
WE LAST WEEK WE HAD A
DISCUSSION AND A SPECIFIC
MEETING WITH THE VARIOUS LARGE
REFINERIES THAT ARE TOPPED OFF
OF A TRANSMISSION SYSTEM TO BE
DISCUSSIONS IN TERMS OF THE-
HEALTH OF OUR SYSTEM IN AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR OUR
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM MADE IT BY
NATURE. IS SPECIAL HUNDRED KV
AND ABOVE AS MYSTERY NOT TALKED
ABOUT THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF
RELIABILITY THAT'S BUILT INTO
IT BECAUSE FROM A- A
RELIABILITY PERSPECTIVE WE'RE
LOOKING TO REALLY OPERATE THE
SYSTEM ON A AND MINUS ONE
CONTINGENCY MEETING IF YOU LOSE
YOU KNOW A LINE YOU HAVE. BEEN
IN OTHER FROM A BACKUP
PERSPECTIVE AND- THE WHOLE
INTENT BEHIND ENGAGING FOR
EXAMPLE TO REFINE RECENCY USE
THAT USE THAT EXAMPLE IS TO.
MAKE THEM AWARE THAT THIS IS
THE REALITY UNFORTUNATE REALITY
OF WHAT WE ARE CURRENTLY FACED
WITH AND WHAT WERE LIVING WITH
A WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TO ORDER THEM TO
ALSO HAVE A PLAN. AND FROM A
RECOURSE PERSPECTIVE. IT'S WE
LEAVE IT UP TO THEM RIGHT A
FIFTY FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE DECISION THAT WE MADE
WAS INACCURATE INAPPROPRIATE
TARGETED IN IN SOME WAY IT LED
TO A CERTAIN HARM. THEY THEY
ALWAYS HAVE A LEGAL RECOURSE
THAT THEY CAN PURSUE BUT THAT
THAT'S- I JUST DON'T KNOW. WITH
ALL RESPECT. TO THE I
UNDERSTAND. THE P. GINNY WANTS
TO PROMOTE YOU KNOW. THE SAFETY
ARGUMENT I'M NOT SAYING THAT P.
GINNY DOESN'T CARE ABOUT SAFETY
AT ALL NOT I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THAT. BUT I ALSO DON'T BUY THE
ARGUMENT THE PGA ANY. AS AN
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE TO ITS-
SHAREHOLDERS OF PRESUME AT SOME
POINT COME OUT OF BANKRUPTCY
AND HAVE SHARE HOLDERS WITH
EQUITY AGAIN. DIED DIED IT'S
JUST FOCUS JUST ON THE SAFETY
AND IT'S NOT ABOUT A P. GENIES
BOTTOM LINE AND AVOIDING. A
LIABILITY AND AGAIN POWER
SHUTTLES HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY I
DON'T YOU KNOW THESE THESE
WILDFIRES A CATASTROPHIC AND WE
CAN AVOID THEM. THAT IS A GOOD
THING BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF
DRAWING THAT LINE AND THE
SCOPE. DOT I HAVE A I AGREE
WITH MAYOR OF THE CARTER THAT
THAT SHOULD NOT BE OF EXACT A
SENIOR EXECUTIVE P. GINNY
MAKING THAT. A DECISION THAT IS
A PUBLIC ROLE IN TERMS OF
BALANCING OUT SAFETY AND MY
FINAL QUESTION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE MISTER CHAIR.
CENTER STERN I KNOW IS TALKED
ABOUT DVRS OF DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE. WITH WITH HIM
IT IS A PART OF THE SOLUTION ON
SO MANY LEVELS IN TERMS OF
REDUCING OUR NEED FOR MORE AND
MORE TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE MORE
DECENTRALIZED. APPROACH AND SO
THAT DISABILITIES WHETHER IT'S
A NURSING HOME OR A BUSINESS OR
A OR AN INDIVIDUAL CAN. KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON THE POWER ON EVEN
IF THERE IS A POWER SHUT DOWN.
THROUGH ENERGY STORAGE PGA ANY
AT AND OTHER I OR USE HAVE MADE
IT VERY VERY HARD AND LINK THE
TO GET INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENTS. FORWARD DVRS
PARTICULARLY FOR BUSINESSES. WE
HAD A BILL EARLIER THIS YEAR
WITH THE I. O. U.'S FOUGHT TO
TRY TO PUT BETTER STANDARDS IN
PLACE SO THAT FARMS OR
BUSINESSES OR SCHOOLS OR
WHATEVER ELSE. CAN GET A QUICK
AND EFFICIENT INTERCONNECTION
AGREEMENT FOR SOLAR FOR ENERGY
STORAGE SO THEY CAN TAKE THEIR
ENERGY FUTURE INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS. AND RESPECTFUL TO SEE IF
YOU SEE HAS NOT BEEN
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL HERE
EITHER AND WE NEED MORE DVRS
AND SO WILL P. GINNY BE A
BETTER ACTOR IN TERMS OF
ALLOWING. BUSINESSES AND
SCHOOLS INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE
THOSE DVRS SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE THESE CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES FOR A POWER SHUT
DOWN. FROM FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
SERVICE ABSOLUTELYSUPPORT THAT
I DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFICS IN
TERMS OF THE CHALLENGES ON THE
OF THE PROCESSES OF THE
INTERCONNECTIONS. OF TAKING
THAT DOWN AS A FOLLOW UP FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
SOME OF THOSE PICKUPS ARE AND
HOW WE CAN HELP. US STREAMLINED
SOME OF THOSE PROCESS HE'S
FINALLY FROM HER CUP.
UNDERSTOOD BUT WE WILL IT FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE WE SUPPORT. OF
D. OURS AND FRANKLY WE'RE
ACTUALLY AS PART OF OUR SYSTEM
HARDENING AND RESILIENCE
EFFORT. INSTEAD OF JUST
BUILDING THE GREAT LIKE FOR
LIKE RIGHT THAT'S EXISTED FOR.
MORE THAN A CENTURY IN SOME
CASES FOR LOOKING AT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES OF. A HOW DO WE-
IMPLEMENT AND LEVERAGE THE D.
R. SOLUTIONS LATEST QUIZ
TECHNOLOGY WITH THE REMOVAL.
CAPABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. A SERVICE TO CUSTOMERS
IN SOME CASES IN A MICROWAVE.
TOP OF A SET. AS OPPOSED TO
RUNNING. A ELECTRICAL OVERHEAD
LINES ARE UNDERGROUND LINES TO
SOME OF THESE URBAN WILDLAND
INTERFACE IS BECAUSE THAT IS
ONE WAY. OF HOW WE MITIGATE
RISK IS TO REMOVE THAT.
ELECTRICAL LINE OF FROM THE
ACTUAL HIGH FALL RISK AREA RISK
REMOVAL THE NASA REMOVAL IS THE
BEST WAY TO MITIGATE THAT RISK.
OKAY I JUST I THINK THAT THE I.
R. USE HAVE YOU D. E. OURS IS A
THREAT TO THEIR BUSINESS MODEL
AND OF WORK TO UNDERMINE THEM.
AND I HOPE THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING FLUX AN ATTITUDE CHANGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER. AND I DO HAVE A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS IN A GOOD WAY TO
MAKE A COMMENT FIRST AND WE
WANT TO GET ON TO THE SECOND
PANEL. BUT THESE ARE IMPORTANT
ISSUES AND I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES OF
THE BEFORE. I HEARD THREE WORDS.
THAT I HAVE NEVER HEARD FROM P.
JEANNIE BEFORE. THREE WORK AND
I'M HAPPY AND EXCITED THAT I
HEARD THE- IN THOSE THREE WORDS
ARE. I OWN IT. I'VE NEVER HEARD
THAT IN THE NINE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON ISSUES
RELATED TO P. JEANNIE I'VE
NEVER HEARD THOSE WORDS. AND
THAT'S GOOD THAT WE'RE HEARING
THEM TODAY. BECAUSE THE THREE
WORDS THAT I'M HISTORICALLY
HEARD HAVE BEEN DENY DENY DENY.
THIS IS THIS IS TO BE AN
EXCITING MOMENT BECAUSE WE
WE'VE GIVEN. YOU KNOW THEY WERE
ALL WILLING TO GIVE SECOND
CHANCES TO COMPANIES TO PEOPLE
TO ISSUES AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. IS THE THIRD CHANCE
AND THAT'S THE ONE I THINK P.
GENIES LOOKING FOR NOW. AND
THEY HAVE TO EARN IT. AND IS
CENTER WIENER ASKED THE
QUESTION A COUPLE MINUTES AGO.
YOU KNOW I GO BACK TO THOSE
DAYS EIGHT DAYS IN IN THE LAST
NINE YEARS AND YOU KNOW WHY WHY
THEY DIDN'T BILL THAT GRID OR
WHY THEY DIDN'T MAKE IT IS
RESILIENT. BUT WHY THEY DIDN'T
DO THE THINGS THAT WERE
NECESSARY AND WHAT I SAW. IT
BUT I THINK WE'VE LEARNED IS
YOU KNOW WE'RE DEALING WITH A
CONVICTED. FELON. WE'RE DEALING
WITH A COMPANY THAT DIVERTED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FROM SAFETY FROM MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS TWO BONUSES AND
PROFIT ANOTHER THING. WE SAW
WHAT I CONSIDERED A CORRUPT
COMPANY AND WE SAW CORRUPTS
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AT
THE TIME. YEAH I THINK THOSE
THINGS HOPEFULLY HAVE CHANGED
AT PGA. AND I THINK. THAT WILL
ALLOW FOR THE OPENING. AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT THIRD
CHANCE SO I APPRECIATE THOSE
THREE WORDS TODAY THANK. WOULD
LIKE TO DO IS YOU CAN ASK A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT MISS
THOMAS JACOBSON THE OVEN IS THE
YOU HAVE THE LETTER THAT YOU
HAD SENT TO THE UTILITIES IN.
ON OCTOBER TWENTY SIX OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE LETTER THAT
OUTLINED SOME OF THE ISSUES IN
CONDITIONS THAT YOU WERE
CONCERNED WITH. HELLO YES AND
CAL FIRE IN THE UC WERE
CONCERNED WITH OVER. THE D.
ENERGIES ATION PROGRAM AT THE
TIME AND- THE LETTER S. FOR
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF DETAIL.
IN FACT HEN I SAW THE LETTER
AYE AYE. BACK IN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I LOOKED AT IT AND IT
SHOULD MIKE GOT I DON'T HAVE
THE UTILITIES CN. CAN DO THIS
AND- THEN THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF CONDITIONS INCLUDE WANTED
CLARIFICATION DID THEY GET THE
CLARIFICATION THAT THEY- SHOULD
ASK THEM BUT WAS THE
CLARIFICATION PROVIDED TO THE
UTILITIES OVER THE- FROM THE
LETTER THAT WAS SENT. WE HAD
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS OBVIOUSLY
SINCE THAT THAT WAS ALMOST A
YEAR AGO NOW SO I DO IT WOULD
BE GREAT TO GET CONFIRMATION
FROM THEM BUT WE CERTAINLY
ENGAGE WITH THEM ON CLARIFYING
WHERE WE COULD I THINK SOME OF
THE ISSUES. FOR EXAMPLE IT WAS
BROUGHT UP BY SENATOR STERN IN
TERMS OF THE DEFINITION OF OWN
ABILITY AND STUFF. IS STILL AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION BUT I
WOULD I WOULD I WOULD SAY YES
THAT FOR THE MOST PART WE WERE
ABLE TO PRY THE CLARIFICATIONS.
WE SPEND A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF TIME REALLY DIVING INTO THE
DETAILS OF IT AS MY- TITLE
MENTIONED I'M I'M AN OFFICE
PERSON RIGHT I'M AN OPERATIONAL
PERSON SO IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF EXACTLY HOW DO WE-
EXECUTE. ON THESE DIFFERENT
ENGAGEMENTS THAT WERE HAVING SO
IT GETS DOWN TO THE DEFINITIONS
OF THE TERMS. HOW DO YOU DEFINE
THE POLYGONS WHEN THEY'RE
SENDING US THE MAPS WHERE
EXACTLY IS THE OUTSIDE THE
BOUNDARY OF THE POLY GONE. SO
THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL IS AN
ONGOING PROCESS TO GET TO THE
LEVEL OF SPECIFICITY. THAT WE
ALL KNOW WE NEED TO GET TO. THE
GOOD. AND UP ALL THE RESEARCH
CENTER I ABSOLUTELY COMPLETELY
WITH WHAT MISS THOMAS JACOBSON
SAID WE HAVE RECEIVED A
CLARIFICATION. AS I THINK THE
GENESIS OF THAT LETTER WAS
BEGAN THAT OCTOBER EVENT. WHERE
WE HAD A LOT OF LESSONS
LEARNED. AND WE HAVE YOU KNOW
FRANKLY TRIPPED UP IN TERMS OF.
THE EXTERNAL STICKLER
COMMUNICATION AND WE COULD HAVE
DONE BETTER WE NEED TO DO
BETTER AND THAT WAS KIND OF
WHAT THAT LED TO AND- SINCE
THEN WE'VE BEEN PRO ACTIVELY
ENGAGED WITH MISS THOMAS JACOBS
AND HER TEAM. TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE EXPECTATIONS INCLUDING
DEVELOPING A DETAILED FORM.
THAT WOULD BE SUBMITTED TO THE
WARNING CENTER AT THE TIME.
THAT WE DO DO THE ACTIVATION AS
WELL AS PROVIDING. A
PRESCRIPTIVE DETAILED
INFORMATION THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF THE EVENTS SO THAT.
THERE'S COMPLETE STRUCTURED
THAT'S UNDERSTOOD ON OUR SIDE
AND WE CAN ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT
OUR PROCESS SEES. TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE. WE PROVIDE. THE DATA IN
AT THE RIGHT QUALITY CONTROL IN
PLACE SO THAT. IT A TO THE BEST
OF OUR EXTENT POSSIBLE. IS AS
ACCURATE AS A AS A CAN BE AN AS
TIMELY AS A CANDY. OKAY THAT
THE ISSUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I A DAY AFTER WHEN. THIS
OCCURRED. AND I SAW THE LETTER
AND THEN. IN THIS WAS AFTER THE
FIRST PS PS THE P. JEANNIE HAD
DUCTED AND THE COMMUNITY
OUTRAGE HAT CAME FROM THAT OF
AND THEN IS NOVEMBER CAME
NOVEMBER EIGHTEEN WE STARTED
SEEING THOSE CONDITIONS ARISE
P. JEANNIE ANNOUNCED THE
ANTICIPATED PS PS. EVENT IN THE
LAST MINUTE THEY DIDN'T GO
FORWARD WITH THAT. PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE EVEN THE
TRANSMISSION WAS A PART OF THAT
AND THEN WE SAW THE DISASTERS
OF FROM THAT AND I GUESS A I IS
I WAS LOOKING AT I SAID. YOU
KNOW FRANKLY. P. JEANNIE WAS
KIND OF IN A BAD SPOT. WERE
THEY GOING TO DO. THAT LETTER
THOSE REQUIREMENTS FOR SO TOUGH
THEY WERE NOT PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO. ABIDE BY
THOSE. BEFORE THAT P. S. P. S.
S. EVENT WE'RE GOING TO OCCUR.
AND SO I THINK EVERY JUST
MYSELF AND THAT THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE TO SHOW IT THAT THEY-
THEY TOOK THE CHANCE. THIS TWO
OR WE KNOW WE'RE GONNA GET IN
TROUBLE FROM BY NOT FOR
PROVIDING THE APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION BECAUSE WE CAN'T DO
IT AT THIS POINT. IS WE TOOK A
CHANCE AND DIDN'T DIDN'T DE
ENERGIZED AND THAT BUT THAT'S
JUST MY THINKING ON THAT AND WE
SAW THAT THE CATASTROPHE AND
DID THAT. THE DISASTER THAT
CAME FROM FROM THOSE FIRES OF
EIGHTEEN BUT OF. WHAT I LIKE TO
DO IS MISTER ARENA IS GO TO THE
CALICO I SAW A LITTLE BIT AND
COULD YOU ELABORATE A LITTLE%
BIT MORE ON. ON HOW YOU DECIDE
ON AREAS TO ASK TO POWER DOWN
IF THERE'S A- IF THERE IS A
LINE OF SUCCESSION OR PRIORITY
IN THE EVENT OF AN- EXTREME
EVENT OR A PS PS OF INVITE YOU
TO IT. YOU HAVE THE ABILITY AND
AS I ASKED EARLIER. TO RE
DIRECT THAT POWER IN AND. AND
OTHER THINGS PRIVATIZATION THAT
YOU GO THROUGH IN THAT. SO
ESSENTIALLY WHEN WE KNOW ARE
NOTIFIED BY THE UTILITY OF A
POTENTIAL PSP ASSESSMENT.
HOPEFULLY WE GET THAT AND AN
EARLY WARNING OF THAT AND WE
GET THE DETAILS FROM THE
UTILITY AS TO EXACTLY WHAT
LINES THEY'RE ANTICIPATING THAT
THEY WANT TO GET IT. THEY'RE
GOING TO DE ENERGIZED. BASED ON
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE A LARGE
TEAM OF ENGINEERS. THAT ARE.
TIGHTLY CONNECTED TO OUR
OPERATIONS CENTER AND THEY DO
EXTENSIVE STUDIES. AS TO ONCE
THOSE LINES ARE TAKEN OUT WHAT
ARE THE IMPACTS TO THIS-PARTICULAR AREA. WHAT OTHER
AREAS OF GENERATION AND
TRANSMISSION CAN BE UTILIZED TO
MITIGATE THAT TYPE OF OUTAGE.
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE. AS A
GRID OPERATOR WE EXPERIENCED
TRANSMISSION OUTAGES IN
GENERATION OUTAGES YOU KNOW AS
A AS A NORMAL COURSE OF DUTY
RIGHT AND SO WE HAVE EXTENSIVE
ABILITY TO STUDY THE SYSTEM.
AND DETERMINE WHAT THE IMPACTS
ARE. PART OF OUR ANALYSIS IS WE
HAVE AN OPTIMIZATION ENGINE.
THAT CAN FULLY OPTIMIZED TO THE
GRID TO THE BEST THAT IT THAT
IT CAN IN TERMS OF. OPTIMAL
DISPATCH SO ONCE WE GO THROUGH
THAT STUDY. WE COMMUNICATE WITH
THE UTILITY AS TO WHAT IS POT
POSSIBLY RECOMMENDED STEPS
MOVING FORWARD. AND THAT'S
WHERE COORDINATION WITH UTILITY
MAY RESULT IN A CHANGE IN WHAT
THEY INITIALLY ANTICIPATED AS A
TRENT TRANSMISSION OUTAGE.
THERE IS A GOOD THANK YOU. IS
THAT I GUESS WHAT THIS PROBABLY
GOES TO. THE THREE OF THEM IN
TERMS OF THE STANDARDS THE
NGUYEN STANDARDS THAT ARE
NECESSARY LOOKED AT THE KIND OF
THE CRITERIA USED FOR THE PSP
AS A VENDOR LIST OF THE
CRITERIA THAT THAT IS OUTLINED
IN THE WIND THAT I THINK THE
GENIE IS TALKING ABOUT IS
TWENTY FIVE MILES PER HOUR
FORTY FIVE OR SOMETHING IN A IN
A- GUSTER SOMETHING IS
DIFFERENT. HOWEVER THESE
THRESHOLDS SECTION THE MINIMUM
WINDS SPEEDS STANDARDS FOR
UTILITY POLES AND OTHERS THE
GEO NINETY FIVE. RULE THAT
QUITE A LOT HIGHER THAN THE
FORTY MILES PER HOUR IN THE
OTHER UTILITIES DON'T HAVE THAT
THAT THRESHOLD SO IS IT TO. HOW
DID YOU DEVELOP THAT STANDARD
THAT NUMBER ANYWAY THAT WOULD
THAT WOULD BE YOUR TRIGGER
POINT. THAT THAT NUMBER WAS
INTENDED TO BE A GENERAL RULE
OF THUMB JUST IN TERMS OF
GUIDANCE AND IT IN MY REMARKS
SENATOR I HAD TO MENTION THAT
ONE PLACE THAT WE ARE. WE MADE
PROGRESS ON IS CORRELATING ARE
CIRCUITS TO THE PERFORMANCE OF
WINDS. WHICH MEANS AS WINDS
PICK UP THERE'S OUTAGES SO WE
START TO SEE OUR ON OUR SYSTEM
WHETHER THAT'S EQUIPMENT
RELATED WHETHER THAT'S
VEGETATION COMING IN CONTACT.
WITH THE LINES AND WE'VE DONE
YOU KNOW THAT ANALYSIS FOR OUR
CIRCUS IN THE HIGH FAR RISK
AREAS SO WE'RE- LOOKING TO BE
MORE IN A STRATEGIC AND
TARGETED. IN TERMS OF WHAT IS
THAT OF PROBABILITY OF A LOOK
LIKE OF OUTAGE PRODUCING WIND
BECAUSE IN THIS CASE WERE
CORRELATING THE OUTAGE AS A
LEADING INDICATOR TO A
POTENTIAL FIRE IGNITION A KEEP
IN MIND NOT ALL OUTAGES. TURN
INTO FAR IGNITIONS AYE SHE VERY
FEW OUTAGES. DO BUT THAT'S NOT
A BILL THE UNDERLYING KINDA
MECHANISM AND MODEL THAT WE'VE
COME UP WITH SO THE TWENTY FIVE
TO FORTY FIVE WAS INTENDED TO
BE. JUST MORE OF A DIRECTIONAL
A TYPE OF A GUIDELINE IF YOU
WANT TO CALL IT. IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY. A AN ABSOLUTE.
OKAY THE AND THAT. THAT'S GOOD
TO HEAR THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF FACTORS AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
SURE YOU'LL YOU'LL BE WORKING
ON IN TERMS OF THE NEXT PHASE
OF DEVELOPING THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT TOOLS AND WHAT. WHAT WHICH
STANDARDS THERE SAID IN. AS IT
MOVES FORWARD SO YOU CAN
MONITOR THAT A LITTLE MORE AND
I GUESS WHAT. WHAT I'M LOOKING
AT IS AT THE END. WHEN THERE IS
AN EVENT AND YOU REVIEW THOSE
EVENTS THEY HAVE A P. S. P. S.
CALLED POWERS OFF THE RE ENGAGE
REENERGIZE THEN YOU REVIEW
THOSE AFTER THE REPORTS COME IN.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO LEARN
FROM THOSE AND HOW DO YOU
EXPECT THAT TO GUIDE FUTURE.
EITHER REGULATIONS OR
REQUIREMENTS AND I GUESS WHAT
I'M TRYING TO USE IT SO WE CAN
GET THAT METRIC DOWN TO
SOMETHING THAT IS CONTROLLABLE
AND REFINED ENOUGH SO WE CAN
AVOID THE PS PS OF INCHES WE
HAVE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHICH I KNOW THIS IS JUST THAT.
I'M HOPING A TEMPORARY. THE PS
PS OF ENTERED ARE ARE JUST.
TEMPORARY THAT WE WILL HAVE A
RESILIENT SYSTEM ROBUST SYSTEM
AND NOT THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT SHARING THE POWER
OFF BECAUSE WE KNOW TO
WITHSTAND THAT IS THAT WITH
THE- END GOAL IS. WELL I AM THE
WITH THE- UTILITIES ARE
DEVELOPING THEIR HOME HIS PEERS
PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW IS A THEIR
DEPENDENCE ON THE FINANCE WITH
THE FINANCIAL INDEX THAT EACH
COMPANY IS DEVELOPING FOR THEIR
TERRITORY AND NOT INDEXED
SEEKS. OUT SEVERAL FACTORS INTO
CONSIDERATION WIND BEING ONE OF
THEM BUT SOME CHRISTIAN
RELATIVE HUMIDITY OF
INVIOLABILITY OF FUEL. OR OTHER
CRITICAL FACTORS THAT THEY'RE
ALL LOOKING AT THE AS WELL AS
HISTORIC CIRCUIT PERFORMANCE.
EACH UTILITY IS. DEVELOPING
THEIR OWN THAT SEEKING THE FROM
FACTORS INTO CONSIDERATION AND-
THOSE INDEXES ARE BECOMING MORE
AND MORE COMPLEX. AND THE WAY
THAT THEIR OPERATIONALIZE IN
THEIR PROCESS SEES IS THAT IF
THE SPECIFIC. IN THE YOU KNOW
IF INDEX REACHES A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD THAT'S WHEN THE
UTILITY ACTIVATES INTO THEIR PS
PS WATCH. AND TELL THEM YOU
KNOW AND THEN WE GO FORWARD
FROM THERE SO THE THING
COMMUTER THE ONE THE ONE AREA
FOR THE STATE TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THE UTILITIES ARE DEVELOPING
THESE. L. INDICES AND HOW THE
TIE WITH THE STATE'S
ASSESSMENTS OF FIRE THREATS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT ONE IN THE
SAME AND ONE CAN BE USED TO
INFORM THE OTHER AND THERE'S
INTO DEPENDENCY IS THERE. BUT
IN ORDER FOR THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
TO FUNCTION EFFECTIVELY WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO RECONCILE THE
UTILITY FIRE THREAT POTENTIAL
INDEXES WITH THE OVER ALL
THREAT ASSESSMENT IS THE STATE.
SO THAT'S- A THINK IS GOING. TO
TAKE SOME TIME AND ILL. YOU
KNEW WHAT IT YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL CAN FACTOR HERE IS
THAT THE YOU KNOW IT WHEN IT
COMES TO WIND IT'S NOT SO MUCH
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR POLLS TO
WITHSTAND THE CERTAIN WIND
FACTOR I MEAN ONE. THE FIRST
POINT IS FULL OF THE MOST THE
L. ROBUST PIECE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE POOL FAILURES
ARE THE- LOWEST. YOU KNOW OUT
OF ALL THE STATISTICS OF FIRING
CONNECTIONS THAT'S THE BILL ONE
OF THE WILL WAS BECAUSE IT IS
AND I MEAN IT. DOES LITTLE AT
LEAST LIKE A PIECE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO FAIL ELLEN
THE CONDUCTOR IS MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO FAILED ON THE POLE.
OWN AND YOU KNOW BUT EVEN MORE
SO WHAT YOU'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT IS A VEGETATION FAILURE AND
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE TOUGH
PART YOU KNOW YOU CAN DESIGN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SUIT TO
WITHSTAND A CERTAIN NGUYEN
FACTOR BUT- EL YOU CAN EVEN
KEEP INCREASING THE CONDUCT THE
STRENGTH. BUT IF YOU KNOW YOU
HOME YOU KNOW WITH WINS OVER
YOU KNOW THIRTY FIVE MILES PER
HOUR GUSTS YOU STARTING TO HOLD
THE TREES AND VEGETATION
FAILING THAT FLIES ON THE WIND
UNTIL IT HIT SOMETHING. AND
THAT SOMETHING CAN BE A AND
ENERGIZED CONDUCTOR SO HELD THE
YOU KNOW SO THAT UNITS THAT'S
PART OF THE REASON WHY THE
WINDOWS IN THE PORN FACTOR HERE
IN JUST ABOUT DESIGNING. THE
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE TO
WITHSTAND CERTAIN WINS ISN'T
QUITE ENOUGH IN ITSELF TO
REDUCE. THE RISK DOWN IN THIS
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT CAN BE
DONE. ALL IN THAT RESPECT BUT
GOING BACK TO THE SCHOOL
QUESTION. ELTON. WHEN THE
UTILITIES DE ENERGIZE IN DOING
THE ASSESSMENTS AFTER THE FACT
IN THIS ONE ELEMENTS ALL OF YOU
KNOW UNDERSTANDING HOW THE
UTILITIES DECISION MAKING
PROCESS AND FACTORS LIKE WIND
IN THE FIGHT FOR A POTENTIAL
INDEX THAT GO INTO IT WITH THE
OTHER ONE IS THE RISK TOLERANCE
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN GOING BACK TO AND ALL THE
YOU KNOW WHETHER ALL OF ITS
FINANCIAL OR SAFETY YOU KNOW
THE EVERY AND CITY HAS A
DIFFERENT RISK TOLERANCE I MEAN
THAT'S JUST THE NATURE ALL OF
PALM WITH RESTORE INCE'S ARE
THERE SPECIFIC TO THE AND CITY.
OF AN IN EVERYBODY'S RISK
ASSESSMENT THIS DIFFERENCE SO
UTILITY LAKE AS THE GENIE FOR
EXAMPLE CAN SAID THE RISK
TOLERANCE TO BE ZERO ZERO
IGNITION SO FIRES FROM OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE ALL YOU KNOW
THAT CAN BE THE RISK TOLERANCE
OF THE OTHER UTILITIES THAT FOR
WHATEVER REASON MAYBE THAT'S
THEIR ASSESSMENTS OF WHAT'S
BEST FOR THE PUBLIC MAYBE
THEY'D SEEKING YEAR THE L.
THERE THE FINANCIAL VIABILITY
OF THE COMPANY ISN'T SO COUNTS
WITH WHATEVER THAT IS THEY SAID
THEY WERE A RISK TOLERANCE.
HOURS RISK TOLERANCE MADE THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE MAY BE
DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON. THE
STATE AGENCY OR ALL. A SPECIFIC
JURISDICTION RATE ELM IN MAYBE
IN SOME CASES AS THE STATE'S WE
COULD TOLERATE A UTILITY
IGNITION OF A FIRE. IF THE
DAMAGES BELOW A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD NOW HOLLOW DO WE DEAL
WITH THAT RATE IF WE HOW OF
THESE DIFFERENT RISK TOLERANCES
IN THE UTILITY BASED ON THAT
RISK TOLERANCE IS ONCE. WITH
THE AT THE SITES TO THE
ENERGIZED THEIR LINES IF
THERE'S A RISK OF ANY A
CONNECTION. ALL HOW DO WE AS
THE REGULATOR THEN THE SIDE
WITH THE DOT WAS AN ACCEPTABLE
DECISIONS TO MAKE RIGHT NOW ALL
KIND OF SITTING. IN THE IN THE
I OWN A CHAIR ON THE ON THE
RECEIVING SIDE THAN THE
REGULATORY ROLE I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO MAKE THAT ASSESSMENT. OF
WHETHER THEIR DECISION TO THE
ENERGIZED BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
THERE MIGHT BE A RISK OF
IGNITION AND MAY BE A LOSS OF
ONE PROPERTY WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN THE DEVASTATING. YELP WILD
FIRE BECAUSE THE CONDITIONS TO
MAKE IT. SPREAD THROUGH THE
ENTIRE TERRITORY WERE THERE BUT
THERE WAS A LEGITIMATE RISK OF
AN IGNITION IS THAT THE CLIP
DOUBLE OR NOT. I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION OF THAT
RIGHT I DON'T THINK THAT ANSWER
EXISTS AND SO SOMETHING WILL
NEED TO HOP IN AS WE MOVE
FORWARD HERE. TO ENGAGE FURTHER
IN THAT CONVERSATION IN THE
SEAT WITH THE WE ALL. YOU KNOW
ARE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A E. L.
HE IS A STATE. COMMUNICATE WHAT
THAT RISK TOLERANCE. IS WITH
THE PUBLIC WITH RISK TOLERANCES
AND THEN HOW TO MANAGE IT WOULD
IF WE CAN GET THERE TO AT
LEAST. EXPOSE OF WOOD THE RISK
TOLERANCES ARE OF DIFFERENT
ENTITIES SO FOR EXAMPLE FOR
UTILITIES OF THE RISK TOLERANCE
IS TRULY KNOWING IGNITIONS A
THINK THEY NEED TO COMMUNICATE
THAT SO AT LEAST. WE KNOW THAT
CRITERIA WITH WHICH THE WORKING.
THAT WAS. THAT IT WAS AN
EXCELLENT WAY TO END THIS PANEL
DISCUSSION. THERE REALLY WAS
BECAUSE THAT WAS THAT'S THE
ENTIRE ISSUE RIGHT THERE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
AND FIND WITH THAT RISK
TOLERANCE IS AND WHO HOW. WE AS
A COMMUNITY AS A SOCIETY ARE
WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANKS I KNOW
THIS ONE A LOT LONGER THAN
ANTICIPATED BUT MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU YOU. WILL NOW
MOVE TO OUR PANEL NUMBER TWO SO
IF I COULD CALL UP OUR NEXT
PANELIST. OF LANCE HASTINGS
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATIONS CREATION IS NICE
TO SEE YOU SCOTT. MURDER SHOT
SENIOR ADVISER REGULATORY
AFFAIRS FOR CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION.
MELISSA COUSIN IT'S LEGAL
DIRECTOR FOR CENTER FOR
ACCESSIBLE TECHNOLOGY. KERRY
KERRY CRAWLEY HEALDSBURG
UTILITY DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY
OF HILLSBORO. AS WELL AS
ALEXANDER COPE. THE GENERAL
MANAGER EAST BAY MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT. AND I'M
ASSUMING THAT IS CALLED. A VERY
GOOD TO PLEASE COME UP AND
AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I THINK FOR ALL OF US
IT SO WELL WORTH IT I THINK
THERE'S ENOUGH HOPEFULLY ENOUGH
ROOM. FOR EVERYONE IT'S A GOOD
THING WE GOT MAYOR LICCARDO OUT
OF HER EARLIER THAT'S GOOD. WE
WOULD HAVE ROOM OR ANYWAY. SO
THAT'S WONDERFUL WELL. THANK
YOU FOR A THE URGENT WORK
YOU'RE DOING IN THE P. S. P. S.
SPACE TRYING TO COORDINATE IN
EVENT. WALL MINIMIZING ITS
IMPACTS OF. THE NEXT DAY YOU
KNOW I'D LIKE TO REALLY TALK
ABOUT THE VARIOUS CUSTOMERS
PERSPECTIVES OF AND THOSE
IMPACTED BY THE P. S. P. S.
ADVANCE MY HOPE IS THAT. WE'LL
BE ABLE TO THROUGH THIS
DISCUSSION. AND WAS INTO A
COVERED THINGS THAT WEREN'T
COVERED IN THAT THE CONSECUTIVE
BACKGROUND PAPERS AND THAT'S OF
THE RESPONSIBILITY THE LADY. OF
THE COMMUNITY AROUND THE PS PS
IS SO YOU CAN HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT ON OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND
OUR CUSTOMERS IS B. S. P. AS A
VENT BUT IT ALSO PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FORCE US TO
BETTER PREPARE FOR DISASTERS
GENERALLY. TO REDUCE THAT
COMMUNITY RISK WHICH I THINK IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ALL VERY
MUCH INTERESTED IN AND I
APPRECIATE SENATOR STERN.
DIRECTION IN HIS PREVIOUS
COMMENTS RELATED TO THAT SO IF
AN EARTHQUAKE OR A CYBER ATTACK
OR ANY OTHER HORRIFIC EVENT
OCCURS. IN GREATLY IMPACTS OUR
ELECTRICITY GRID OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE PREPARED TO
WITHSTAND THAT POWER LOST. TO
SOME DEGREE. UNDERSTANDABLY
THERE ARE CHALLENGES WITH
CALIFORNIA BEING IN THE P. S.
P. S. REGIME I HOPE TO. DISCUSS
EACH OTHER'S CHALLENGES TODAY.
BUT I HOPE WE CAN FOCUS ON SOME
SOLUTIONS THAT THAT WE CAN GET
WAYS TO LESSEN THE IMPACTS OF
THESE EVENTS. AND TO STRENGTHEN
OUR COMMUNITIES SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WELCOME AND I
GUESS WE MAY START WITH THE
ORDER THAT. WE HAVE IN THE
BEGIN WITH MR HASTINGS WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND FOR THE MEMBERS.
I'D APPRECIATE THE UP TO
REPRESENT A BUSINESS FOR YOU
REGARDING PS PS AND- WE WORK
WITH THE COALITION OF AG
INDUSTRIAL COMMERCIAL USERS
MANY OF WHICH WERE THE ROMANS
ONE OF KNOWLEDGE THAT ARE
APPRECIATION FOR BEING ABLE TO.
HAVE PERCENT TODAY. THAT YOU'RE
RIGHT ABOUT THE CONCLUSION OF
LAST PAEL WHAT A GREAT WAY TO
WRAP THAT UP AND FOCUS INTO
OURS BECAUSE WE'RE ON THE
BUSINESS END OF THE PS PS. AND
I'M NOT HERE TODAY TO SAY. YOU
KNOW GOSH WE'RE GONNA LOSE ALL
KINDS OF WHICH IS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IN THE PROCESS
BECAUSE THAT IS A FOREGONE
CONCLUSION. BUT RATHER CREATE A
NUDGE TO PUSH UPWARD FOR A
SOLUTION AND I THINK IT WAS HIT
UPON RIGHT THERE AT THE END. IF
YOU CAN IDENTIFY THIS OF
VEGETATION ISSUE. THAT'S GOING
TO CAUSE. A POWER SHUT DOWN
REQUIREMENTS. LET'S ADDRESS
THAT. AND LET'S ADDRESS IT WITH
ALL VIGOR AND ATTENTION. WE DID
POLAR MEMBERS PART OF THE
HEARING AND THANKS FOR GIVING
US IN ADVANCE. DIRECTIVE TO
FOCUS ON SOLUTIONS RATHER THAN.
THE PAIN. HAVE A SHUT DOWN. AND
ALL THE FEEDBACK WE GOT WAS IN
THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS. AND
THIS IS ACROSS A- WHOLE RANGE
OF MANUFACTURERS IS FORTY EIGHT
HOURS NOTICE. THAT ALLOWS US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROPERLY
SHUT DOWN OUR EQUIPMENT. MANAGE
WHAT IS ON THE FLOOR MANAGER
EMPLOYEES AND BE PREPARED. AND
THEN FOR OUT HOWEVER LONG THE
EVENT OCCURS THERE'S GOING TO
BE ANOTHER FORTY EIGHT HOURS ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT TO POWER
BACK UP. SO FOR MANUFACTURING
PERSPECTIVE THE MINIMUM IS FOUR
DAYS NOT WITHSTANDING HOWEVER
LONG THAT DID THE EVENT MAY
OCCUR. IN THE IMPACT OF THAT IN
THE COST AND I DO APPRECIATE
SENATOR WINTERS COMMENTS
EARLIER. IT COMES AT A GREAT
COST FROM AN EMPLOYMENT
STANDPOINT LOSS OF PRODUCT
ANECDOTALLYI CAN SHARE THAT
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO.
MY PREVIOUS EMPLOYER LOS FORTY
THOUSAND GALLONS OF BEER AT A
BREWERY IN LOS ANGELES BECAUSE
THE POWER WENT OUT. YEAH THAT
SOUNDS GOOD WELL TOO BAD BUT
IT'S A PERISHABLE PRODUCT IS A
PROCESS THE AND- DID COST A
GREAT DEAL OF MONEY FOR THAT
BREWER. SO HOW WE MANAGE THAT
AND I'M JUST USING THESE AS YOU
KNOW RATIONALE TO PUSH BACK UP
WHERE WE GO THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS LIABILITY. THAT WE
FACE WHEN THE POWER GOES OUT.
AND I DON'T KNOW A SINGLE
MANUFACTURER THAT DECIDED TO
COME TO CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE
POWER MIGHT BE ON MOST OF THE
TIME. AND THEY EXPECT THE POWER
TO BE ON ALL OF THE TIME.
BARRING A NATURAL CATASTROPHE.
AB QUAKERS ARE SOME OF HE
MAGNITUDE. TO THE EXTENT WE
HAVE CONTROL OVER THE OUTAGE
LET'S REALLY FOCUS OUR EFFORT
ENERGY. IN THAT REGARD BECAUSE
I THINK IT'LL BE VERY HELPFUL
FOR US. THE AND SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT I GOT FOR YOU IN
FACT OUR MEMBERSHIP IS. QUITE
DIVERSE. IMAGINE IF YOU'RE A
CEMENT MANUFACTURE IN U.
VIRTUALLY HAD ALMOST NO NOTICE.
TO TURN OFF YOUR FACTORY IN IF
YOU HAVE PRODUCT IN. THE PIPES
BEING PREPARED YOU'RE GONNA
LOSE THAT YOU LOSE THE
EQUIPMENT. THE REFERENCE TO
REFINERIES FLARING WAS ALSO
MADE EARLIER. IT IT'S HARD IN
THE ABSTRACT. FOR I THINK THE
PUBLIC CERTAINLY TO GRASP AND
MAYBE SOMETIMES. AND THOSE OF
US HERE IN SACRAMENTO. IS A
REALLY SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT
COULD HAPPEN. AND WOULD RATHER
THAT THEY NOT SO IF WE GET A
WARNING FOR A P. S. P. S. FOR
US. YOU HAVE TO SHUT DOWN. YOU
CAN'T RISK LIKE YOU CAN AS A
RESIDENT WHEN YOU HEAR ALL THE
POWER MAY GO OUT LET'S. LET'S
WEATHER THE STORM AND IF IT
DOESN'T GO OUT YOU CAN HIGH
FIVE YOUR FAMILY IN YOUR HOUSE
WELL WE MADE IT THROUGH. WE
DON'T HAVE THAT OPTION. THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIND THE BEST WAY TO
AVOID TO ALL EXTENT POSSIBLE.
ANY SHUT DOWNS IS REALLY UR
GOAL OR OBJECTIVE TO BE HERE
TODAY. AND TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE DISCUSSION ON WE RECOGNIZE
IS GONNA BE AT AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION. THE END OF A WRAP
pWHO UNITED CONVERSATION EARLIER
IN THE WEEK. THAT THIS HEARING.
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO HAPPEN NEXT
YEAR. THIS IS A ONE TIME
HEARING CLOSE GET THE ISSUES ON
THE TABLE. PERHAPS FOCUS ON
SOME REALLY. MEANINGFUL
SOLUTIONS THAT CAN BE ACTED
UPON AS SOON AS THIS
LEGISLATURE CAN ACT. SO THE
NEXT YEAR IF THERE IS A HEARING
YOU TO BE WELL WE DID A GREAT
JOB. WE HAVEN'T HAD A SHUT DOWN
AS A RESULT OF WILDFIRE. THE
END THE FACT IT WOULD THE
PREVIOUS PANEL DID CONCLUDE THE
WAY THEY DID IF THAT'S THE
PROBLEM AND I'M I'M NOT HERE TO
SAY THAT IT IS. BUT IF THAT'S
THE PROBLEM. LET'S WORK WITH
UTILITIES AND FIND IF IT'S ONE
PARTICULAR VULNERABLE VALLEY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ONE
VULNERABLE VALLEY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. LET'S FIX IT. AND
THE ISSUE OF HAVING. READY
POWER AVAILABLE. IF THE PART IS
GONNA GO OUT TO HAVE GENERATION
AVAILABLE. THAT WOULD BE GREAT
IF THE LAWS ALLOWED US TO DO
THAT. BECAUSE WE BUILD ALL
KINDS OF BACK UP OPPORTUNITIES
BUT WE JUST DON'T HAVE THAT.
THAT LUXURY IN MOST CASES THE
HARMONIZATION OF THE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS TO DO THAT. IS ALL
MAKE THE POINT THAT IT'S THE
IMPACT IS FAR GREATER TO HAVE A
SHUT DOWN FOR US IN OUR CASE A
MINIMUM FOUR DAYS. TO KEEP THAT
FACILITY RUNNING AND KEEP
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYED THAT WOULD
BE TO HAVE THAT BACK A
GENERATION OF WHATEVER SOURCE.
IDEALLY THE LEAST POLLUTING AS
POSSIBLE TO KICK IN AND KEEP
THE PROCESS GOING. SO IT IS
PART OF YOUR SOLUTION PLEASE
CONSIDER THOSE THINGS TO GIVE
US THE OPTIONS. THE AND I WILL
CONCLUDE WITH THE OF THE NOTION
THAT ON THE BACKGROUND MATERIAL
SAYS WITH GREAT POWER COMES
GREAT RESPONSIBILITY. AND I
LIKE TO DO A LITTLE REFORM THAT
TO SAY WITH RELIABLE POWER
COMES GREAT OPPORTUNITY. AND
THAT WOULD GIVE US NOT. THE
ABILITY TO GROW BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA TO HELP. GROW THE
ECONOMY AND BE LIKENED. TO CALL
OURSELVES THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY WHEN WE'RE HAVING A
HEARING LIKE THIS IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A PARADOX. IT'S HARD FOR
US TO SAY THAT. WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE OVER TALK ABOUT TURN OFF
OF THE POWER SO. GOOD WITH THAT
ALL DAHLE PROCEDURE THERE
LATELY. STOCK ONE QUESTION IF
YOU DO MANY OF YOUR FACILITIES.
HAVE COGENERATION OPPORTUNITIES
TO THEY HAVE FACILITIES ON SITE
AND IF THEY DON'T ARE THOSE.
BEING PLANNED NOW I BELIEVE YOU
CAN BETTER BE A PLANS NOW
BECAUSE OF THE SITUATION THE
THREAT THAT WE FACE. THE
REACTION TO THE BURGER WAS THEY
PUT INTO FIVE MEGAWATT GAS
FIRED TURBINES IMMEDIATELY. AT
TO AVOID THAT PROBLEM IN THE
FUTURE. BUT THAT'S NOT A
PROCESS YOU CAN JUST GO IS BUT
WAS MENTIONED BEFORE HOME DEPOT
AND BUY ONE. AND PUT IT IN AND
GET GOING CITY DOES TAKE A LOT
OF PLANNING YEAH WE THINK
THERE'S JUST AS MUCH PLAN THAT
COULD BE DONE IN MANAGING. THE
THREAT ON THE ENDS THAT YOU
JUST HEARD FROM THE PREVIOUS
PANEL SO THEY WOULD HAVE TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION AND THAT
WOULD BE AN IDEAL SITUATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
COMMERCIAL. WELCOME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR EXTENDING
THE INVITATION. TO THE
CALIFORNIA SO IN STORE
DISSOCIATION TO BE HERE AND
REPRESENT THE INTERESTS OF THE
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCE
COMMUNITY. YEAH I WAS A IT
REALLY BROUGHT HOME TO ME JUST
HOW TRAGIC THE CONSEQUENCES CAN
BE WHEN MISTER HASTINGS
MENTIONED THAT FORTY THOUSAND
GALLONS OF BEER LOST MY MIND I
IMMEDIATELY CONVERTED THAT TO.
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
PINTS WHICH YOU KNOW REALLY
MAKES MORE PALPABLE. NOW I MEAN
WE REALLY CAN'T STAND YET HAVE
SUFFERED MORE LOSSES LIKE THAT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE
STUDENT RESOURCES CAN HELP. IT
IN FACT YOU MENTIONED COMBINED
HEAT AND POWER. IN THE STATE IS
REALLY BEEN MOVING AWAY FROM
COMBINED HEAT AND POWER. IN
PART BECAUSE OF OUR DESIRE D.
CARBONIZED THE GRID. SO POLICY
ACTIONS TAKEN THE PC OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS OF PHILLY.
BEEN GEARED MORE TOWARDS
RAMPING DOWN THE AMOUNT OF.
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE OVERTIME. THE BACKGROUND
DOCUMENT THAT WAS PREPARED VIEW.
FRAMES. THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS FORGET GRID OPERATORS
AND FOR THE FOR THE REGULATORS
THAT OVERSEE THEM AS A DILEMMA
BECAUSE ON ONE SIDE YOU HAVE
THE CERTAINTY THAT TAKING
ACTION. TO INITIATE A POWER
SHUT OFF WILL CAUSE SOME HARM
AND THAT COULD BE FINANCIAL. IT
COULD BE SAFETY RELATED OR EVEN
JUST PSYCHOLOGICAL THE-
INCONVENIENCE IN THE
AGGRAVATION OF HAVING A PARTIAL
FOR DAYS AT A TIME. THAT'S
1100% CERTAINTY THE PROBABILITY
IS ONE THAT THAT WILL HAPPEN IF
YOU EXECUTE IT. ON THE OTHER
HAND YOU HAVE THE UNCERTAINTY
OF WHETHER YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE AVOIDED A FIRE AND IF SO
WHAT WHAT WOULD THE MAGNITUDE
OF THAT FAR HAVE BEEN. SO YOU
CAN THINK OF IT AS-
ESSENTIALLY. OF ESTIMATING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ACTION VERSES
IN ACTION. SO THE HIGHER THE
LEVEL OF THE COST. OF A- OF A
POWER SHUT OFF. THE MORE
RELUCTANT UTILITIES WILL BE TO
EXECUTE THEM BECAUSE THE
BOUNCING BACK COST VERSUS.
THEIR THEIR ASSESSMENT OF THE
FIRE RISK. SO WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
WE CAN HELP TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF POWER SHUT OFF BY
MAINTAINING POWER AND THAT
COULD BE EITHER FOR TARGETED
CUSTOMERS ARE FOR ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES. PAGES FOUR AND
FIVE OF THE BACKGROUND DOCUMENT.
LIST SEVERAL EXAMPLES OF THE
KINDS OF SOCIETAL COSTS AND
SAFETY RELATED RISK THE PARTIAL
OFTEN POSE. A SELLER AND
STORAGE CONTRACT THE ADDRESS
TWO MAJOR CATEGORIES OF THE
SOCIETAL COSTS THE ONE IS THE
DESTRUCTION OF POWER TO
CRITICAL FACILITIES. AND THE
OTHER IS THE RISK THAT POWER
SHUT OFF IMPOSES ON CERTAIN
CATEGORIES OF HONORABLE
CUSTOMERS. OF SEWER AND STORAGE
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO RESILIENCY
AND CONTRIBUTE TO REDUCING THE
COST A PARTIAL LOSS. UNDER
THREE BROAD CONFIGURATIONS SO
THE FIRST WOULD BE. THE
SIMPLEST AND EASIEST TO DEPLOY
IS PROVIDING BACKUP POWER FOR
SINGLE FACILITIES ARE
RESIDENCES AND RECENT ACTIONS
HERE AT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
PC OF ALREADY SHOWN A STRONG
INTEREST IN HELPING FACILITATE
THAT. I CAN TALK ABOUT ABOUT
THAT'LL IT MORE LATER. THE
OTHER TWO CONFIGURATIONS ARE
MORE CHALLENGING FINANCIALLY
REGULATORY EARLY AND
TECHNICALLY. THE SECOND IS THAT.
A DISTRIBUTED SOLAR IN STORAGE
COULD BE CONFIGURED IN A WAY
THAT UTILITIES OR UTILITIES TO
AGGREGATORS COULD CALM THOSE
RESOURCES TO HELP MAINTAIN
RELIABILITY SO THAT NO ONE
LOSES POWER THIS IS RELATED TO
THE LIKE THE IN MINUS ONE
CONTINGENCIES THAT UTILITIES
ALREADY REQUIRED TO PREPARE FOR.
AND IN THIS CASE YOU HAVE A
COMMUNITY THAT DOESN'T ENTIRELY
ISOLATED MAYBE IT HAS TWO OR
THREE DIFFERENT TRANSITION
PATHWAYS SERVING IT. BUT IN THE
EVENT THAT ONE OR TWO OF THOSE
NEED TO BE TAKEN OUT OF SERVICE.
WHERE UTILITY WOULD NORMALLY
NEED TO. START INITIATING
ROTATING OUTAGES IN ORDER TO
BALANCE. THE DEMAND AND THE
LOAD POCKET BUT THE AVAILABLE
SUPPLY. D. E. OURS COULD BE
CALLED ON TO HELP THE UTILITY
RIDE THROUGH THOSE HOURS WERE
DEMAND MIGHT EXCEED. THE
AVAILABLE SUPPLY AND OUR JUST
COULD BE AVOIDED. THAT IS
CHALLENGING WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE THE REGULATORY PROCESS IN
PLACE TO DO THAT. THERE'S A AN
ANALOGOUS PROGRAM AT THE CHI SO
RUNS THE RELIABILITY DEMAND
RESPONSE RESOURCE PROGRAM. MY
IMPRESSION IS IT'S AN UNDER
UTILIZED PROGRAM AND IT'S NOT
GEOGRAPHICALLY GRANULAR ENOUGH.
BUT IT COULD SERVE AS A MODEL
FOR HOW WE WOULD USE THE OURS
IN THIS HI CONFIGURATION. AND
THEN THE THIRD IS USING SOLAR
STORAGE AND OTHER DVRS. AND A
FULLY ISLAND AND MICRO GRIDS
OPERATION MODE. AND THERE ARE
VERY FEW EXAMPLES OF THAT THAT
SPANNED MORE THAN A COUPLE OF
FACILITIES AND FOR MANY OF YOU
ARE FAMILIAR WITH BREAK A
SPRINGS THAT TAKE YEARS IT WAS
FUNDED BY. NUMEROUS GRANTS
IMMUNITY COMMISSION FROM DO YOU
EAT THE UTILITIES AND IT TOOK A
LONG TIME TO FIGURE IT OUT. BUT
JUST BECAUSE DIFFICULT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT IT'S NOT WORTH
PUTTING CONSIDERABLE EFFORT
INTO EVALUATING. WHERE THE
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES ARE THAT
MIGHT MOST BENEFIT FROM USING
D. R. AS IN THESE WAYS AND THEN
AND VIGOROUSLY PURSUING AT
LEAST SOME PILOTS TO START.
THOSE LESSONS LEARNED AND TO
DEVELOP THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT WE NEED TO DO
THAT. IN THE MEANTIME WE SHOULD
STRIVE TO ACCELERATE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF DVRS FOR THAT
FIRST USE CASE SINGLE FACILITY
OR SINGLE RESIDENTS BACKUP
POWER. WE CAN DO THAT NOW WE
CAN DO THAT QUICKLY IN THIS
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE. THE
COST THE POWER CHAU LOS IMPOSE
ON THESE MOBILE CUSTOMERS. AND
COMMUNITIES. BECAUSE THESE ARE
CRITICAL FACILITIES MAINTAIN
POWER. THERE'S ONE THING I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT WE
OFTEN THINK ABOUT. SOLAR AND
STORAGE IS BEING THE ALL IN
SOLUTION AND- THE UTILITIES
HAVE ALREADY BEEN PROMOTING THE
USE OF BACKUP GENERATORS.
HOSPITALS ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
BACKUP GENERATORS. THE ONE
INTERESTING APPOINT KEEP IN
MIND. IS THAT EVEN WHERE THESE
FOSSIL FUELED BACKUP GENERATORS
ARE ALREADY IN PLACE OR
CUSTOMERS ARE CONSIDERING LIKE.
ODD THE- CUSTOMER THE PURCHASE
THE TWO FIVE MEGAWATT CASTER
BINDS. THE USE OF SOLAR AND
STORAGE AND ACTUALLY ENHANCE
THE RESILIENCY CAN WORK IN
TANDEM WITH OF TRADITIONAL
FOSSIL FUEL GENERATOR AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS. THE WAY
THAT IT DOES US OBVIOUSLY JUST
SOLAR WILL DISPLACE KILOWATT
HOURS OTHERWISE PRODUCED BY THE
DIESEL OR GAS FOR GENERATOR.
BUT WITH THE ARK ADDITION OF
STORAGE THAT ENHANCES. THE
ABILITY OF THE BACKUP GENERATOR
TO OPERATE IN A MORE STEADY
STATE MODE BECAUSE DID THE
STORAGE CAN ABSORB THE LARGE
FLUCTUATIONS IN DEMAND THAT ARE
TYPICAL SERVING ONE CUSTOMER
THEY'RE NOT SMOOTHED OUT BY
HAVING. HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS
OF CUSTOMERS WE GET SMOOTH
TRANSITIONS THEY'RE VERY.
JAGGED FOR SPIKES IN DEMAND AND
THAT CAUSES A DIESEL GENERATOR
TO OPERATE VERY INEFFICIENTLY
AND IT STARTS EMITTING A LOT OF
PARTICULATES AS IS RAMPING UP
QUICKLY TO TRY TO MEET THOSE. I
WIDE SWINGS IN DEMAND I KNOW
THAT THE NATIONAL NOBLE ENERGY
LAB AND OTHERS HAVE. DONE SOME
STUDIES AND SHOWN THE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS OF ADDING
STORAGE. AS A HYBRID. BACK UP
CLUB POWER SUPPLY. AND SO WITH
THAT I'LL JUST I'LL CLOSE HERE
AND SAY THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE SI PC
HAVE ALREADY GIVEN TO THE SE
OF CLEAN THE OURS TO PROVIDE
THIS BACK UP AND RESILIENCY
BENEFIT IN ADDITION TO THE MORE
CUSTOMARY OF BENEFITS THAT WE
THINK OF LIKE GRID VALUE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS. GOOD
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT INSIGHT INTO THAT AREA
THAT I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ARE
THINKING ABOUT AS MUCH AS THEY
SHOULD DISCUSS WITH. WELCOME
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS. I'M MELISSA
CABINETS AND THE LEGAL DIRECTOR
WITH THE CENTER FOR ACCESSIBLE
TECHNOLOGY WHERE I REGULARLY
REPRESENT THE INTERESTS OF THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. I'VE WORKED ON
ISSUES REGARDING THE ENERGY
STATION SINCE THE FIRST
APPLICATION BY SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT FOLLOWING WHAT WITHIN THE
MOST DISASTROUS FIRES IN STATE
HISTORY IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN.
I WANT TO START UP A JOINING
THE OTHER PANELISTS BY THANKING
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE. AND THE COMPLEX ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ENERGY
STATION FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE AT
PARTICULARLY HIGH RISK.
EVERYONE AGREES THE POWERSHOT
OFFICE CREATE RISK OF HARM TO
AFFECTED POPULATIONS EVEN AS
THEIR INTENT IS TO REDUCE THE
OVERALL RISK OF CATASTROPHIC
WILD FIRE. BUT THE RISKS ARE
NOT SPREAD EVENLY THROUGHOUT
THE POPULATION. AS IS SO OFTEN
THE CASE HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
ALREADY VULNERABLE INCLUDING
THOSE THAT CONTAIN A PERSON
WITH A DISABILITY SOMEONE WHO
SUFFERS FROM CHRONIC ILLNESS OR
ANY OTHER FORM OF ACCESS TO
FUNCTIONAL NEED ARE AT
INCREASED RISK OF HARM.
PARTICULARLY DURING AN EXTENDED
POWER SHUT OFF. THIS IS BEEN
GENERALLY IDENTIFIED IN THE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL BACKGROUND
PAPER. BUT I WANT TO ELABORATE
ON SOME OF THE A CONSTITUENCIES
WERE MOST AT RISK. AND
HOPEFULLY DISCUSS SOME
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS. TO THE
WHITE PAPER SPECIFICALLY NOTES
THAT HOUSEHOLD CONTAINING A
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY ARE AT
RISK. BUT IT IS DOESN'T GIVE
SPECIFICS OF WHO THESE PEOPLE
MIGHT BE THERE WAS SOME
DISCUSSION EARLIER OF MEDICAL
BASELINE. BUT THAT'S ONLY A
TINY SLIVER OF THE POPULATION
THAT ACTUALLY AT RISK OF HARM
DURING AN EXTENDED POWER OUTAGE.
GREATER EXAMPLES OF COMMUNITIES
AT RISK. MOST OBVIOUSLY ARE
PEOPLE WHO RELY ON RESPIRATORS
OR OTHER DEVICES TO BRIEF.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE AT RISK
OF DEATH WITHOUT ONGOING ACCESS
TO A CONSISTENT ENERGY SUPPLY
AND THEY SIMPLY MUST HAVE POWER
FOR THE DURATION. BEYOND THAT
THOUGH THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
WHO RELY ON AN EXTENSIVE ARRAY
OF MEDICAL DEVICES POWERED BY
ELECTRICITY TO MAINTAIN THEIR
HEALTH. THESE CAN INCLUDE
INSULIN PUMPS AND GLUCOSE
MONITORS. NEBULIZERS C. PAP
MACHINES. AN EMERGENCY ALERT
SYSTEMS WHICH INCLUDE WIRED AS
WELL AS WIRELESS COMPONENTS AND
ALSO DEPEND ON RELIABLE
FUNCTIONING OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK. THE
HEALTH RISKS TO THESE
POPULATIONS DURING AN EXTENDED
OUTAGE MAY BE LESS DRAMATIC
THAN LOSS OF RESPIRATOR
ASSISTANCE BUT THEY'RE NO LESS
REAL. AND THEY MAY BE NO LESS
SEVERE. THEN THERE ARE
POPULATIONS WHO RELY ON
MEDICATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
REFRIGERATED INCLUDING INSULIN.
IN ADDITION TO THE IMMEDIATE
HEALTH RISKS TO THESE PEOPLE IF
THEY'RE UNABLE TO PROPERLY
STORE THEIR MEDICATION. AN
EXTENDED POWER OUTAGE MAY CAUSE
SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC BURDENS AS
PEOPLE HAVE TO REPLACE THE LOST
MEDICATIONS POTENTIALLY OUT OF
POCKET. THEN THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO USE MOBILITY DEVICES
POWERED BY ELECTRICITY. THEY
MAY NOT BE AN IMMEDIATE RISK OF
HARM WHEN A POWER OUTAGE TAKES
PLACE BUT IF THERE'S ANOTHER
EMERGENCY OF A FIRE ACTUALLY
BREAKS OUT IN AN EVACUATION IS
ORDERED. THEIR ABILITY TO
EVACUATE MOVE TO SAY FIFTY IS
LIKELY TO BE EXTREMELY
COMPROMISED. THEN THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T TOLERATE
EXTREME TEMPERATURES. THIS
GROUP OF PEOPLE MAY FACE X. THE
IMMEDIATE HEALTH RISKS OF OR
ELSE THEY MAY BE FORCED OUT OF
THEIR HOMES BECAUSE BY
DEFINITION OF P. SPS ADVANTAGE
IS GOING TO TAKE PLACE DURING
THAT SANTA ANA CONDITION OR
TIME OF HIGH WINDED HIGH FIRE
THREAT. WHEN TEMPERATURES ARE
HIGH. THEY MAY FACE IN ADDITION
TO THE HEALTH RISKS SUBSTANTIAL
ECONOMIC BURDENS. AS THEY UP
ARE FORCED TO PAY OUT OF POCKET
TO GET THEMSELVES TO A LOCATION
OF SAFETY. AND STAY THERE FOR
AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME. SO
THESE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
BROADER COMMUNITY. IDENTIFIERS
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
AT RISK. THE WHITE PAPER ALSO
IDENTIFY SOME SOCIAL COSTS OF
THE ENERGY STATION. BUT IT
LEAVES OUT MANY FORESEEABLE
COSTS INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE
MOST LIKELY TO IMPACT A. F. AND
WHICH IS ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS HOUSEHOLDS. FOR EXAMPLE
THE WHITE PAPER DOES KNOW THE
POTENTIAL FOR HAMPERED IT BACK
YOU ASIANS. BUT IT LEAVES OUT
IMPORTANT BARRIERS THAT MAY BE
WIDESPREAD. INCLUDING RISKS TO
PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
MANUALLY OPEN THEIR GARAGE DOOR
IN ORDER TO GET THEIR CAR OUT
OF THEIR RESIDENTS. PEOPLE WHO
CAN'T GET OUT OF THEIR HOMES IF
THE ELEVATORS AREN'T
FUNCTIONING DUE TO A LACK OF
POWER. AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
DEPENDENT FOR MOBILITY ON
DEVICES SUCH AS POWER
WHEELCHAIR SCOOTERS THAT MAY
LOSE ACCESS TO CHARGING. THE
WHITE PAPER OF KNOWLEDGE IS
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES TO
BUSINESSES. BUT IT DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES
TO INDIVIDUALS. WHICH CAN
INCLUDE LOSS OF FOOD AND
MEDICINE WHEN FEDERATION IS
DISRUPTED. LOST EARNINGS WITH A
PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT IS CLOSED
AN OUT OF POCKET SAFETY IN
ORDER. I'M SORRY OUT OF POCKET
SPENDING IN ORDER TO ENHANCE
THEIR PERSONAL SAFETY. THIS IS
A SERIOUS ISSUE FOR ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS OF
COMMUNITIES. MAY FACE MORE
LOSSES THAN AVERAGE AND ALSO
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY LIKELY
TO BE LOW INCOME AND NOT WELL
POSITIONED TO ABSORB OUT OF
POCKET COSTS. AND THEN FINALLY
THE WHITE PAPER NOTES THE
POTENTIAL FOR INCREASED FIRE
RISKS DO PEOPLE WHO USE
GENERATORS DURING THE TIME OF
AN EXTENDED OUTAGE. BUT IT
DOESN'T IDENTIFY OTHER FIRE
TRIGGERS SUCH AS PEOPLE WHO MAY
USE CANDLES OR OTHER FLAME
BASED SOURCES OF LIGHT IF THE
POWERS ARE OUT. BACKYARD GRILLS
RATHER FLAYED BASED SOURCES OF
COOKING IF THEIR KITCHEN
EQUIPMENT DOESN'T WORK. AND
OTHER FIRE TRIGGERS THAT MAY
COME. ACTUALLY INCREASE THE
RISK OF FIRE WHEN THE GREATEST
DOWN. SO AFTER EXPANDING
SUBSTANTIALLY THE LIST OF RISKS
I DO WANT TO BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS THAT
POLICYMAKERS CAN CONSIDER.
OPTIONS CAN INCLUDE PROVIDING
ADEQUATE BACKUP POWER TO
MAINTAIN RELIABILITY FOR THE
PEOPLE MOST AT RISK. THIS COULD
BE GENERATORS. STORAGE OPTIONS
OR OTHER METHODS ON BUT FOR ANY
OF THESE TO WORK FOR A HALF AN
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE POLICY MAKERS
WILL NEED TO ADDRESS THE COST
OF THESE SOLUTIONS PRIORITIZE
NEED AND THE ABOUT PRAGMATIC
ISSUES OF INSTALLATION AND
MAKING THEM AVAILABLE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO THEY WILL. MOST
BENEFIT. THERE'S A SUBSTANTIAL
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL ADVANCE
PLANNING BY UTILITIES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PERSONNEL. TO ENSURE
ONGOING ACCESS TO MEDICATION
AND OTHER FORMS OF ASSISTANCE
FOR PEOPLE AT RISK. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY VITAL FOR PEOPLE
WHO RECEIVE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
CARE. BECAUSE THEIR PERSONAL
ASSISTANTS ARE LIKELY TO ALSO
BE CAUGHT UP IN AN EXTENDED
OUTAGE LOSE ACCESS
TRANSPORTATION POTENTIALLY. OR
ABILITY TO CALM AND PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THE PEOPLE THEY
NORMALLY. WORK WITH. RELOCATION
ASSISTANCE REYES HOUSEHOLDS. TO
APPROPRIATE LOCATIONS OUTSIDE
OF A DE ENERGIZED DE ENERGIZED
ZONE OR ELSE TO ADEQUATELY
SUPPLIED EMERGENCY SHELTERS.
AND ALL OF THIS DEPENDS ON
EFFECTIVE PLANNING A UTILITIES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PERSONNEL ON HOW TO BE
PREPARED TO PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
ASSISTANCE AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSES DURING AN EXTENDED
OUTAGE ON THIS MAY REQUIRE WORK
AS WAS TOUCHED ON IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL. TO ALLOW FOR
GREATER EASE OF A INFORMATION
SHARING BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UTILITIES AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SERVICES.
AND THEN FINALLY AFTER AN EVENT
IS OVER POLICY MAKERS NEED TO
CONSIDER FOR UP THE OPTIONS FOR
FINANCIAL REIMBURSEMENTS. A FOR
LOSSES SUFFERED BY PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCE THE EXTENDED OUTAGE.
THIS IS JUST AN OVERVIEW OF
ITEMS THAT MIGHT BE RELEVANT TO
THE NEEDS OF F. AND HOUSEHOLDS
IMPACTED BY POWER SHUT OFFS I
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING
IN AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO BRING THESE IDEAS
TO FRUITION AND HELP PROTECT
THE SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE MOST
AT RISK DURING AN EXTENDED
OUTAGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
IT SAYS THAT THE- HELPFUL AND I
APPRECIATE THE SOLUTIONS THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT ONE OF THE IF
YOU KNOW SOME UTILITIES HAVE
DISCUSSED THE AND PROPOSED TO
TRANSPORT VULNERABLE RESIDENTS
TO COOLING CENTERS OR TO OTHER
PLACES WHERE THEY CAN.
CONSISTING THEMSELVES WITH SOME
POWER HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THAT ISSUE. I THINK THAT THAT
MIGHT BE A VERY USEFUL
COMPONENT OF PREPARATION TO
DATE I AM NOT AWARE OF FULLY.
STOCK AND PREPARED FULL ON
EMERGENCY SHELTERS BEING
PROVIDED IT'S MORE BEEN ON THE
ORDER OF DROP IN CENTERS SO I
AM NOT AWARE OF SHELTERS THAT
ARE PREPARED TO HOUSE PEOPLE
FOR SEVERAL DAY PERIOD I AM NOT
AWARE OF PREPARATIONS TO
PROVIDE MEDICATION FOR PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT NEED A LA WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION BACK WITH THE
ORIGINAL APPLICATION BY SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THE UTILITY
SUGGESTED FOR EXAMPLE
TRANSPORTING PEOPLE TO
HOSPITALS. ON END WHEN FURTHER
INQUIRY ASKED AND WILL YOU.
GUARANTEE THAT PATIENTS THAT
THAT THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
OTHERWISE HEALTHY AND IF THEIR
DEVICES WERE FUNCTIONING WOOD
FROM AND HEALTHY WILL ACTUALLY
BE ADMITTED. TO THE HOSPITAL'S
THEY COULDN'T SAY AND WHEN
ASKED AND WE COVER THE HOSPITAL
BILLS THAT THESE PEOPLE PEOPLE
WILL EXPERIENCE. OF THERE WAS
NO ENTHUSIASM FOR THE- AND WHEN
ASKED WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF A
FURTHER EMERGENCY. BENT AT
HOSPITAL BEDS WERE IN SHORT
SUPPLY AND- HOW WOULD. THREE
ARCHING HAPPEN THERE WAS NO
THOUGHT. YET IN PLACE FOR THAT
SO FULLY STOCKED EMERGENCY
SHELTERS I DID IDENTIFY AS A
POTENTIAL COMPONENT OF THE
SOLUTION BUT A DROP IN CENTER
WHERE YOU CAN CHARGE YOUR CELL
PHONE AND SAID IN THEIR
CONDITIONING FOR AN HOUR OR
TWO. ON ISN'T SUFFICIENT TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF HONORABLE
PEOPLE THANK YOU AND THANKS FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY AND
ESPECIALLY YOUR THE CONTEXT YOU
CAN PROVIDE BECAUSE OF THE
HISTORY GOING BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT AFTER RISKY
GENIES EXPERIENCES IN THEIR
DIRECTION THAT WAY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND IF I MAY JUST ADD
ON THAT THE INITIAL CPC
DECISION AND FOLLOW UP
DECISION. BUT THE SAN DIEGO
APPLICATIONS DID TALK ABOUT THE
NEED FOR MITIGATION IN THE
EVENT OF A WHAT'S NOW BEING
REFERRED TO AS PS PS EVENTS.
AND. MY PAST ORGANIZATION WAS
THE ONE THAT FILED THAT
APPLICATION AND PURSUED THAT SO
I'M VERY. KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
IT BUT I AM. DISAPPOINTED THAT
THERE HAS BEEN LESS DEVELOPMENT
OF WHAT FACT MITIGATION
REQUIREMENTS REALLY MEANS. AT
THE CPUC AND I BELIEVE WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE AND SO. THAT NEED
FOR MITIGATION. REALLY IS. THE
UNIVERSE THAT WERE OPERATING IN
NOW ON AND I'M SORRY THAT WERE
STILL AT SUCH A PRELIMINARY
STAGE WHEN THE DECISION WAS
MADE QUITE SOMETIME AGO TO SAY
MITIGATION IS NEEDED. AND THEN.
NOT ACTUALLY FURTHER DEVELOPED
AS TO WHAT THAT MEANS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER CRAWLEY
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
HOSTING THIS MEETING AND
INVITING US TO SPEAK ON OUR
ISSUES SO I AM THE YOU TO
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY HILLS
BERG HILLS WERE PROVIDES
ELECTRIC WATER AND WASTEWATER
SERVICES SO IN DOING THAT WE
OWN AND OPERATE OUR OWN
ELECTRIC DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
BUT WE ARE A TRANSMISSION
DEPENDENT ON PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITY AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT WE RELY ON P. GINNY'S
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM TO PROVIDE
ALL THE POWER AND ENERGY NEEDS.
TO THE CITY SO IN P. GINNY
STARTS TO TALK ABOUT
TRANSMISSION LEVEL OUR SAFETY
SHUT DOWNS WE GET REALLY
CONCERNED BECAUSE OF THE CITY
WIDE BLACKOUT SO LITERALLY ALL
OF OUR CITY FUNCTIONALITY IS
AFFECTED SO PLEASE FIRE
DISTRICT HOSPITALS OUR ABILITY
PROVIDE WATER SERVICE ABILITY
PROVIDE WASTEWATER COLLECTION
TREATMENT NOT YOU KNOW NOT TO
MENTION JUST ELECTRICITY IN
GENERAL ARE ALL AFFECTED BY
TRANSITION LEVEL OUTAGE TO
BECOME VERY CRITICAL FOR US IN
PREPARING OUR COMMUNITY FOR
THOSE TYPES OF EVENTS THAT WE
HAVE. EARLY COMMUNICATION WITH
P. GINNY AND GINNY IS AWARE OF
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THAT
TRANSITION LIKE IT SHUT DOWN TO
OUR CITY HISTORICALLY. GINNY'S
LOOKED AT. VERSION CONNECTED
PUBLICLY ONLY TILL IT IS A
SINGLE METER AND THEREFORE
SINGLE CUSTOMER. REALLY DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF AWARENESS OF WHAT
THE COMMUNITY IS THAT SERVED BY
THAT SINGLE METER IN SINGLE
CONNECTION TO THEIR SYSTEM. AND
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONCERNS WE HAVE IN THIS IS HOW
DO THEY ASSESS THIS RISK OF
SHUTTING DOWN THE TRANSMISSION
VERSES LOSING POWER TO A
COMMUNITY OF TWELVE THOUSAND.
AND SO WE'VE GONE THROUGH THAT
DISCUSSION WITH THEM AND TRY TO
GET SOME CLARIFICATION. AND TRY
TO HELP PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION BUT IT'S STILL NOT
CLEAR TO US. HOW P. GENIE IS
PRIORITIZING THOSE TRANSMISSION
SHUT DOWNS AND THE ULTIMATE THE
FACT OF LOSING POWER FOR. COULD
BE FOUR DAYS INTO A CITY SO
THAT THOSE ARE BIG ISSUES FOR
US AND AGAIN THOSE ARE ISSUES
THAT ARE GOING TO FACT NOT JUST
ELECTRIC UTILITY PROVIDING ITS
SERVICES IT'S GONNA AFFECT THE
CITY'S ABILITY PROVIDE POLICE
AND FIRE SERVICES DURING THOSE
PERIODS TIME WITH YOUR COULD BE
CRITICALLY NEEDED. IT'S GOOD
AFFECTING THE CITY'S ABILITY
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER AND
WATER FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION AS
WELL ITS ABILITY TO FRIED YOU
KNOW COLLECTION SYSTEM FOR
WASTE WATER IN TREATING THAT
WASTE WATER THOSE THINGS DON'T
STOP JUST BECAUSE THE POWER
WENT OUT SO THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS WE GOT I. CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
REALLY CONCERNED WITH THIS
TRANSITION LEVEL OUTAGES. SO
GOING BACK TO TIMING WE NEED
EARLY NOTICE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
AS THE DISCUSSION GOES IN AS
THE P. GINNY OR THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES REACH OUT TO
COLORADO AND LET THEM KNOW THAT
HEY THESE ARE POTENTIALLY
TRANSITION LINES ARE GONNA BE
OUT OF SCOPE OR IN A SCHOOL FOR
pAT THAT POINT IN TIME WE NEED
TO KNOW AT LEAST SEVENTY TWO
HOURS IN ADVANCE SO THAT WE CAN
START REACHING OUT TO OUR STAFF
THEY ARE STOP NO HEY THERE'S A
POTENTIAL ISSUE THAT'S GOING ON
WE NEED TO MOBILIZE OUR
GENERATION FOR A BACKUP SUPPLY
TO OUR WATER WASTEWATER
FACILITIES. WE NEED TO LET
POLICE AND FIRE KNOW THAT HEY
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
PROBABLY WANT TO START SHOPPING
UP FOR AT LEAST KNOWING WHAT
RESOURCES YOU HAVE AVAILABLE TO
YOU. AND IN WITH THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE CAN WAIT FOR THE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIOD SO WE
NEED THAT EARLY NOTICE AND EVEN
IF IT'S WRONG EVEN IF THE
INFORMATION IS PARTIAL OR
POTENTIALLY INCORRECT IN THE
ULTIMATELY DON'T CALL FOR THAT
SHUT DOWN IN THE SCOPE THAT
THEY ORIGINALLY THOUGHT IT WAS.
IT'S BETTER FOR US TO HAVE THAT
EARLY WARNING. TO PREPARE AND
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME CLEAR
REQUIREMENTS. FOR THE MESS ROOM
UTILITIES THAT THEY WORK WITH
THE PUBLIC. UTILITIES AT OUR
TRANSMISSION DEPENDENT. TO
PROVIDE THAT EARLY
COMMUNICATION AND WARNING FOR
THESE. AGAIN AS WE GO INTO A
SHUT DOWN. WE NEED CONSTANT
COMMUNICATION WITH THE MEASURE
ON UTILITIES AND WILL YOU
PREFERRED TO BE IN THOSE ROOMS
WHEN THEM WHILE THEY'RE MAKING
THOSE DECISIONS. SO WE CAN HAVE
CONSTANT UPDATES OF WANT THE
ESTIMATED TIME RESTORATION.
WHAT IS OUR PROCESS WHAT ARE
THEY SEEING ON THE GROUND WITH
THEIR SSTEM. ARE THEY STARTING
THEIR INSPECTION SO THAT WE
COULD ALSO START INSPECTION OF
OUR SYSTEM TO RE ENERGIZE OUR
SYSTEM. BUT THAT CONSECUENCIAS
IN FROM THE INITIAL THOUGHT OF
HEY THIS MIGHT BE SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. ALL THE
WAY THROUGH RESTORATION IS
REALLY CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME CLEAR
MECHANISM. THAT REQUIRES THAT.
THE GATE AND THEN THE OTHER
THING OF HARD HIT ON IS. THIS
NEEDS TO BE A SHORT TERM
SOLUTION. THE UNCERTAINTY OF
SHUTDOWNS TRYING TO RUN A CITY
TRYING TO RUN BUSINESSES TRYING
TO JUST LIVE YOUR NORMAL LIFE.
THIS NEEDS TO BE A SHORT TERM
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE HAPPENING CALIFORNIA
THIS IS A GREAT STATE. THERE'S
A LOT OF TALENTED PEOPLE HERE.
THIS IS NOT A SOLUTION AT ALL
AND SO WE NEED TO FIND WAYS
THAT YOU KNOW. IDENTIFY WHAT
ARE THE KEY ISSUES AND REALLY
DRIVE AFTER THOSE SOLUTIONS.
SALUTE THIS BECOME SOMETHING
THAT'S IN OUR PAST AND WE'VE
LEARNED FROM IT BUT WE'VE MOVED
ON TO SOMETHING THAT'S MUCH
MORE RELIABLE. SO WHATEVER THAT
TAKES YOU KNOW PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITIES ARE CERTAINLY WILLING
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT EFFORT.
BUT THOSE ARE THE KEY POINTS
THAT I'D REALLY LIKE TO DRIVE
HOME WITH TO THE CHAIR AND THE
SENATORS OF THAT'S GREAT DID
THREE TO HEAR THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK
pTHEME IS THIS IS A TEMPORARY.
SOLUTION TO A BUT HOPEFULLY
TEMPORARY PROBLEM OF A SYSTEM
THAT. IS NOT GOING TO WITHSTAND
CERTAIN CONDITIONS AND HAS TO
BE DE ENERGIZED TO THAT AND
AGAIN. COMMUNICATION EARLY
COMMUNICATIONS LETTING US KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON REALLY MAKING
THOSE RISK ASSESSMENTS ON WHEN
YOU'RE SHUTTING DOWN
TRANSMISSION WHAT DOES THAT
REALLY AFFECTING AND SO HAVING
THE BEST FROM YOU TILL YOU HAVE
THAT AWARENESS AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT. IF I SHUT
OFF THIS ONE CUSTOMER TO FAX A
COMMUNITY OF TWELVE THOUSAND.
THE TO THE MAJOR THEME AS WELL
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
STRUGGLING WITH WHAT. WELCOME
THANK YOU ARE PROJECTS ARE
PRETENDING TO BE HERE. CARE
HEALTH AND THAT THIS IS A- AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION. ALSO
APPRECIATE OPPORTUNITY TO BACK
AT BATS CLEANUP NORMALLY I'D
WORRY ABOUT MAKING AN AFTER
LUNCH PRESENTATION BUT IT LOOKS
OUR CRICKET MATCHES TO. A
BEFORE LUNCH CHEF. BUT BELATED
LUNCH PRESENTATION SERVICES
THROUGH I HAVE FIVE TWO
RECURRING THEMES THAT LIKE TO
TRY TO COMMUNICATE TODAY ONE IS
THE SAME AS MISTER CRAWLEY AND
OTHERS. HAVE SAID IN THAT IN
THIS TIME. PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTIAL SCENARIO COMMUNICATION
AND COORDINATION ARE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL YOU CAN'T OVER DO IT.
AND THE SECOND IS THAT WE HOPE
THAT TED THIS THAT FIRE SEASON
WILL PROVIDE US A LOT OF
LESSONS LEARNED. IN THE TO BE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THOSE.
AND ADJUST THE APPROACH IS
GOING FORWARD. SO A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HE'S VERY MUCH NOW WE ARE
A MAJOR PUBLIC UTILITY N
CALIFORNIA. WE PROVIDE WATER
SERVICES TO ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE. AND WASTE WATER
SERVICES TO SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN ALAMEDA
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES. AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF FACILITIES TO
DO THAT WE HAVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED FACILITIES THAT ARE IN
THE SERVICE AREA AND IN THE
COUNTIES ALTHOUGH WE LEADING UP
TO OUR WATERSHED. N. DAB A
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF AS
A VERY REAL POSSIBILITY OF
IMPACTING US BECAUSE OUR
SERVICE AREA GREAT PORTIONS OF
IT. AND A WATERSHED ARE AT
ELEVATION AND THEY ARE IN
EXTREME FIRE THREAT AREAS. AND
SO WHEN WE ENGAGED IN THIS
PROCESS AS SOON AS WE HEARD
ABOUT IT I THINK OUR FIRST
LETTER COMMUNICATING OUR
INTEREST IN BEING A PART OF THE
PROCESS AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT
IT MEANS WAS IN JULY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS SOON AS IT WAS
ANNOUNCED. AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING HARD TO UNDERSTAND AND
ADAPT EVER SINCE THEN. FOR US
IT'S VERY REAL A DISTRIBUTION
LEVEL EVENT L. DISTRIBUTION
LEVEL ELECTRICAL OUTAGE HI HAS
THE POSSIBILITY IS REFERRED TO
LAST FIVE TO SEVEN DAYS AND IT%
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO IMPACT WE-
LEARNED UP UNTIL LAST WEEK. UP
TO TWO HUNDRED OF OUR
FACILITIES AT HALF OF ALL THE
FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE AND
THEN LAST WEEK WE HEARD THAT
MAYBE THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
FORTY THAT MIGHTBE IMPACTED
BRINGING THE TOTAL TO FORTY. I
JUST THE SEQUENCE OF
CONVERSATIONS WERE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE POTENTIAL
IMPLICATIONS ARE ANXIOUSLY AS
ME TO SHARE THAT IN OF THE YEAR
THE ACCURACY. OF THOSE
ESTIMATES OF WHAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPACTED. ARE AT VERY IMPORTANT
ADAM AN OVER ESTIMATE WHICH
MIGHT BE EASY TO PROVIDE CAUSES
US AND OTHERS TO EXPEND
CONSIDERABLE RESOURCES TRYING
TO BE PREPARED FOR SOMETHING
HUGE. CONVERSELY IN
UNDERESTIMATING WHICH WE DON'T
THINK SAID REALLY HAPPENED SO
AT THIS POINT. WOULD ALLOW
WOULD HAVE IS BEING
INSUFFICIENTLY PREPARED SO.
BACK TO YOU KNOW WE'RE AT A
CRITICAL SERVICE PROVIDER HAS
TO FIND OUT BY THAT. THE THAT
THE P. S. P. S. REQUIREMENTS
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW EVEN IN THE
CONTEXT OF BEING PREPAREDNESS
FOR PREPARE FOR OTHER
EMERGENCIES DISASTERS. OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AND SO WE
VIEW THAT YOU KNOW WE REALLY
DESERVE TO HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION ALL THE POSSIBLE
COORDINATION EVEN IF IT
REQUIRES PGA ADDING EXTRA
VALUABLE AND A GOOD INVESTMENT.
SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING TO
PREPARE JUST AS AN EXAMPLE
UTILITY. FIVE WE'VE BEEN USING
THE BEST INFORMATION AVAILABLE
THROUGH THAT COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION TO TRY TO BE
SURGICALLY FIVE I HAVE POSITION
GENERATORS AND RESOURCES TO BE
AVAILABLE BUT ALSO TRYING TO WE
WANT TO MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF
RESPONSE TIME THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT WE TALK ABOUT SEVENTY TWO
HOURS. AT POTENTIALLY AVAILABLE
BUT THE REALITIES IT COULD BE A
WHOLE LOT LESS THE WEATHER
CHANGES QUICKLY AND WE COULD
JUST HAVE EIGHT HOURS OR LESS
TO PREPARE BUT WE WANT THE
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS TO BE
VERY CLEAR SO THAT WE CAN
MAXIMIZE THAT BECAUSE OF ANY
ALL THE TIME WE GET TO MOBILIZE
AND MAKE THINGS HAPPEN. OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS
PROVIDING SAFE AND RELIABLE
WATER SERVICE. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE WATER IS
AVAILABLE FOR OUR CUSTOMERS FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS AND FOR
FIREFIGHTERS. WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THROUGH OUR
ACTIONS THAT WE AVOID A D.
PRESSURIZATION INCIDENT RIGHT
WE BASICALLY SUCKING SYSTEM
DRIER PORTIONS OF THE SYSTEM
DRY. BECAUSE THAT CREATES
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS AND THAT
ALSO MAKES IT HARD TO FIGHT
FIRES. SO WE HAVE STAFF IN
EXPANDING CONSIDERABLE
RESOURCES IT'S NOT LIKE WE
HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED POWER
OUTAGES BEFORE RIGHT THESE
HAPPEN WE'VE EXPERIENCED THEM.
BUT THE PARADIGM WAS DIFFERENT
IT WAS WELL THERE'S A POWER
OUTAGE IN OUR ELECT FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS WORK IN A S. A. P. TO
TRY TO BRING THAT SAYS. THOSE
SAID ISOLATED SYSTEMS BACK
ONLINE. NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LARGE AREAS THAT COULD BE
IMPACTED. AND SO WE WANT THEM
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE- WE
HAD THIRTY THREE PORTABLE PUMPS
AND GENERATORS HE'S OUR DIESEL
SYSTEMS AND ALSO A NUMBER OF
CRITICAL FACILITIES REATMENT
PLANTS AND SUCH HAVE. A HARD
STAND BY BY SYSTEMS. AND WE'VE
ADDED TO THAT WOULD PRETTY MUCH
DOUBLED IT BY LEASING EQUIPMENT
THAT GOT IN EARLY BOARD
APPROVED A- AN ADDITIONAL ON
NEAR THIRTY FIVE GENERATORS. SO
IMMOBILIZE THAT THROUGHOUT OUR
SYSTEM BOB WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE PUMPING PLANTS
THROUGHOUT THE SERVICE AREA.
AND WE ARE. AND SO WE'RE GOING
TO TURN THOSE THINGS ON AND
WE'VE GOT CONTRACTS FOR FUEL
TENDERS TO MOVE AROUND FEEL
AROUND IF THINGS ARE GONNA LAST
MORE THAN. A COUPLE OF DAYS
OUTAGE. AB BUT THERE'S GOING TO
BE IMPACTS FROM THAT LINKS BACK
TO SOME OF THE EARLIER
COMMENTS. AB THESE ARE ALL
DIESEL GENERATORS. AB AND
THEY'LL BE RELEASING AIR
EMISSIONS. I THAT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH A EAST BAY
MUCH GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
OBJECTIVES ARE CLIMATE CHANGE
MONITORING ESPONSE PLANS IS
NOT. THIS WAS IN PART OF THE
PLAN TO GO TO DISTRIBUTED STAND
BY SYSTEMS LIKE THIS. AND SO
WILL BE WORKING TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY CLEANER APPROACHES FOR
THE FUTURE. WE ACTUALLY DON'T
THINK THAT THIS WILL BE OVER
THIS YEAR AND PROBABLY
PERPETUATE INTO NEXT YEAR. BUT
THEY WEREN'T AVAILABLE FOR US
IN THE TIME THAT WE HAD A WAR
OF THE SIZE OR HORSEPOWER
DEPENDABILITY. UNFORTUNATELY
DIESEL CAN RUN FOR FIVE TO
SEVEN DAYS BUT THE BATTERIES.
AND IS SOLAR IS NOT AVAILABLE
IN A PORTABLE MODE. SO MAYBE
THERE'S A ROLE FOR THE STATE
AND THAT WAS EARLIER
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW THAT MIGHT.
BE APPROACH TO LOOK AT NEW
CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES. THAT
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE AND ALSO
HOPEFULLY TO THINK ABOUT
ALTERNATIVES THAT CAN MAKE
SEGUE OUT PUBLIC SECTOR
POWERSHOT OFFICE IN A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME. YOU
PROBABLY INVITED ME HERE
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED WITH
THE MEDIA IN OUR COMMUNITY
EXTENSIVELY IN OUR FAIR NUMBER
OF ARTICLES IN THE PAPER. AND
ON THE RADIO ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN HE BAY AREA. NOW
WE HAVE I HAVE REACHED OUT TO
OUR COMMUNITY TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND WHAT A PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF HIS. ARM WHAT IT
MEANS TO WATER SERVICE WHAT IT
MEANS THAT. WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
BE PREPARED WHAT IT MEANS FOR
OUR CUSTOMERS. AND THERE WAS A
RATHER CONVERSATION ABOUT BEING
PREPARED FOR EMERGENCY IN
GENERAL HAVING BACK UP WATER
SUPPLY FOOD AND A AND A WAY TO
COOK IT. NOW WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE OUT REACHING IS TO GO
BEYOND THAT AND HELP OUR
CUSTOMERS UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO
CONSIDER. WE WANNA MINIMIZE
OUTDOOR IRRIGATION TRY TO. HELP
PRESERVE WHAT WE HAVE IN THE
TANKS SO THAT WE CAN KEEP THEM
SUFFICIENTLY CHARGE TO AVOID IT
PRESSURIZATION INCIDENT. AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR ELECTRIC
SERVICE PROVIDERS SOME CREDIT
TO PGA ANY. OB THEY PROBABLY
VIEW US AS HAVING HARASSED THE
HELL OUT OF HIM OVER THE LAST
YEAR BUT WE NEED TO GET THE
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED AND HE- HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIVE. IF THERE WAS ONE
THING WE COULD ASK FURTHER IS
THAT TAB IT WILL. WE'VE TALKED
A LOT ABOUT CLEAR CHANNELS OF
COMMUNICATION AND THEY PROVIDED
US NUMBERS AND ASSURED US THAT
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE AVAILABLE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. AM WE HEAR
WHEN THE EMERGENCY ACTUALLY
HITS AND THAT IS PUBLIC SAFETY
SHOWER SHUT OFF AND- YOU HAVE
LARGE PORTIONS OF THE SERVICE
AREA OUT OF POWER POTENTIALLY.
IN OUR DESIRE IS TO. AT B. EVEN
FURTHER EMBEDDED IN THE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
WITH P. JEANNIE. HAVING A PHONE
NUMBER. IS HELPFUL BUT NOT AS
REASSURING AS HAVING OUR OWN
PRESENCE THERE TO BE ABLE TO
RELATE BACK TO OUR STAFF. M.
AND FINALLY WERE DEVELOPING A
COMPREHENSIVE PS PS MEDICATION
PLAN. AND YOU KNOW DRAWING ON
ALL THIS RETURN REAL TIME
INFORMATION ONE OF THE YOU KNOW
IT'S ONE THING TO RESPOND SO
WE'LL HAVE SOME TIME EIGHT.
MAYBE SEVENTY TWO HOURS TO
BEGIN TURNING THINGS OFF BUT WE
ALSO NEED A PLAN FOR HOW ARE WE
GONNA TURN THINGS BACK ON AGAIN
IT WAS A REFERENCE TO TAKE IN A
COUPLE OF DAYS TO BRING SAYS
SYSTEMS BACK ONLINE. BUT WITH A
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE PUMPING
PLANTS. AND A THERE WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
PGA ANY TO BE ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE WHAT WHICH ONES ARE
GOING TO BRING ON AND WE HAVE
TO HAVE PEOPLE THERE TO. TO
BRING ON THOSE PLANTS IT'S NOT
JUST FLIPPING A SWITCH THERE'S
A LOT TO IT. THERE ARE CERTAIN
LARGER SYSTEMS WE WANT TO BRING
ON FIRST. SO THAT OUR
DEVELOPMENT OF MITIGATION
PLANNING COORDINATION WITH PGA
ANY WE HOPE WE CAN FURTHER
REFINE THIS. BUT WE'RE PROBABLY
GONNA LIVE IT AND. AT BE
PUTTING THOSE EXPERIENCES INTO
THE PLAN FOR NEXT YEAR. SO IN
CLOSING AND WE VIEW THAT THIS
FIRE SEASON IS A TRANSITION
PERIOD. FOR HIS PAY MODE AND
OTHERS. THAT THERE WILL BE
LESSONS LEARNED. AND THAT TIME
WE NEED TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE THOSE. AND WE ALSO
HOPE THAT AS OTHERS HAVE
EXPRESSED THAT THEY'LL BE
ALTERNATIVES CONSIDER TO THIS
P. S. P. S. APPROACH BECAUSE
FAIRLY. DISRUPTIVE AND WE VALUE
THE ROLE THAT YOU'VE PLAYED AM
I SUGGEST THAT HAVE YOU WOULD
CONSIDER HAVING ANOTHER HEARING
NEXT YEAR TO DISCUSS THOSE
LESSONS LEARNED BECAUSE- WE
KNOW STUFF GOING TO HAPPEN AND
WE REALLY OUGHT TO BE SHARING
IT AND FIGURING OUT A PATH
FORWARD BASED ON THOSE
EXPERIENCES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
QUESTION FOR YOU MISTER CRAWLEY
ON IN TERMS OF HOW DO YOU GO
ABOUT NOTIFYING YOUR CUSTOMERS
TODAY. WHEN THERE'S A P. OR IF
THERE IS A HIS BIGGEST EVENT
WITH RAPTUROUS. OCCURS JOINT
MEDICAL FIRST I COULD CONNECT
SO FOR US SMALL CITY INTO THE
SIX THOUSAND CUSTOMERS SO IT'S
PROBABLY YOU KNOW TWO PHONE
NUMBERS IN OUR BILLING SYSTEM
INTO POTENTIALLY WOULD HAVE TO
CALL TWO THOUSAND CUSTOMERS AND
SO WE HAVE A- YOU KNOW ITS- A
VENDOR THAT PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE. STOCK QUICK BUT WE
WOULD ALSO USE AND BECAUSE A
SMALL CITY OF GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS OUR POLICE AND
FIRE. UNIX ALERTS SOCIAL MEDIA.
AS MUCH INFORMATION RESOURCES
OUT THERE THAT WE CAN GET TO
NOTIFY PEOPLE OF THE SITUATION
BUT WERE PREPARED. THROUGH A
VENDOR TO MAKE THESE REVERSE
PHONE CALLS TO EACH OF THE
PHONE NUMBERS ARE BILLING
SYSTEM AND WE'VE MADE A YOU
KNOW AN OUTREACH EFFORT TO OUR
CUSTOMERS TO. UPDATE THOSE THE
PHONE NUMBERS TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE GOOD INFORMATION BUT-
THAT'S ONLY ONE MEANS SOCIAL
MEDIA IS GOING TO BE ANOTHER
BIG PIECE OF THAT. BUT AGAIN.
EARLY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
EVENTS GOING TO HAPPEN OR MAY
OR MAY NOT HAPPEN HELPS US GIVE
SOME. EARLY WARNING TO OUR
CUSTOMERS OF HEY. YOU WANT TO
PROBABLY GET. WE'RE NOT SURE
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN YET OR
NOT BUT. BE PREPARED. THE
WEATHER'S CHANGING SO THANK YOU.
YEAH IT FOR US WE'VE BEEN OUT
REACHING AT ALREADY TO TRY TO
HELP PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. WE USE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD NEXT DOOR HAS ONE
COMMUNICATION VEHICLE WE HAVE
SOCIAL MEDIA THAT WE EMPLOY WE
HAVE OUR WEBSITE AS A GO TO
PLACE. NOW WHEN PEOPLE IF THEY
ARE EXPERIENCING ANY OUTAGES
THAT'S WHERE THEY WOULD GO TO.
OUR GOAL AT IT AS THE WATER
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO AVOID THE
OUTAGES. AND TO COMMUNICATE
MORE BROADLY ABOUT THE NEED TO
CONSERVE SO WE CAN PRESERVE.
AND WE TOP UP EVERYTHING. WHEN
WE GET A RED FLAG WARNING
FILLABLE THE TANKS MOBILIZE THE
GENERATORS. AND FUEL CONTRACTS
OUR HOPE IS THAT WILL BE IN A
POSITION WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
EVERYTHING IN WATER. BUT IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT WE HAVE ISOLATED
AREAS WHERE. THINGS ARE HEADED
TOWARDS D. PRESSURIZATION FOR
REASONS OUTSIDE OF OUR CONTROL.
THEN WE HAVE MORE SURGICAL
APPROACHES TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY WITH THE
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE IMPACTED SO.
WE STAY BROAD WILL EMPLOY ALL
OF OUR PRACTICES TO KEEP THE
SYSTEM PRESSURIZED IN IN WATER.
AND IF IT DOES TURN OUT THAT
THIS GOES ON FOR TOO LONG AND
WE SOMEHOW HAVE SOME PROBLEMS.
THEN WILL TARGET THAT COMMUNITY
AT TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. VERY GOOD.
JEFF QUESTION SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LIKE DID
YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP HEARING
HOPEFULLY ONE TABLE WHO WILL
NEED ONE IS MISTER HASTINGS WAS
TALKING YEAH I HOPE IT DOESN'T
TAKE TILL NEXT YEAR TO FIGURE
SOME OF THIS OUT AND
UNFORTUNATELY. YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
TESTIMONY MISTER HASTINGS. IF
YOU'RE ONE VALLEY OR ONE CANYON
YOU KNOW I THINK IT BE SOLVABLE
THE PROBLEM IS. THERE'S
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF I
MEAN EVEN THE DESTROYED LOOK AT
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
SANTA SUZANNA MOUNTAINS WHERE-WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT. SORT OF
MANUFACTURING ASSETS ALL
THROUGHOUT THE NORTH SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY BREWERIES
AEROSPACE YOU NAME IT FIND A
REASON GAS FIELD BY THE WAY
THAT NEEDS THE POWER ON TO
MAINTAIN SOME SAFETY OUT THERE.
AND IT'S ALL. IT'S ALL AT RISK
I WANTED TO ASK MS CABINETS
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE. I'M
THIS MADE HERE THAT YOU CAN
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND WE'RE
HERE ELEVEN YEARS LATER AND THE
SAME CONVERSATION IT'S
APPALLING AND UNACCEPTABLE AND
PEOPLE THAT YOU REPRESENT TOO
OFTEN ARE LEFT BEHIND I'M GLAD
THERE'S AN EMERGING COALITION
HERE OF. YOU KNOW BIG INDUSTRY
AND. PEOPLE WHO ARE TOO OFTEN
HIDDEN FROM VIEW IN THAT WE ALL
WE LEAVE BEHIND FAR TOO OFTEN I
WANT TO GET A SENSE THOUGH HOW
MANY PEOPLE DO YOU THINK. YOU
WERE GETTING AT THIS ISSUE OF
HOW DO YOU AREN'T BEING COUNTED
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE SCOPE OF
THE POPULATION THAT'S TRULY
RISK HERE YOU MENTIONED A F. N.
AS A SORT OF DESIGNATION.
ACCESS FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
HOUSEHOLDS. I THINK OBVIOUSLY
COULD BE BROADER THAN NAPA GIVE
A SENSE OF SORT OF COMPARING
WHAT YOU SEE IN A MINUTE
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMER.
NUMBER'S VERSES WHAT YOU SEE IN
THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
WHAT THE GAP COULD BE. I WISH I
HAD BETTER NUMBERS FOR YOU BUT
I CAN ONLY GIVE YOU CONCEPTS IN
RESPONSE. A MEDICAL BASS LINE
IS ONLY A TINY FRACTION OF THE
VULNERABLE AT RISK HOUSEHOLDS
AND IT'S NOT INTENDED AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. TODAY AS AN
EMERGENCY DESIGNATION MEDICAL
BASELINE AT ITS ESSENCE IS A
RATE. IT IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ELECTRICITY AT A
LOWER RATE FOR PEOPLE WHOSE
USAGE IS DRIVEN BY MEDICAL NEED.
AND THAT'S VERY APPRECIATED BUT
IT'S NOT AN IDENTIFIER FOR
PEOPLE WHO RELY ON ELECTRICITY
FOR HEALTH. JUST TO GIVE THE
MOST SIMPLE EXAMPLE THE PEOPLE
WHO RELY ON REFER TRADING THEIR
MEDICATION. IT DOESN'T DRIVE
ADDITIONAL ENERGY USAGE. AND
YET THEIR HEALTH IS VERY
DEPENDENT ON RELIABLE ENERGY SO.
THEN YOU ADD TO THAT THAT. EVEN
FOR THE POPULATION THAT WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE MEDICAL BASELINE IS
SEEMS TO BE VERY UNDER
SUBSCRIBED AND THE CPUC HAS
JUST FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
REALLY MANDATED THAT THE
UTILITIES DO A MORE AGGRESSIVE
OUTREACH PROGRAM TO ATTEMPT TO
ENROLL PEOPLE IN MEDICAL
BASELINE. ON THE OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES OF. PERHAPS THE
MAYOR WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER
PLACE TO SPEAK TO THIS CITIES
AND COUNTIES HAVE REGISTRIES OF
HOUSEHOLDS THAT THEY MAINTAIN
FOR EMERGENCY SITUATIONS OF
MEDICALLY FRAGILE I'M MORE OR
OTHERWISE IDENTIFIED VULNERABLE
OF CUSTOMERS ARE RESIDENTS AND
THOSE ARE ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE
LARGER THAN THE MEDICAL
BASELINE POPULATION SO ON THIS
SOME STRUCTURE TO COORDINATE
BETWEEN THE UTILITIES AND
COUNTIES TO EXCHANGE THOSE
LISTS AND I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT HIPPA. AND OTHER
PRIVACY REQUIREMENTS SO I DON'T
KNOW HOW EASY THAT WOULD BE BUT
THAT WOULD CERTAINLY EXPAND THE
UNIVERSE AND ONE POSSIBILITY
THAT I'VE RAISED AT CPAC
HEARINGS IS THE UTILITY IS
PROVIDING INFORMATION AND THEN
RESOURCES TO COUNTIES SO THAT
THE COUNTIES COULD USE THEIR
OWN LISTS WHICH WOULD AVOID THE
NEED FOR ACTUALLY EXCHANGING
INFORMATION BUT WOULDN'T SHIFT
THE BURDEN ENTIRELY TO THE
COUNTIES. TO NOW TAKE ON THIS
NOTIFICATION PROCESS. AGAIN I
AM WORKING IN THE ABSTRACT I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT WOULD REALLY
HELP THAT'S THE CONCEPT OF THE
UTILITIES PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES. AND THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS USE THEIR EXISTING
IDENTIFIERS OF VULNERABLE
HOUSEHOLDS AS A PRIORITY LIST I
THINK IT'S IS THE SMART IDEA
AND YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY SELF.
WELL AS A SUPPLEMENT IT
CERTAINLY SHOULD BE RELIED ON
AS WE ARE NOW BUT I DO THINK
PEOPLE WOULD BE MUCH MORE
WILLING TO SELF IDENTIFY IF
THEY KNEW. THERE COULD BE SOME
BENEFIT OF THEM DOING SO IN
OTHER WORDS THAT THERE MIGHT BE
A SOLUTION SO. IF YOU ARE
LIVING IN A NURSING ASSISTANT
FACILITY AND YOU KNOW THA IF
YOU AND YOUR FELLOW RESIDENTS
WHO LIVE THERE MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR. A DISCOUNT ON A
SOLAR BATTERY YSTEM TO BE
INSTALLED IF YOU GUYS JUST SIGN
UP AND CLICK ON. ON POWER DOWN
NOW THERE'S ACTUALLY SOMETHING
TO SAY LIKE YES WE HAVE A NEED
PEOPLE MIGHT ACTUALLY STEP
FORWARD AND START IDENTIFYING
THEMSELVES I KNOW I MEAN I
THINK OF WHAT. THE MTA COULD DO
SORT OF MORE COMPREHENSIVELY TO
ADDRESS YOUR VULNERABLE NEEDS
AND I LIKE I'M REALLY GLAD YOU
GOT THAT PROCESS STARTED THAT
INVENTORY IN BECAUSE IT'S- IT'S
EASIER TO COORDINATE. A BUNCH
OF YOU KNOW SORT OF LARGE
CRITICAL INDUSTRIES MUCH HARDER
HERE SOMEONE FROM MISTER MURDER
SHAW. I MEAN HOW QUICKLY COULD
YOU GO TO A CLIENT LIKE ONE OF
THESE AFN HOUSEHOLDS AND GET
UP. SMALL SCALE NOT BIG ENOUGH
TO NECESSARILY HANDLE A CEMENT
PLANT BUT SMALL ENOUGH TO
HANDLE YOUR TEN PEOPLE LIVING
IN NURSING IS ASSISTED
FACILITY. HOW QUICKLY COULD YOU
GET A SOLAR STORAGE PROJECT UP
AND RUNNING. BARRING ANY
COMPLICATIONS WITH THE
INTERACTION OR THE APPROVAL BY
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION. REMARKS
AT FOR YOU OKAY LET'S
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOU CAN BE
ANYWHERE FROM FROM WEEKS TO
MONTHS. BUT FOR SMALLER SYSTEMS
IT'S USUALLY ON THE ORDER OF
JUST A FEW MONTHS. AND SO ARE
YOU AWARE OF. SO THEY ARE
THEY'RE IMPEDIMENTS IN OTHER
WORDS TO GETTING THOSE SOLAR
STORAGE SYSTEM SAY UP AND
RUNNING IN FOR CUSTOMERS LIKE
THAT TO INTERCONNECT. GENERALLY
WHAT WE HEAR FROM OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES IS THAT BECAUSE
STORAGE IS STILL RELATIVELY NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHO.
HAVE JUST AND ARE VERY SLOW TO
APPROVE THE PERMITS EITHER
DON'T HAVE. OTHER QUALIFIED
PERSONNEL OR DON'T BELIEVE THEY
HAVE QUALIFIED PERSONNEL TO GO
OUT BECAUSE OF THE SUDDEN
ACCELERATION THE ADOPTION OF
STORAGE. SO JUST GETTING THE
PERMITS APPROVED HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE AND THEN FOR LARGER
SYSTEMS MAY BE A SYSTEM SERVING
A LARGE S. ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITY OR NURSING HOME. THAT.
YOU THEN CAN RUN INTO
INTERACTION CHALLENGES WITH
UTILITY BECAUSE UTILITY. BEING
CONSERVATIVE ORGANIZATIONS THEY
WANT TO ANALYZE THE IMPACTS OF
THE STORAGE UNIT ASSUMING THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO THAT IT
CHARGES AS RAPIDLY AS POSSIBLE
AT THE WORST POSSIBLE TIME. AND
VICE VERSA. SO THAT OFTEN
ENTAILS A COMPLEX ENGINEERING
REVIEW. SO WOULD STREAMLINED
PERMITTING PROCESS SEES THOUGH
HELP ESPECIALLY WITH HONORABLE
POPULATIONS YES. AND SO LAST
QUESTION HERE IS THAT THERE'S A
PERMITTING ELEMENT IS SORT OF
THE COORDINATION CYBER THERE'S
ALSO FINANCING ON IT THESE
THINGS COST MONEY AND EVERYONE
SENSITIVE TO ADDING MORE
PRESSURE ON TO THE RATE BASE OF
COURSE AND I GET THAT BOTH FORD
LARGE INDUSTRIAL USERS AS WELL
AS- YOU KNOW FIXED INCOME AND
USERS. ARE THERE OTHER REVENUE
STREAMS THAT WE CAN BE LOOKING
TO BEYOND THE RATE BASE TO HELP
SUPPLEMENT AND I'M THINKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT HEALTH
INSURANCE OR OTHER I. MEAN
CERTAINLY ON AN IN IS IN A
HAVE. ANY HOW DO WE GET
CREATIVE ABOUT COBBLING
TOGETHER FINANCING BECAUSE I.
I'D LIKE TO SEE A WILLINGNESS
FROM HIS LEGISLATURE TO STEP
UP. AND PUT A CHUNK OF FUNDING
FOR BEYOND THAT SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR STATE FACILITIES
FOR BACKUP POWER. TO REALLY DO
SOMETHING BIG HERE BUT- HOW DO
WE SORT OF. WHAT IS THE PRIVATE
STE WHAT COULD THE PRIVATE
STAKE LOOK LIKE IN THERE HOW
COULD WE PULL IN POTENTIALLY
OTHER CREATIVE REVENUE STREAMS
AND REALLY START TO. AT LEAST.
ELISE GET MOVING RIGHT WE MAKE
A BILL TO COVER EVERYONE AT
LEAST TO GET STARTED ANY ANY
THOUGHTS MISCAST. THIS IS NOT
MY AREA OF EXPERTISE AND SO ALL
I CAN TELL YOU IS STUFF THAT
I'VE BEEN READING OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS. BUT THERE IS.
CERTAINLY INTEREST AND.
MOVEMENT THAT I'M AWARE OF
ABOUT TRYING TO WORK WITH THE
LARGE PUBLIC INSURERS MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID NOW. TO SEE IF
THERE COULD BE OPTIONS FOR
COVERAGE ON THE SAME WAY YOU
WOULD COVER FOR EXAMPLE DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT. TO SAY
SOMEONE WHO NEEDS THAT
EQUIPMENT ALSO NEEDS THE
ABILITY TO SUSTAIN THAT
EQUIPMENT. DURING A TIME OF
DESTRUCTION I DO NOT PERSONALLY
HAVE INFORMATION ON WHETHER
THIS HAS ACTUALLY MOVED BEYOND
THE BRAINSTORMING STAGE AND
WHETHER THERE'S WORK ACTUALLY
UNDER WAY BUT I DO KNOW AT
LEAST IT IS. A CONCEPT THAT IS
THE SUBJECT OF THE INITIAL
DISCUSSION. RIGHT WE LOVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT AND
IS AND IS FAR FROM LIKE A CITY
OR- AT THE MUNICIPAL UTILITY
PERSPECTIVE. YOUR YOUR RATE
BASE IS OR YOUR RATE BASE OR
YOUR MARGINS HE SERVICES
BUDGETS AND ARE THESE THINGS%
YOU'RE YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF HOW DO YOU IDENTIFY
EVEN AT A MUNICIPAL LEVEL WHAT
YOU'RE CRITICAL ASSETS ARE AND
WHAT YOU CAN BE DOING NOTE TO
BACKSTOP THAT OR EVEN WITHIN
EAST BAY MUD I MEAN. YOU'RE
ALSO I MEAN WATER DISTRICTS
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WASTE DISTRICTS EVERYONE'S
LIABLE ALSO POTENTIALLY WE
HAVING LAWSUITS AGAINST LOCAL
WATER DISTRICTS IN VENTURA
COUNTY RIGHT NOW AFTER THOMAS
FIRE FOR THEIR PUMPS FAILING.
AT WHETHER DUE TO NEGLIGENCE OR
JUST WITHOUT ANY FAULT OF THEIR
OWN IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE GONNA
BE HELD LIABLE FOR HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF FIRE
DAMAGE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T GET
THEIR PUMP SYSTEMS GOING SO HOW
PROACTIVE. ART ARE YOU GUYS
ABLE TO GET IN TERMS OF GETTING
YOUR BUT YOU'RE SORT OF EITHER
RATE BASED OR GENERAL FUND
HEADED SOME. OF THE STUFF SO
YOU DON'T SEE THOSE BIG FAILURE
POINTS. THE PER HEALDSBURG
YOU'RE MORE THAN A DECADE AGO
THE CITY MAN AN EFFORT TO PUT
BACK UP GENERATION AND ALL OF
OUR CRITICAL FACILITIES FOR
POLICE DEPARTMENT FIRE
DEPARTMENT CITY HALL AT OUR
WATER FACILITIES WASTE WATER
FACILITIES SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
BACKUP GENERATION IT'S DIESEL
IT'S NOT CLEAN BUT IS THERE AND
AVAILABLE SO THAT WE CAN
PRODUCE WATER INTRIGUE WATER
AND THEN WE HAVE A FLEET OF
BOWL GENERATION THAT WE RUN
AROUND TO OUR VARIOUS
COLLECTIONS STATIONS PUMP
STATIONS TO KEEP THAT WATER
WASTEWATER. FACILITIES GOING
YOU KNOW IT IS DIESEL. TO BE
NICE TO HAVE A CLEANER
TECHNOLOGY I MEAN THE CONCEPT
OF BATTERY STORAGE IS A GREAT
IDEA. IN IN THE FACT THAT YOU
POTENTIALLY COULD USE A BETTER
STORAGE YEAR ROUND VERSUS JUST
A ONE TIME EVENT. WERE BACK OF
DIESEL GENERATION IT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING UNLESS YOU HOW THE
EVENT GOING ON THERE BUT- AGAIN
THE COST OF BATTERY STORAGE AND
THE SIZE OF THE UNIT SO WE
WOULD HAVE TO PUT INTO SUSTAIN
A FOUR DAY FIVE DAY. OUTAGE
THAT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
OVERCOME. SO WE DISCUSS REPAIRS
GENERAL FUND LIMITATIONS. THERE
WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME OTHER
FUNDING SOURCE TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN RIGHT NOW. AND THEN. IT
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT MICROGRAPH
PERTINENTES AS WELL FOR FIRE
STATIONS I KNOW WE'VE HAD A FEW
LA FIRE STATIONS THAT THE
PORTER RANCH AREA THEY JUST
GOTTA MICROGRAPH OF YOU GUYS
START LOOKING AT THAT. SO I DID
FALL SOME THE ARTICLES THAT
WERE ON THE FIRE STATION IN THE
MICRO GET THOSE PUT IN THERE
AND THERE WAS OF A FAIRLY LARGE
GRANITIC FROM THE CDC. THAT
THAT SUPPORTED THAT OPPORTUNITY
I'M NOT SURE THE SIZE OF THAT
BATTERY SYSTEM AND WITH THAT
SUSTAIN ANOTHER FOUR DAYS OF
SHUT DOWN I MEAN THAT'S THE
REAL CHALLENGES. A LOT OF THE
YOU KNOW IT HAS A WALL PACK AND
THOSE ARE REALLY. TWO TO FOUR
TO SIX HOURS AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT DAYS. OF OUTAGES AND SO.
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE FINDING THE RIGHT
SOLUTION FOR THE- FOR THE
PROBLEM YOU'LL CELLS. YOU'LL
CELLS AS AN OPTION YOU KNOW
SWITCHING FROM. DIESEL BACK UP
TO NATURAL GAS THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE WITH NATURAL GAS
IS DURING THE SENATE ROSE FIRES.
OUR ENTIRE CITY LOS NATURAL GAS
SERVICE. MY LAST COMMUNICATION
LESS NATURAL GAS SERVICES SO
EVEN THOUGH WE WEREN'T NESTLE
AFFECTED DIRECTLY BY THE FIRES
THOSE SERVICES WERE GONE DURING
THAT TWO TO THREE DAY PERIOD.
SO DEAL FUELING DURING THOSE
BACK UP SITUATION IS CERTAINLY
A MAJOR FOR DIESEL SIMILAR IS A
SIMILAR ISSUE IN MY STUPID
ANALOGY OF ME WITH A PICK UP
TRUCK CONVOY TRYING TO GET OUT
PCH WITH A BUNCH OF. RED YOU
KNOW PLASTIC JUGS OF DIESEL BUT
I MEAN THAT'S WHAT IT COMES
DOWN THAT'S THE REALITY OF IT
AND WE HAD SENATOR MCGUIRE
MAKING PHONE CALLS TO FEELING
COMPANIES TO GET FUEL INTO
HEALDSBURG SO THAT WE COULD
CONTINUE. TO RUN THROUGH THOSE
PROCESSES BUT. YEAH I THINK I
THINK BETTER SORTS NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF SOLUTION
BUT I THINK THERE FUNDING
THERE'S NEEDS TO BE FUNDING OR
SOME SIGNIFICANT COST REDUCTION.
REALLY BRIEFLY MEXICO JUST YES
WELL THANK YOU FOR ASKING SO I
IS IT RELATES TO THE BACK OF
POWER WE WENT WITH DIESEL FOR
THE PORTABLE APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH A HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE I'M NOT SURE IF YOU WERE
HERE I SO WE ARE UNDER THIRTY
FIVE PUMP. HI AT OUR-
MAIN FACILITIES LIKE OUR WASTE
WATER TREATMENT PLANT WILL THAT
WE HAVE THE GOOD FORTUNE THAT
TO. COULD BE RUN ENTIRELY ON
RENEWABLE ENERGY THAT WE
GENERATE AT THE PLANT SO WE
THINK THAT THAT IS A PRETTY
SAFE OPERATION. AT OUR WASTE
WHAT ARE EXCUSE ME IN OUR WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS SO WHICH WE
HAVE A NUMBER. ADD THOSE ALSO
HAVE YOU KNOW STATIONARY
GENERATORS THAT WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY. FEEL COMFORTABLE
THAT WILL BE IN A POSITION TO
KEEP THEM RUNNING. WE HAVE
REFINERS IN THE SERVICE AREA WE
HAVE ARRANGEMENTS PURCHASE
ORDERS A PRE ESTABLISHED TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE DIESEL THAT WE
NEED FOR OUR. GENERATOR SYSTEMS
IF YOU'RE A CREATIVE DISTRICT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING PATH BREAKING
WORK ON WASTE WATER TO ENERGY
AND EVER WASTE ENERGY AND- I
MEAN. DIESEL THAT'S REALLY
THAT'S THE WHOLE THAT'S THE
PLAN RIGHT NOW. WELL THAT IS
WHEN YOU'RE TOLD THAT YOU HAVE
TWELVE MONTHS AND THEN IT TURNS
OUT THAT DO BY THE TIME YOU
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S REALLY GOING
ON YOU HAVE SIX MONTHS RIGHT.
THE ONLY THING THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO THE TO WIN AND YOU'RE ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS
HOPEFULLY GOING TO GO AWAY AND
NOT BE THE SOLUTION FOR THE
FUTURE. YOU GO OUT AND YOU
LEASE THE GENERATORS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO MAKE THIS THING
YOU KNOW GET US THROUGH THIS
FIRE SEASON. HOME WE GET DONE
WITH THIS WE HAVE THE
EXPERIENCES AND WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION COULD UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S NEXT READ THE IN AND
WHEN THEY ARE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ARE DEVELOPED THAT ALLOW COST
EFFECTIVELY TO YES MASS STORE
SOLAR ENERGY. FOR FIVE TO SEVEN
DAY OUTAGES AT LEAST PUMPING
PLANTS AND WE PUSH. WATER UP
HILL IT'S HEAVY AND IT TAKES
LESS ENERGY TO. SO THE TO IF
WHEN THE TECHNOLOGY IS THERE
WILL BE FIRST IN LINE AS YOU
KNOW WE TRY TO BE ON THE
CUTTING EDGE OF THE FRONT FOR
SOME MONEY. TO INVEST PLEASE
LET US KNOW WE CAN DO TO HELP I
MEAN THAT'S THAT WE'VE GOT
WE'VE GOT A MONTH HERE. THERE
ARE LEGISLATIVE VEHICLES MOVING
IT TAKES AWHILE FOR THE PC TO
GET GOING. I DON'T REALLY WANT
TO WAIT FOR THE NEXT ROUND A
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS. TO
GET THIS PART THIS STARTED
BECAUSE THEY WERE. THEY JUST
APPROVED ON. AND THEY ADDS FROM
WHAT MY PERSPECTIVE IS POULTRY
MITIGATION STRATEGIES AS-
HAVING MODES OF MOBILE
GENERATION SYSTEMS ON TRUCKS TO
DRIVE AROUND AND I GUESS THEY
NEED TO DEPLOY THESE STRATEGIES
BUT. YOU KNOW SOME TRUCKS TO
GET THERE AFTER THE FACT OR
RESPONSE TO IT YOU KNOW AFTER
THE SYSTEM GOES DOWN IS
INSUFFICIENT SO I I'VE FOUGHT
THE UC AS MUCH AS THE TILL
THESE FOR THE INADEQUACY OF THE
STRATEGIES BUT I ALSO THINK.
THEY CAN GET CREATIVE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH US TO START TO
REMEDY THIS NOW BUT I JUST I
DON'T THINK WE CAN AFFORD TO
WAIT TILL JANUARY SO. LET'S
LET'S GET CREATIVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN YEAH THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND BE PART OF
THIS PANEL OF THE IT WAS A
GREAT DISCUSSION AND I THINK WE
LEARNED A LOT. TODAY SO THANK
YOU AND WILL NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT SO AT THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE TODAY
AS WELL
. SPEAKING OF THINKING
PEOPLE FOR THEIR PATIENTS HEY
YOU'RE AT THE END OF THE LINE
IN THE END OF THE AGENDA SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT AND- WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE SO. PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALLEY
CANNING TEN AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS HEARING TODAY I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS US
SEE A FILE SEE OR IT IS WHAT WE
CALL IT IS A STATE WIDE
MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION OF
TWENTY THREE INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS REPRESENTING FIFTY SIX
OUT OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE OUR MISSION IS
TO INCREASE ACCESS AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES BY INCREASING THE
CAPACITY OF INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS. INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS OR I'LL SEE YOU ARE RUN
BY AND FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES COLLECTIVELY THE
CENTERS SERVE OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND FOLKS WHO ARE
AGING AROUND THE STATE. FOLKS
WITH ALSO SOCIO ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS AND IDENTITIES THE
IOC'S ARE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND REACHING
US THEIR SELF DETERMINATION. AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING GOALS SO FOR
OVER TEN YEARS SEE IF I'LL SEE
AS PRIORITIZE DISASTER
READINESS AND MANAGEMENT FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE AGING
AND HAVE ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS. SO SEE IF I'LL SEE IS A
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP OF FOR DISASTER
STRATEGIES COALITION. AND SEE
IF I'LL SEE HAS OVER THE YEARS
HAVE PROVIDED SUPPORT HUNDREDS
OF INDIVIDUALS. IMPACTED BY THE
DISASTERS BY LOANING AND GIVING.
ALL MEDICAL EQUIPMENT ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS WHEEL CHAIRS
WALKERS A SPEECH DEVICES EXCEPT
TRUCK. SO ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY'RE FORCED TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMES AND WE HAVE PROVIDED
TRAINING AND SUPPORT TO IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND
FEMA DURING AND AFTER DISASTER.
WE CAN ALL SAY THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE PREVENTIVE MEASURES TO
MEDICAID DISASTERS SEE IF I WAS
HE BELIEVES THAT THE CPUC AS
WELL AS ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN
THIS NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
FIND SOLUTIONS THE CPUC. HAS
NOT INCORPORATED SYSTEMS AND
PROCEDURES THAT SUPPORT
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
AND THOSE WHO ARE AGING AND
REQUIRED THE DEVICES THAT WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT TODAY. AND I WON'T
GO DOWN THAT LIST BECAUSE I
THINK WE KNOW THEM BY NOW WHILE
YOU KNOW. THERE ARE. WHEN
THEY'RE THERE ARE SO MANY
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT WE CAN
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH
AND ESPECIALLY WITH THE POWER
SHUT OFF BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
AVAILABLE TO US TO US THEN
DURING A NATURAL DISASTER. SO
HOW ARE WE INFORMING PEOPLE
WITH ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL
NEEDS OF THIS THE ENERGIZED
ATION HOW'RE WE EVEN TELLING
FOLKS THAT THEY ARE A PART OF
THIS COMMUNITY I KNOW I DIDN'T.
AND SO HOW ARE HOW ARE WE
PROVIDING RESOURCES IN TRAINING
RECENTLY AT SEA OF FILES HE
PUBLISHED A VERY SHORT QUICK
SURVEY OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AN AGING COMMUNITY
ABOUT WHAT OUR NEEDS MAY BE
THIS IS A SMALL SAMPLE SIZE BUT
WE'RE HOPING THAT IT WILL HELP
INFORM. THE ACTIONS MOVING
FORWARD AS WE ARE THE EXPERTS
IN OUR OWN LIVES AND ARE AND
WHAT WE NEED I WAS SO WE ARE
BEGINNING TO SHARE THESE
RESULTS WITH THE STAKE WITH KEY
STAKEHOLDERS. AND WE- BY IN FAR
ARE COMMITTED TO AND THE ONLY
WAY FORWARD IS TO BRIDGE
PARTNERSHIPS WHICH I SEE IS
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. THANK YOU I KNOW I WENT
OVER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMING AND
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE TODAY
TO THINK IN THE COMMENTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK OU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
TODAY I REALLY APPRECIATE IT MY
NAME'S DANNY ANDERSON I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER OR
I'LL SEE IS ALLEY. MENTIONED
THAT COVERS INTEREST IN A
BARBER IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTIES. I AM I WAS STRUCK
TODAY BY THE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON LOCALLY
AND I THINK THAT SENATOR STERN
REALLY TOUCHED ON SOMETHING
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE-
EXPERIENCING IN OUR AREA WHICH
IS. THE LAYERS OF NEEDS WE TALK
ABOUT THE POWER SHUT OFF SEN.
AND I GETTHAT THAT WAS THE
MAIN SUBJECT TODAY BUT THERE'S
SO MANY OTHER NEEDS ASSOCIATED
TO WHEN WE HAVE A POWER SHUT
OFF WICH WE'RE DEALING WITH ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL. WE ARE
RECEIVING ALL THESE GUIDES FROM
THE COUNTY AND FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SAYING. HOW YOU CAN
PREPARE FOR THE POWER SHUT OFF
BUT THERE. IS AN INFORMATION
ABOUT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
WHO ARE LOW INCOME AND LIVE BY
THEMSELVES ARE NOT IN NURSING
FACILITIES LIKE ME I LIVE BY
MYSELF. I COULD NOT SET UP A
GENERATOR. I COULDN'T
PHYSICALLY DO IT I'M LUCKY I
HAVE FAMILY THAT WOULD COME
OVER AND HELP ME IF THAT'S WHAT
I HAD TO DO. BUT THAT'S NOT THE
STORY FOR EVERYONE SO WE'RE
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE. ON THAT WE
SERVE TO GET A DIFFERENT KIND
OF BACK UP SYSTEM THAT'S MORE
ACCESSIBLE. HOWEVER THESE GUYS
ALSO SAY THINGS LIKE. WELL
YOU'RE GOING TO GET NOTICED IN
TWO DAYS GO AND STAY WITH A
FRIEND. OKAY I CAN'T DRIVE I'M
RELY ON DIAL WRITER PARA
TRANSIT. I HAVE TO CALL AND
MAKE THAT RESERVATION A WEEK
AHEAD OF TIME. THERE'S NO WAY I
COULD EVEN GET TO MY FRIEND'S
HOUSE AND BY THE WAY WHEN I GET
TO MY FRIEND'S HOUSE CAN I GET
INTO MY FRIEND'S HOUSE CAN I
USE THE RESTROOM AT MY FRIEND'S
HOUSE. THESE ARE ALL THE LAYERS
THAT WE EXPERIENCE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR UNDERSTANDING
OF WHY WERE SO SCARED OF THESE
POWERS SHUT OFFS BUT REALLY THE
POWER SHUT OFF IS THE ROOT. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
COMPONENTS TO THE ISSUES FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. AND
ALSO IF I CAN JUST VERY
RESPECTFULLY. VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WE HATE THAT. SO IF
WE COULD BE CALLED PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES OR THOSE RELIANT
ON ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY. WE
WOULD APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
SOME THANK YOU FOR THE
SUGGESTION. AND IN THE COMMENTS
MUCH APPRECIATED TODAY NEXT THE.
VERY MUCH PHONE IN THIS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY YES
BYNARI BUT THAT THAT'S FINE MY
NAME IS CONNIE ARNOLD I LIVE IN
ELK GROVE. BEEN AN ADVOCATE FOR
DISABILITY RIGHTS FOR OVER
THIRTY PLUS YEARS. I'M HERE
BECAUSE- WHAT IS BEING DONE
WITH THESE WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS. IS TERRIBLE FOR PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES AND SENIORS
WHO ARE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
WHO ARE BEING LEFT BEHIND
AGAIN. BY A THIS CPUC AND THE
UTILITY COMPANIES AND BEING
TOLD TO PLAN FOR OUR OWN OUTAGE.
PLANS FOR PROVIDING OUR OWN
POWER NEEDS GO TO A HOSPITAL GO
TO A LOCAL SHELTER. THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE EXISTENT. AND THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE. IT'S REALLY
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THESE UTILITY
COMPANIES WHETHER THEIR PROFIT
OR PROFIT ORIENTED AND PRIVATE
OR PUBLIC TO ENSURE THAT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
VULNERABLE SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND AND SOMETHING NEEDS TO
HAPPEN LIKE PROVISION OF A
SOLAR POWER BACK UP RESIDENTIAL
BATTERY POWERED SYSTEM NEEDS TO
BE PROVIDED LIKE IT'S BEEN DONE
IN VERMONT. IN VERMONT. FOR TWO
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS BY GREEN
MOUNTAIN POWER. WHICH PROVIDED
A ONE TIME OF FEE CHARGE OF
FIFTEEN HUNDRED OR FIFTEEN
DOLLAR MONTH PAYMENTS. FOR
INDIVIDUALS AS WELL AS THE
VULNERABLE SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WERE GIVEN AT
NO COST. OF THE BACKUP BATTERY
BATTERY POWER SYSTEMS SOLAR
BATTERY POWER SYSTEMS. IT WHICH
WAS INSTALLED FOR THOSE
CUSTOMERS. SO. PEOPLE DO NOT
WANT TO BE GOING TO A HOSPITAL.
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES DO NOT
HAVE THE FUNDING TO SET UP
INTERMITTENT EMERGENCY SHELTERS
THAT PROVIDER NEEDS THERE ISN'T
A GOOD TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO GET OUR
POPULATION TO THOSE SITES
ASSUMING THE PERSON COULD MAYBE
THEIR BED RIDDEN. MAYBE THEY
THEY CAN'T EASILY BE
TRANSPORTED THERE ARE ALL THESE
OBSTACLES NOW I HAD A FRIEND
WHO LOST HER HOUSE. IN THE
PARADISE FIRE. HER AND HER
MOTHER. BARELY GOT OUT OF THAT
HOUSE. WITH WHAT THEY HAD AND
RUSHED TO THE CAR AND THE ONLY
NEW THERE WAS A FIRE BECAUSE
THEY COULD FEEL THE HEAT FROM
THE HOUSE ON FIRE NEXT DOOR.
AND THEIR HOUSE PARISH. AND
THEY BARELY MADE IT OUT THERE
WERE A LOT OF SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES THAT
DIED IN THAT FIRE AND I FOR ONE
DO NOT WANT TO BE PUT IN THAT
PREDICAMENT. SO THE IT'S
ALREADY BEEN STATED THAT YOU
KNOW WE RELY ON ELECTRIC
WHEELCHAIRS I HAVE AN ELECTRIC
BED I HAVE AN ELECTRIC AIR
MATTRESS. I EIGHT NEED AIR
CONDITIONING I CAN'T TOLERATE
SUPER HE- SUPER COLD THE WHOLE
NINE YARDS SO. THERE'S PEOPLE
WITH HOME ELEVATORS ALL OF A
SUDDEN THE ENERGY COULD JUST BE
SHUT OFF AND THEIR STOCK. AND
THEIR TRAP ORDER SENIOR
CITIZENS OR PEOPLE DISABILITIES
THAT DON'T KNOW HOW TO MANUALLY
OPEN THEIR GARAGE DOOR. NOR CAN
THEY DO THAT. AND I FOUND IT
VERY INTERESTING. YOU KNOW THAT
AND ARTICLES WRITTEN RECENTLY
BY EIGHT ON NORTH BAY BOHEMIAN
CALLED USED ABOUT THE P.
JEANNIE AND HOW MUCH MONEY THEY
POURED INTO SOME OTHER
FOUNDATIONS. AND I THINK IT'S
TIME FROM THAT ARTICLE THAT THE
PRIVATE UTILITY COMPANIES BE
TAKEN OVER AND BECOME PUBLIC
UTILITIES BECAUSE IT CONCERNS
ME IF LEGISLATORS ARE MEMBERS
OF THE C. P. C. P. YOU SEE ARE
BEING WINED AND DINED. BY SOME
OF THESE. C. E. O.'S. YOU KNOW
THAT HOW DOES THAT HOLD THE
PUBLIC INTEREST AT HEART OF THE
COMMISSIONERS OR- YOU KNOW
MEMBER CENTER ACCEPT CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS HOW DOES THAT HOW
DOES THAT HELP US SO I MEAN THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT NOT ONLY
SHOULD A BACKUP RESIDENTIAL
BATTERY POWERED SYSTEM BE
PROVIDED BUT ALSO NOT KNOX BOX
UNITS COULD BE INSTALLED THAT
ONLY EARLY MERCHANTS HE
PARAMEDICAL PEOPLE. X. WOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO A PERSON'S HOME
AND I HAD TO SIT HERE AND LAUGH
WHEN I HEARD P. JEANNIE STATE.
THAT THEY SEND A TRUCK OUT IF
THEY CAN'T REACH YOU. BUT IF
THE PERSON CAN'T GET OUT OF BED
AND DOESN'T COME TO THE DOOR
THEY JUST LEAVE A- LITTLE
HANGER ON THEIR DOOR THAT THEY
WERE THERE. THIS SIDE WE DO
HAVE YOUR LETTER. THAT YOU KNOW
YOU GOT MY LETTER IS SO YEAH.
ADD FIVE LETTERS AND I JUST
WANT TO STATE SOMETHING MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE I DID LIKE TO
HEAR SOME PEOPLE SAYING. ARMS
IF THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
CAN'T BE DESIGNATED FOR FUNDING
FOR THE SOLUTIONS WE NEED
SOLUTIONS TO THESE PROBLEMS WE
WILL DO THAT AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING TO AN THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU. HE SURE TO MAKE
SURE I ONLY HAD FIVE WILL MAKE
FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS I HAD A
PRINTER PROBLEM AT THE END.
WE'LL TAKE CARE OF IT FOR IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING TODAY. MISTER CHAIR
ADD CORPS IN JENSEN ON BEHALF
OF TECH NET FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
pIMPORTANT TO DISCUSS. ON THE
IMPACTS OF THE INTERNALIZATION
WILL HAVE ON CALIFORNIANS AND
ALSO CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESSES
TECHNIQUES DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP
INCLUDES ADVANCE ENERGY
COMPANIES AND ALSO TECH AND
TELECOM COMPANIES WHO ARE
DEPENDENT ON ON INTERRUPTED
ENERGY SUPPLIES. OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES DEPEND ON A LEVEL OF
LIABILITY OF RELIABILITY THAT
THE GREAT HAS SOMETIMES
STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE. NOW IS THE
INTERNALIZATION AND POTENTIALLY
IMPACTING MAJOR PORTIONS OF
CALIFORNIA WE NEED MORE TOOLS
LIKE SOLAR AND MICROGRAMS. A
LOSS OF POWER CAN HAVE CREATES
VERY SERIOUS SAFETY CONCERNS
BUT ALSO VERY SERIOUS FINANCIAL
IMPACT OUR MEMBER COMPANIES BUT
ALSO CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL
ECONOMY. THIRTY DIESEL BACKUP
GENERATORS CANNOT BE THE TOOL
RE REACH FOR TECH NET URGES
SUPPORT FOR ELECTRICITY
SUPPLIES THAT ARE ABLE TO RIDE
THROUGH OUTAGES AND RESTORE THE
SYSTEM MORE RAPIDLY AFTER AN
OUTAGE INCLUDING RENEWABLE AND
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY SOURCES.
MICROGRAPHS ARE ONE SUCH
SOLUTION THAT CAN ALLOW MEMBER
COMPANIES TO MANAGE THEIR
ENERGY NEEDS AND DO SO
SUSTAINABLY. WE NEED TO SET
RULES FOR MICROGRAMS AND ENSURE
THAT ENERGY CUSTOMERS ARE
EMPOWERED TO BE PART OF THE
STATE'S OVERALL EFFORTS TO
MANAGE CLIMATE IMPACTS. AND
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR HELLO MY NAME IS
ALLEY TRAIL AND I'M AN
INDEPENDENT CLEAN ENERGY AND
SUSTAINABILITY PROFESSIONAL AND
SUSTAINABILITY ACADEMIC. I WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST IN THE WORLD
TO RECEIVE AN ACCREDITED
BACHELORS DEGREE OF
SUSTAINABILITY AT THE GLOBAL
INSTITUTE OF. SUSTAINABILITY AT
ARIZONA STATE WAS RANKED NUMBER
ONE IN INNOVATION AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. I WHAT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND ALSO THE P. YOU SEE
FOR ADDRESSING RESILIENCY IN
THE ASTOR PROCEEDING THAT'S ON
GOING RIGHT NOW. AND BUILDING
ON WHAT OTHERS TOUCH ON EARLIER
I REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF MY GRADES IS A
CRITICAL SOLUTION TO MITIGATING
IMPACTS PSCS ARE COMMUNITIES.
RESILIENCY IS INHERENTLY LOCAL
AND MICRO GRIDS CAN PROVIDE
LOCAL SUPPORT ACROSS THE STATE
IN A DISTRIBUTED FASHION. THE
DEAL WE AND AN INDUSTRY
ACCEPTED DEFINITION OF MY
GRADES IS A GROUP OF
INTERCONNECTED LOADS AND
DISTRIBUTE ENERGY RESOURCES
WITH A CLEARLY DEFINED
ELECTRICAL BOUNDARIES. THAT ACT
AS A SINGLE CONTROLLABLE ENTITY
WITH RESPECT TO THE GRAD AND
CAN DISCONNECT AUTONOMOUSLY.
MICROGRAPH OUR TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL THEY HAVE A WIDE
VARIETY OF GENERATION STORAGE
AND CONTROLS THAT CAN BE PART
OF THE MAKER GREG. SO I URGE
MIKE LAWMAKERS AND POLICY
MAKERS TO CREATE POLICIES THAT
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SPECIFICALLY AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES TO PARTNER WITH
DEVELOPERS TO CONSTRUCT THESE
RESILIENCY PROJECTS. A TYPICAL
COMPREHENSIVE ENERGY PROJECT
THAT MIGHT HAVE HVAC LIGHTING
AND MY GROUP CONTROLS COST
ANYWHERE FROM THREE TO TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DEPENDING ON THE
SIZE OF THE PROJECT. THE
MICROCOMPUTER INS FOR RECENT
PROJECT COST ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADD TO THE PROJECT.
SO A REAL EXAMPLE COULD BE A
CITY THAT HAS A COUPLE
COMMUNITY FACILITIES DESIGNATED
SCHOOLING IS OWNED BY THE
UTILITY. THIS KIND OF PROJECT
THAT I'VE JUST READ ABOUT IS
TEN MILLION DOLLARS. ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE A
COMPONENT WITH HISTORIC
INTEREST RATES THESE PROJECTS
CAN BE FINANCED WITH TO HELP
STE WHICH IS TAX EXEMPT LEASE
PURCHASES AND OTHER FINANCING
VEHICLES THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
DEVOTED TO PUBLIC AGENCIES.
THREE POINT 1% INTEREST. THAT
IS MUCH CHEAPER THAN WHAT SOME
OF THE OTHER ENTITIES ARE
PROPOSING THEIR INTEREST RATES
BE NOW. SO THESE ARE TYPICALLY
TWENTY YEAR AGREEMENTS THEY
HAVE NO CAPITAL OUTLAY AN
IMMEDIATE SAVINGS OVER NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
THESE PUBLIC AGENCIES. I JUST
TALK WITH THE AGENCY LAST WEEK
THAT SIDE THEY'RE RENTING
TWENTY NINE DIESEL GENERATORS
AT A COST OF FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR FOUR
MONTHS. THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
FUEL OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
COSTS ANYTHING ELSE THAT MIGHT
BE NEEDED OR HAVE THESE
GENERATORS OPERATE SAFELY AND
EFFICIENTLY. SO IF YOU REALLY
THINK ABOUT THAT YOU MIGHT AS
WELL INVESTED MIKE REGRETS FOR
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES SO I'M
REALLY HAPPY TO VOLUNTEER TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE MORE
ON THIS AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR ATTENTION THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY WE SHOULD. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON NOT
YOUR MOM ON BEHALF OF CAPSTONE
TURBINES. CAPTAIN OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURER OF
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY MAKER
TURBINE. MAC MICROTURBINES.
SERVING MEDIUM AND LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS AND MORE CLEAN AND
EFFICIENT SOFT GENERATIONAL
TURN IT IS. THE STATE SHOULD BE
DOING MORE TO INCENTIVIZE
MEDIUM LARGE ENERGY CONSUMERS.
THAT ARE INVESTING IN
TECHNOLOGY AND EQUIPMENT FOR
RESILIENCY TO MAKE THE CLEANEST
WAYS POSSIBLE ALREADY THERE'S A
SELF GENERATION CENTER PROGRAM
BUT THERE'S MORE THAT WE CAN
DO. FEED IN TARIFF PROGRAMS CAN
BE EXPANDED TO ALL CLEAN AND
EFFICIENT DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION TECHNOLOGIES. FALLS
AXTEL TRUNCHEON PROGRAMS AT THE
TREASURES OFFICE CAN BE
EXPANDED. WE THINK THAT THE
CHEN THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD ACT
BEFORE YOU RETURN. BECAUSE THE
BETTER THE SOONER THE THAT A
CONSUMERS CAN START MAKING
CLEAR. CHOICES THE BETTER
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON I AGREE HEARING
PANELISTS ARE REALLY HEALTHY
DISCUSSION MY NAME IS WILL
ABRAMS ALSO PARTY TO THE IDEA
JERSEY XIN PROCEEDING BEFORE
THE CPUC. RESIDENT A CINEMA
COUNTY AND WHILE FIRST RUBBER
SO WITH THESE ISSUES ARE
PERSONAL TO ME. ARM AND I JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS THAT I THINK
THAT THE WAY TO REALLY APPROACH
THIS IS A SORT OF A SOLUTION
ORIENTATION. IS FOR PAPER FOR
PERFORMANCE SO A LOT OF WHAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING THE UTILITIES
IS ACTIVITIES THESE THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT WE WILL DO. SO
LIKE COMMUNICATIONS SHOULDN'T
MATTER TO ANY OF US IN THIS
ROOM IF THEY SAID MAILERS OR
THEY HAVE A SUPERBOWL AD IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY COMMUNICATE
ALL THOSE THOSE ARE THE TYPES
OF THINGS THAT THEY DESCRIBE
THAT THE FREE SHOULDER
CUSTOMERS. WHAT WE CARE ABOUT
OUR CONSUMERS EDUCATED HAVE THE
DO THEY KNOW HOW TO RUN THE
GENERATOR WITHOUT CAUSING A
FIRE DO THEY KNOW HOW TO RUN.
EXTENSION CORDS SO BEING ABLE
TO. COMPENSATE THEM AND PAY FOR
PERFORMANCE AROUND ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS I SEE IS
REALLY THE ONLY WAY THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE RIGHT
MOTIVATION. TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND THAT
GOES FOR DE ENERGISED ATION
ISSUES BUT ALSO GENERALLY
SPEAKING WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
ISSUES. AND UNTIL WE START
PRYING RETURN ON EQUITY FOR OUR
RETURN ON INVESTMENT ALL THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS. ARE RATE PAY
REIMBURSEMENT UNTIL WE START
TYING THOSE THINGS TO EACH AND
EVERY MITIGATION. I DON'T SEE
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SEE A PATH FORWARD SO THAT'S
RELATING TO KEY AS WE LOOK
FORWARD. AND I HAVE A NUMBER OF
COMMENTS AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUBMIT TOWARDS THAT WOULD BE
GREAT WE APPRECIATE IT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO READING THEM SO
PLEASE DO. THANK YOU THINK AT
OTHERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
CNN NO ONE WILL OF. WHAT THIS
WAS A ONE FOUR HEARING TODAY A
LITTLE LONG FOR OF MANY OF US
BUT- I THINK WE'VE REALLY. CAN
SEE WHERE THE HILL. THIS IS ONE
WILD FIRE MITIGATION TOOL
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AN
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET IT RIGHT.
IN A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE TAKING
STEPS TO GET THERE AND TO MAKE
IT RIGHT AND I THINK THAT THE
REAL PROCESSES OF THE CPUC IS.
THERE CONSIDERING MANY OF THESE
CONCERNS IN THAT NEXT PHASE OF
THE PC PS PS PROCEEDINGS AND-
AND I URGE THE CPUC TO TAKE UP
THESE ISSUES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE THE ONE THING
WE ARE TODAY. IS THAT THIS
ISN'T URGENT AND TIMELY MANNER.
MATTER THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. SO THAT WE CAN GET
IT AS RIGHT AS POSSIBLE SO THE
ANSWERS TO MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS RAISED. A CANNOT
WAIT. UNTIL ALL THE FACTORS ARE
KNOWN WITH CERTAINTY WE MUST
CREATE AN INTER FROST SAYS.
THAT CAN GET US TO WHERE WE CAN
HAVE A SAFE SYSTEM. A BALANCED
SYSTEM AND ONE THAT WILL WORK
FOR ALL OF US AND THAT WE CAN
REFINE IT OVER TIME THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU
FOR A STAFF AND I WANT TO MAKE
THIS PARTICULAR THANKS PEOPLE
WERE MENTIONING HEALTH THOROUGH
THE- THE BACKGROUND PAPER WAS.
AND I WANT TO THANK OF ALARM IF
WILLIAMS. WHO IS SITTING TO MY
LEFT FOR HER GREAT WORK TODAY
IN CREATING THAT CRAFTING IT.
PUT IT TOGETHER SHE'S THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND ALSO MY CHEEK. AFTER THANK
YOU. LORD FOR GREAT JOB THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE HERE
INTEGER